this will be a lengthy introduction and
I hope that you don't skip it because I
have several important messages but if
you would like to then as usual you can
click in the timestamp or over here
there's the time code man oh man this
was months in the making this is the
culmination of the variety of
outstanding guests previous guests on
tow new guests since the beginning all
in one jam-packed monstrous eight and a
half hour live stream the guest list is
so large I'm just gonna have to read
this they include Michael Levin Don
Hoffman Carlos from The semf Institute
Andy from that UFO podcast Dan from that
UFO podcast Gary Nolan John verakee
Christina Gomez avilobe Jack from asking
anything Bernardo Castro Artisan Tony
Professor abai ashtakara physics Kevin
knuth of physics Anthony mativier George
Knapp Jeremy Corbell Lillian dindo Greg
henriks Grant Cameron and Jesse
Mitchells some of the physics and
Consciousness explication contests
either honorable mentions or winners
they've showed up as well Daniel Varga
James Sirois Alexei the memes of
Destruction Dr shosh B Jones Square
nephe Hermanson Richard Dolan Dr Brian
Keating himself Brad from Sonic gravity
Matt O'Dowd Tyler Goldstein Nikolai
Peterson nud Sorensen Ross coldheart
alien girl Rich from gaffon Garrett
Vandenberg Chris Leto Daniel from active
inferenced Institute Lou Angelus Robert
Lawrence Kuhn comb Kelleher and Daniel
schmotenberger rarely do you have large
names in the physics mathematics
Consciousness UFO space in an
agglomeration with other podcasters who
have low thousands or even low tens of
YouTube subscribers in the same place
this Virago was intentional on my part
as unlikely interming anglings are not
only in the mirthful holiday spirits but
something I personally would love to see
more of YouTube is an incredibly
competitive space and YouTubers don't
like to mention one another they don't
like to boost one another up generally
speaking especially as they get larger
and so this is my way of bucking that
Trend there's also that video of the 40
smaller channels in the Consciousness
math physics and UFO space I also plan
on doing a follow-up on that in about a
month or so highlighting some more
channels if you've run a podcast before
you'd realize it's extremely difficult
to schedule even one of these guests let
alone to get several guests from
disparate Fields with prodigiously
contrasting perspectives to speak to one
another let alone getting smaller
podcasters alongside with them when
creating this we didn't realize that
nothing like this had been attempted
before but from reading the chat and
speaking with some of the guests
afterwards we were made known that this
is inadvertently historic and that's not
tooting toe's horn it's this way because
of the guests so thank you thank you to
all the people mentioned above and thank
you to all those who I had invited but
had forgotten to send a link to or
simply forgot to invite it was a much
more unzipped and vexing time than I
thought tremendously more because of the
success tonanza will be a yearly
tradition maybe even semi-annually in
the original stream on December 30th
2022 roughly 1 000 people were watching
at any given moment and in total 17
000 eyes and ears were watching and
listening with excitement for this cast
of Brilliant Minds thank you for making
this possible this was a great deal of
fun for me in fact you'll see a much
more relaxed and temperately more zany
Kurt that is decidedly different from
the laser focused researched and
hopefully incisive Kurt from the
ordinary tow podcasts this is in part
due to my constant theme of lassitude
and insomnia but also because I
purposefully didn't prepare any
questions nor even frame of mind the
vibe of tonanza is meant to be that of a
pub where you invite a mishmash of
people regardless of their opinion of
one another and see what conversation
emerges in a relaxed fashion without a
pre-ordained agenda to everyone who
joined the live stream I'm super super
grateful to you watching now I'm super
grateful to you listening now or reading
now I'm grateful when Topher started I
had no idea where it would be I still
don't know where it's going but watching
you all warms my heart gives me hope
that conversations like this actually
affect a change hopefully in a positive
direction thank you to blinkist who
sponsored tonanza without them this
wouldn't have happened so thank you
blinkist in the time that we live toe
aims to be at the cusp of Cutting Edge
research so that's scientific knowledge
or otherwise we at least attempt to
integrate some of the best tools into
Tow and then as a result we get to pass
on some of those recommendations to you
blinkist is one such exhortation as an
extremely powerful idea curator they
Source the sharpest Minds from
non-fiction titles showcasing key ideas
main takeaways and full-length
audiobooks all from one app I recently
discovered blinkist and I'm extremely
impressed the largest bottleneck or one
of the largest bottlenecks at tow is the
research process and blinkist helps
expedite that process drastically they
have titles like the 5 a.m Club Rich Dad
Poor Dad Atomic habits and Think and
Grow Rich their catalog saves so much
time that would otherwise be spent in
Desperate Jarred research blinkus
condenses the essence of thousands of
books and gathers insights by searching
for some of the most impressive titles
most impactful titles and working with
the authors or experts to give you a 15
minute bit called blinks by the way this
is enjoyed by over 18 million people
worldwide with blinkist you can improve
your professional skills discover
non-fiction titles authors and podcasts
to enhance your Velton and for you
special premium users you can now share
your account with another account for no
additional cost get 25 off blinkist
premium and enjoy two memberships for
the price of one start your seven day
free trial by clicking here blinkist.com
Partners slash theories dash of Dash
everything the link of course will be in
the description and the comments section
also thank you to the video editor who's
diligently working right now editing
this thank you also to Sam who's working
again diligently around the clock on
various aspects of toe including being a
DJ today with the sound effects as well
as dealing with the coordination of the
different guests speaking with them
behind the scenes and most of all thank
you to my wife who for whatever reason
puts up with all my nonsense and these
arduous 100 hour a week schedules thank
you to you watching this reading this
listening to this Welcome to the New
Year and welcome to this eight and a
half hour Behemoth live stream tonanza
foreign
[Music]
it's just this for about eight hours so
welcome to this countdown I'm Luke
that's a joke don't worry
all right
man
hey how's it going everyone
good to see you all here
so Sam is going to be the DJ today he's
over here I have no idea what sounds
he's gonna play
so just forgive me
all right that's one of them I'm going
to be sitting on this ball so in case
you hear some creaking that's what this
is
we're in a new place
plenty that's happened this year so
what's going on with you all are you
excited for eight hours
hold on I can't even keep up with this
oh this is a person who is going to be
on much later
it's a sneak preview
plenty of guests today who's coming on
first should be Ian mcgilchrist so if
you have any questions for him
ask in the chat
I'll give you a rundown
so much of these are meant to be
surprises I will be brief I will be
incomplete John ravaki is coming up
Hoffman's coming up Michael Levin and
John and Donald Hoffman are coming up I
think together Gary Nolan should be
coming up after that or even
simultaneously
several other podcasters and people with
their own channels are coming up Avi
Loeb
Lillian dindo so that's a that's an
episode of the toe podcast about
treating treating anxiety with ACT
therapy
we're also
we're also going to announce
hold on
we're also going to announce the winners
of the physics and Consciousness
explication contest
later we'll do a full video
about it but for now we'll just announce
them and then at that point that'll come
on around 4 P.M at that point we'll also
announce so in addition to the winners
we'll announce the honorable mentions so
those that like almost
almost all of these people should have
won but it's it's
so difficult and like honestly you're
all winners in my heart and I I don't
even I'm not kidding I mean that as a
joke right now but I I do mean it as I
do mean
so
well we'll have so much fun
this is this is this is super fun me
Sam our adrenaline has been going on for
the past
hour just
not only dealing with many technical
issues but then seeing the chat here
holy moly
[Music]
thank you all thank you all
Mick West no no so there are plenty of
people that I've forgotten to give
invites to
simply because this has been such a
frantic effort and it's been
it's been way more it took way more
time and energy to produce than we
thought this was just supposed to be a
live stream that I give it I give out a
code to to several people like everyone
essentially but I've forgotten you can't
remember everyone and so some people
I've forgotten so Mick
please message me on Twitter and I'll
give you the link to come on okay
and this will be a common theme I'll say
over and over if I've forgotten you
please message me and also if I don't
get to the Twitter because Mick it's
just difficult there's so much there's
so many messages if I don't get you on
then we'll have some other conversation
so Bobby where is the kitchen we have
moved
toe will be sometimes in the kitchen so
sometimes at home but now we have an
office and because thanks to you thanks
to you all we have a dedicated video
editor who's editing over here we have
an operations manager who's serving as
the jockey right now wears multiple hats
and we're just hammering away toe in
person so that we can bring some high
quality super high quality podcasts even
more in-depth we have so much so many
more plants
and
and we hope to do that more often next
year T car T car says congrats on the
new office I will match dollar for
dollar any donations on this channel up
to 1000 us and he donated 100 already
thank you
[Music]
thank you
let me put on some music for that
just so you know
something I try to do with toe is make
sure that music is almost never
Incorporated and loud sounds are not
Incorporated and if they are they're not
loud because many people listen to this
podcast as they go to sleep
and I know what it's like to be
listening to something that you think is
relaxing it's somewhat stimulating but
it's not terribly stimulating such that
you can't sleep and and you're just
about to fall asleep and then all of a
sudden there's a car crash or they cut
to someone else's video and if they're
not they haven't mixed their audio
levels properly
so
that's something to keep in mind about
all new toe episodes all toe episodes
from 2022 forward
will be mixed such that you can listen
to them
as you sleep
thank you
[Music]
Austin thank you fifty dollars thank you
Austin wow holy moly
[Music]
thanks Jake
[Music]
that is that is correct Mt Daniel
schmattenberger will be making an
appearance
[Music]
let's bankrupt t-car
[Music]
okay while we're waiting while we're
waiting and this is not even waiting
this is the show
there are
there's plenty to promote so there's the
Discord if you want to continue
conversations on toes and go in depth
conversing with other people then
there's the Discord link I will leave
that somewhere just a moment that's in
every episode
it has the Discord Link in
the description
as well as the link to the subreddit
which I will also link
there's also a subreddit of memes Kurt
gymungal memes
[Music]
and if you would like to contribute on a
monthly basis and support the channel
then there's the patreon so patreon.com
let me place that on this as well
[Music]
so Shawna thank you thank you so much
okay
[Music]
ah okay so they're popping in and out of
the Smite let's see let me bring this
down a bit
okay how about this is this mixed okay
again this is all the pre-show
[Music]
as soon as Ian comes in that's when it
starts that's when the game Begins the
tow game
we're just so exhilarated here
Todd thank you thank you so much thank
you all for the support thank you all
for watching for the past year it's been
astounding and outstanding all right
Mike who says I'm not that's the famous
Einstein experiment you can't tell if
you're in an elevator
[Music]
again if I've forgotten an invitation
message me DM me on Twitter the DMS are
open it's tow with Kurt so add Toe with
Kurt
I'm dealing with plenty of messages
simultaneously
recently
speaking of chat
there's been
oh recently
that's a moment come on
wow okay just a moment just a moment
people
wish hey that like every single dollar
helps please never say that you wish you
could give more what you give
even if it's 10 cents that helps a
tremendous tremendous amount it doesn't
sound like it
but it does thank you thank you and it
helps even especially in terms of morals
morale sorry morals morale it helps in
terms of morale
twenty dollars thank you thank you 10
pounds thank you
the current conversion rate that's like
a thousand Canadians so thank you
what topics will you deal with we're
just today this is just meant for myself
for Sam for you all for the guests this
just meant for us to relax I'm sure
you'll notice that I'm
I much less tense there's less
well there is delirium in me but there's
less agitation in me than usual because
I'm not there's not much pressure this
is just meant for us to have a festive
night and also also I like to go long I
love long podcasts so okay no sandwich
I like to go along
all right I like it I like to go along I
do and
often it's the podcast guess who runs
out of stamina but that again like I'm
not saying that is that a
as any Testament to my stamina it's just
that I have a much easier job as the
person asking questions but the point is
I like to continue I can go for 14 hours
I would love to do a 14 hour podcast
anyway this is close this is eight hours
so maybe we'll see how I'm looking by
the end of this it'll be great to see a
shot by shot comparison
UAP UK thank you thank you thank you
wow thank you thank you John me burger
or Nye Burger looking forward to having
a great time today and a great 2023
thanks for everything Kurt thank you
thank you John gave 50 that's a
thank you
okay I'm gonna take off this music
[Music]
let's do this this time
yeah
yeah let's all jump into bed to love
large fluffy bed
but get your mind out of the gutter it's
not you're not gonna be that lucky not
like that just let's relax that I should
have said large Comfy Couch
so Prince wants to know what topics
we're dealing with this year and again
there are several several
huge plans
I'm curious what you all would like to
see explored more of
and what you'd like to see explored
that's different so that's not been
explored until
Lisa thank you thank you so much
Tony
Tony Tony's a Creator himself and Tony
will be on later thank you thank you
Tony
Rasik thank you
Matthew Tableau Talbot I apologize thank
you thank you wow Matthew says I've
never given to any podcaster but you're
different thank you for doing this
that's that's like
just like just I I just feel So Unworthy
and so lucky thank you thank you
foreign
oh don't worry just even saying even
just just we're us all like
it's so difficult I want to say thank
you but I feel like that's so impersonal
because I'm saying it to an audience and
I I want to I'm just gonna say thank you
to the different people's names who show
up I don't like to deal with the large
groups so day a DA ah thank you a thank
you Matthew thank you Emmanuel thank you
tikar thank you Charlie thank you
Leandro thank you gnome hey
hey thank you Kenneth thank you Tony
thank you jalapeno Matthew
can't pronounce that I can't I'm sorry
so
one
hint thank you Andrea PNF again hi din
thank you Rick thank you goon thank you
shoshana thank you and see you soon
Prince thank you again Stephen thank you
Vincent thank you Phil thank you sneaky
toaster thank you Arjun thank you thank
you
Elver thank you
MF Damien digging the high energy Kurt
thank you Tommy thank you Kenneth thank
you it's me Luigi thank you
towel towel
answers for everything by 2027. I have
this feeling people make plenty of
well there's plenty of attention paid to
prodigies like child prodigies but I
tend to
adore respect and learn more from people
who much later in life came to something
like math or physics so that is when
they're 30 or 40 or even 50. for myself
I don't feel like I'll have a belt on
channel until I'm 57 and I think that's
okay I think that there's something at
least for me there's something honest
about that there's something premature
about having it before you're well while
you're in your 20s and something that
the PHD that the sorry that the academy
does to you is they get you to do some
research for your PhD when you're in
your 20s when you're in your creative
Prime and when you're in your early 30s
which is when you should be evaluating
several other ideas rather than pursuing
a single one that you've chosen based on
some based on based on your research or
your professor so then you've inherited
their biases
I think that you should do your PhD when
you're 50. anyway chops citizen thank
you Vincent thank you speed thank you
Archangel arc angel thank you
Gangsta thank you Indiana thank you
Daniel thank you
Tommy thank you
wow wow wow kyleen thank you so right
now we're waiting for Ian mcgilchrist
and this whole stream is not just going
to be thank yous though I would love it
to just be eight hours of thank yous
because I do thank you all and anyone
who comments over the next two minutes
I'm going to thank you personally with
your name can't continue that the whole
show gotta pay attention to guests
but anyway this is going to be like I
mentioned relaxed I don't have an agenda
specifically we have an itinerary so
that is we have some guests scheduled
but I have no questions for them I don't
want questions for them this is meant to
be like a public house like a pub you
come in and it's mirthful and it's happy
and it's euphoric and
and that's enough
kyleen says thank you so much for your
content thought provoking interesting
it's giving me so many jumping off
topics looking forward to supporting you
in the new year
Artisan Tony's interview with Lou
Elizondo was very much was a very much
sorry was very much a missed gem
everyone needs to watch it
that comes from Mike
Laura 57 I'm 57 yeah
props to all the 57 people
there's something special about the
number 57 157 in particular
that's my favorite number
James R crypto thank you speaks thank
you Zayden thank you
John again thank you PNF ah aye PNF
you're 57 great
go to scroll all right that's an
interesting name thank you Baff on me
baffon met bath omit thank you
Andrew asking anything with Jack thank
you
okay late thank you
ezox thank you
I don't I know the IQ so fluid IQ
apparently Peaks when you're around 18
to 24.
there's much more to intelligence than
mere IQ
and I don't know if wisdom Peaks when
you're older so that's something that's
commonly said but I I like to go
I like to stir the pot and say you're
your most wise when you're a teenager
when you get progressively less wise and
smarter iqys
hides in the long grass
Matthew thank you Phil thank you Laura
thank you Dave thank you Nathan thank
you Mike thank you sneaky toaster thank
you you are by far one of the best
interviewers geez so this is something
I'm not even trying to interview someone
I don't even think of it as interviews I
just think of it as someone's as a
professor's office hours and I'm getting
to ask questions to fill in gaps in my
knowledge like there are holes and there
are gaps in the wall behind me it's like
I'm just trying to put pieces together
and so I'm asking well does this fit
here okay what about this because you
you said this explains this but I don't
see how
and either way well thank you
gangster again Be Kind Rewind
Hannah thank you thank you thank you
and thank you for your being Hannah
Chris Ms thank you
love thank you Trish thank you Cosmic
thank you oh man I I said I'd thank all
these people geez so many more comments
okay speed gaming news thank you
Indiana's thank you MB user thank you
for people who are listening because
this is going to be re-released as a
podcast on its own I'm gonna take this
down edit it put proper audio
oh yes hey by the way this stream is
brought to you by a sponsor blinkist
again get 25 off blinkist premium and
enjoy two memberships for the price of
one start your seven day free trial by
clicking here blinkist.com Partners
slash theories dash of Dash everything
just so you know we say no to certain
sponsors that don't align with us so for
instance well I'm not going to list them
but
there are certain sponsors that don't
align with us so whenever you hear a
sponsor from us it means that we believe
in the product
okay you'll hear more about that later
Ian mcgilchrist is in the house and
speaking of a book some books are great
as blinks as Snippets that you want to
go through Ian is one that you want to
Wade through you want to envelop
yourself you want to you want to swim
you want to let it soak you want to get
your fingers you want that to happen
with Ian's book
it's called the matter with things just
so you know there are two books I'm
gonna let you in because I want to see
his face as I compliment him not on
dealing Hi Ian
hello good good to see you it's good to
see you man
yes don't get wrinkly fingers on my
account
[Music]
um
so
Ian Ian so there's only been two books
that onto I've consistently said this
these are the books that I recommend one
is a physics book so it's called the
order of time that's Carlo rivelli and
then the other is
a much more expansive book about
Neuroscience cognitive science
Consciousness called
the master and his Emissary or master
and his Emissary and you can look that
up the links will be in the description
Ian has another book if you thought
master and his Emissary was at home like
oh my gosh this is a book you can just
you can spend a year or two years
reading and that's a that's a positive
that's not a negative
and so
I'm looking forward to delving into that
book and having a proper interview with
you Ian for now this is just for you to
say hi to audience like there's so many
people that are saying what the master
in his emissary
let's see sweet the Superstar yes Ian
yeah you want your fingers to get
wrinkly
so hi
hi
thank you very much for that uh
anybody who who still wants to read it
after hearing that it might take them
two to three years well good luck but I
reckon that if you if you really want to
you can do it in about six weeks I I I'm
going to be re uh reading the audiobook
um because people said the audiobook
we'd love to have that but we don't
think that the master and his
atmospheres audio book version was that
good so could you do it yourself this
time and so I'm setting aside something
like a 90 hours or something to read
this aloud
um right and uh yeah true and the other
piece of news is that in 2023 at some
point we're going to be releasing a
paperback so it's already available on
Kindle but anybody who's
anybody who's a really serious reader
will want to have a copy of the hardback
before it disappears because it's such a
beautiful book I think and it's
currently in her really is currently in
hardback it started off in hardback and
um we sold about 12 000 copies of the
hardback and I thought it was about time
to move into the paperback and and all
the rest so there we are that's my
favorite comment this is asking anything
with Jack said I read the matter of
things with my iPhone Mini
it's an iPhone Mini even smaller than an
iPhone I can't I can't believe it
it's a Happy New Year to Ian from Mike
Ian thank you so much for coming out to
this thank you
so what's new with you man yeah
well
um
what are you working on basically I'm
allowing things well I what's coming up
uh quite a long period a fallow period I
mean it took me 10 years of solid work
to produce that last book and uh it's
taken me most of the last years to sort
of
um regrouped my my thoughts because I've
been busy talking and doing interviews
and traveling
um what I haven't made is really a
couple of books one which I've been
promising for a long time because I've
over a lifetime
um assembled a number of very
interesting paintings by psychotic
patients of mine and to do a study
generally of the the artwork of people
with psychiatric illnesses because I
think it's absolutely fascinating and
many of the paintings are really
beautiful so I think that would be that
would be a less ambitious task than the
ones I've set myself in recent years and
perhaps another would be just to write a
short book of like
um very short comments aphorisms you
know things like that yeah the very
opposite of my you know other other
works yeah
do you find that the patients who have a
mental condition that they produce work
of higher qualities or it's sorry of
higher quality or it's just Divergent
and so you get extremely high quality
but you get extremely lower quality
or you don't even want to think of in
terms of quality
well I think you'd have to bring to bear
different criteria on it so
um
so it no it's not just more beautiful or
more beautifully executed though some of
the paintings are both very beautiful
and very beautifully executed is that
they introduce us to an amazing way of
looking at the world they're they're
astonishing Little Gems of they explain
things that really can hardly be put
into words and that's presumably why
they spent the time creating these
extraordinary images so I think they're
fascinating and um you know worth worth
looking at from anybody's point of view
even if you're not interested in mental
illness
what what does it take from you to write
such books
okay so that's a problem what I mean is
firstly mentally yeah
in terms of research in terms of how you
structure your day as well
yeah the long books took a lot of work
um
because
I was simultaneously assembling an
enormous amount of material researching
it organizing it
um and putting it together and it's an
organic process in which I kept going
backwards and forwards between uh oh hi
Mike that's really nice to see you by
the way Mike 11 is in the house huge
pleasure to meet you in
yes
um
I was just saying um that writing a very
long book like the matter where things
took an enormous amount out of me
because I was doing both very detailed
work and Broad thinking and joining up
the dots and seeing the bigger picture
which is in a way
um a a an exemplification of my belief
that the two hemispheres weren't paying
very localized detailed focus and the
other paying a much broader sustained
folks need to be working together but I
found your work my I mean nothing very
original in my saying this but to me it
was a real uh Revelation and I'm really
fascinated by what you're doing well
likewise thank you so much
good good and I I do cite your work in
the matter with things
um and it raised some interesting
questions which perhaps I could put to
you um but please I mean very very
simple one have you take the the
experiment you did where you
deliberately
um distorted
the areas of the tadpole that would
create the face of the Frog
and yet the Frog
as it were developed using completely
different Pathways from any that could
have been that could have been as it
were programmed in it so it reacted to
this situation as a new situation
responded intelligently and we know many
many instances of this of single cells
for example but in a complex organism
like that it's particularly fascinating
but of course this is happening all the
time when parts of the brain go missing
and the rest of the brain knows it needs
as it were to recover something that it
senses is not there and another part
gets repurposed have you thoughts about
where these in a way
I hate to use the term because people
get so uppity about it but these sort of
they are morphogenetic
um force field where they are what they
are what they're like where they come
from have you have you been exploring
that
we have um yeah so so we divide this
problem into a couple of different
pieces so what we can do now to a large
extent at least in these model systems
is to directly observe somewhat decode
and and modify it you know in some cases
at will in some cases not the pattern
memories that allow this collective
intelligence of these cells to build
particular things so we can literally
see these memories in the way that
people who do neural decoding can sort
of read out the evidence of specific
memories in the nervous system and so on
so so that part we have uh there's I
think an even more kind of profound
component to this which is that this
this and and I think and I'm you know
I'm not just using this metaphorically
I'm quite serious when I say this the
the collective intelligence of of this
of the cell of the groups of cells are
able to deploy considerable
sophistication and competency in
navigating the space of possible shapes
and as you as you just pointed out in
novel circumstances they do not simply
just do the same thing every time the
the pattern memories that we can read
tell them where they need to go in this
space and that's fine but getting there
they are able to deploy some really
amazing um competencies and that's the
part that we're only now beginning to to
get a hold of is is what are the
mechanisms that allow them to do new
things and new circumstances to still
get to the essential goal at the end and
so I view this very much as a goal
directed phenomenon and it's on us to
figure out what are the competencies
right and how and what are the
mechanisms and we have so much you know
we have some data on it but but this is
the big I think the big mystery for the
next few decades
you mentioned their memory which is
something as it were almost by
definition from somewhere in the past
and you you suggested you didn't use the
word but you suggested somehow that
there was a sense of direction of the
whole complex system of the organism in
other words a kind of tea loss yeah but
where is the memory and where is the
Telos what is a memory where is where do
your men see start with the use of
scriptures where do they sleep a memory
where do they see that memory so so so
the memory is is encoded in a stable
bioelectric state of all the tissues
it's not just the nervous system it's
all the tissues and it allows the
collective to determine whether so so as
far as we can tell it's kind of like a
very simplistic version of this that
would be a set point in a thermostat in
a homeostatic a homeostatic set point
that basically what it allows the system
to do is to compare the current state to
the Target State the target state is
encoded by electrically if the delta or
the error is large enough then stress
goes up but various actions will be
taken to reduce that that Delta and so
whereas everyone's familiar with
individual cells doing this in let's say
metabolic space right to keep
temperature pH you know simple things
the collective is now able to operate in
exactly the same way but in a different
space it navigates this morphe space the
space of possible anatomical
configurations Guided by this electrical
memory which we can literally see and
rewrite so we have a number of examples
where we've altered the memory in this
cells with with no genetic change the
cells are happy enough to build
something else if we change the
information that tells them what they
should be building now that part we sort
of have a handle on mechanistically
quite well now the part that we're just
beginning to to to sort of touch is how
the
um creative problem solving happens
because what we can show quite easily
right and it's exactly what you started
with it we can show quite easily that it
is never a matter of well maybe in some
systems it is but but in the majority of
living systems it is not a matter of
taking the same path through that space
come what may they know how to go around
obstacles and deal with all kinds of
weird you know circumstances and I think
I'll throw it since you know we're here
sort of as just sharing ideas I'll I'll
throw out a kind of a an unpublished
conjecture that was you know sort of
still working on which is why I think
this they're able to do this and I I
think they're able to do this because
this is what they have to do every
single time I don't think this is a
weird third strange capacity that has to
evolve separately I think I call this I
call this right I call this uh the play
The Hand you're dealt meaning that when
when these beings come into the world
they can't really count on anything they
don't know how many cells they're going
to have because we can take embryos and
cut them into little pieces and they
still do the right thing we they don't
know how many copies of the genome
they're going to have they don't know
what the environment is going to be like
every single act of self-construction
and development is this on the Fly where
are we where is my border where do I end
and the world begins right what
effectors do I have what senses right
they have to they have to do this on the
fly every single time and I think that's
why they're so plastic because Evolution
everything that wasn't plastic probably
couldn't make it you know it's it's
Evolution makes these um
problem-solving machines it doesn't make
solutions for specific narrow problems
that's my guess right that's obviously
very very controversial but that's
that's my guess
exploring that
like is that is it that controversial
though
uh I think it is well you know I think
it requires uh what well well I mean
okay the the part where the part where
it's quite clear that uh living things
can do incredible uh Feats of problem
solving that they were not directly
evolutionarily prepared for that part I
hope is not controversial because the
data are what they are we just see that
and we know that when you you know just
the latest you know our latest example
when you take skin cells off of a off of
an early frog and Brew they reassemble
into this into a xenobot they have a
different life with different behaviors
they just you know with no it requires
no long-term evolutionary adaptation
they just do something completely
different and there are many examples
I was just going to say Barbara
McClintock you know back in the 80s and
so on was was showing this and it's got
a Nobel Prize for it so we're not really
surprised by that anymore
but well we shouldn't we shouldn't
basically no but it's all inspiring I
mean yeah we're not surprised but we're
we're all the more awe inspired well I
am anyway I find this absolutely amazing
yeah the creatures do this yeah yeah
that that part I I hope is not
controversial the part that I think will
be controversial is my suggestion that
Evolution does not take the past as
seriously as we sort of assume that it
does we we tend to you know standard
development is so reliable that it kind
of lulls you into this false sense of
security you see it happening the same
time and you say well yeah of course of
course acorns give rise to oak trees and
and you know frog eggs make frogs what
else could they possibly do because it's
so it's so reliable but uh I think that
uh once you start to probe as you must
if you're going to assay the sort of
cognitive capacity of any creature you
have to start to probe it with novelty
to really make a claim about that you
really start to discover how much
plasticity there is and the fact that it
only does the same thing in every
circumstance in the same circumstance it
actually is capable of doing many
different things and why is that and so
this idea that that's because it can
never count on the past the the present
being exactly like the past right so you
can do all kinds of crazy things you can
add cells remove cells add the no you
know add extra copies of the genome you
could put physical barriers into things
you can do all this stuff and the cells
you can combine you know cells will
combine with other species of cells so
you can make chimeras you can make
um chimeras with inorganic components
put in electrodes and all this kind of
stuff they do fine with all of it
because it's just another day to them
it's just we are in a new environment
like we always are we never know what to
expect and we have to somehow make a go
of it at every point so that's what I
think is the product of evolution I
think that will be very controversial
yeah and what I particularly love about
that from a philosophical point of view
is that in my new book no matter with
things I'm suggesting that the way in
which we think of things in a an
entirely mechanistic way is a mistake
and I tend to invert
um the Assumption so for example we used
to think that the normal State as it
were the state that needs no explanation
is stasis and that motion is an aberrant
State when something comes in or gives
it a push and this is Newtonian
mechanics but that actually motion is
the norm and stasis if it could ever be
truly completely achieved would be the
limit case of motion and I have a whole
lot of these that in fact Simplicity is
the limit case of complexity and so on
but what you're really saying here is
that apparently following a road path is
not the norm from which these yes
um extraordinary
um elaborate and inventive and creative
processes are some sort of
um Divergent you're saying that this is
the norm and the the the the following
of a routine path is just something that
we we happen to have taken as the norm
but is a rather the limit case of
creativity yeah yeah well I I completely
agree I think that is the limit case and
I think that that's what they will do as
a lazy sort of um easiest thing when the
environment is the expected simple
environment but it's by no means but
it's by no means assumed and in fact
many things have to be exactly as you
say you know um your your tongue has
these these these rosettes right very
very kind of finely patterned cells if
if you sever the right if you sever the
lingual nerve over the next couple of
weeks there it completely falls apart
even though the cells are alive nothing
is dead every you know everything's
healthy but that organization completely
falls apart because apparently you need
constant input to you know from this
from this this morphogenetic influence
needs to be constantly working to keep
everything together as cells come and go
molecules come and go right that's that
stasis is a lot of hard work I mean it
requires a lot of hard work yes no
that's lovely yeah
so what do you all Mike what are you
working on next year
oh what are you most excited about and
then also I wanted this to be it's so
hilarious because this is supposed to be
like we all come into a pub and we just
drink some beer we just relax and then
this is like the deepest philosophical
conversation that someone said we're
just moving Humanity forward at a bar
so so anyway oh okay yeah please talk
about what you're up to next year Mike
and I'm letting in Don Hoffman Don the
incredible Dawn ah hey Don good to see
you guys I and Mike wow hello Don hello
so I want to know what each of you are
up to next year if you could briefly
outline that and then just and then I'll
shut my mouth
starting with Mike if you don't mind
sure um wow uh let's see well we have we
have lots of lots of things going on in
our group um we have uh efforts in uh
regenerative biology of course trying to
uh really get better at uh convincing
cells to do what we want them to do
which is to rebuild the complex organs
um and appendages we have uh we have
efforts in in cancer and trying to
reverse the kind of loss of
um that basically you know we we view
cancer as a kind of uh shrinking of the
computational boundary between the the
self and the outside world and so when
cells you know okay when that boundary
shrinks to the level of single cells
they treat the rest of the body as just
external environment and so we're trying
to re-inflate that and get them back to
thinking about big goals in terms of
building organs and healthy tissues and
things like that so so we have some some
continued efforts we've done this in
frog years for years we're now in human
cells and so so we're trying to
hopefully push that push that along and
we have we have we have also some uh
some efforts in um in Ai and looking at
just taking some of the things we've
learned in in biology uh to build novel
uh novel synthetic intelligences that
are not neuromorphic not built on human
brain architecture but just you know
everything from slime molds to cell
groups and so on
um and of course some of the some of the
consent actual stuff too so so there
will be some stuff coming out one thing
I'm particularly excited about is kind
of this this effort we were just talking
about this with Ian this really really
trying to tell a story of the very
earliest boot up of a uh of a of a
proto-cognitive agent what are the very
first steps that happened when a new
being enters the enters the world so to
speak so how do you go from from you
know the chemistry of
field of of cells to an embryo or a
robot that's active in the world or
something but like what are the earliest
steps of that so I think we could tell
an interesting story about that so
well Don is here everyone
Don Hoffman Don mute Ian and meet Mike I
know you've met each other before but we
have a jockey here who has the sound
effects so thank you Sam yep so don don
has a book called the case against
reality the links for all of this will
be in the description
so don please take it away I want to
hear from you please I'm gonna shut my
mouth
but as Ian already told us what he's up
to
I'm an old guy I'm retired I'm I'm I'm
uh you know harrowing my soul to meet
the next World I'm doing I I'm I'm on to
small projects I'm through with very
very very big ones that's me
okay okay
I'm there too
I'm retired as well
yeah good
yeah but but I'm still doing some some
some big projects the the thing I'm we
just had with paper accepted just the
last couple days for a publication on
uh with minor revisions that we're
finishing up it's it's a paper that is
trying to
to connect Consciousness with physics in
a rigorous fashion so the physicists
have discovered that space and time are
not fundamental
as David Gross the Nobel Prize winner
put it in 2005 space-time is doomed and
he gave reasons why space-time is doomed
and so the Hunt is on for structures
Beyond space-time and just the last
eight years
they found them they've uh in 2014 they
published something called the
amplitudehedron and uh
decorated permutations these are
structures not inside space-time they're
not curled up inside little dimensions
of space-time these are structures
utterly and completely Beyond space-time
and space-time is a trivial projection
of these deeper structures and you get
Quantum field Theory computations uh
becoming much more simple when you let
go of space-time Quantum field
computations become trivial and you see
new symmetries in scattering amplitude
data that you couldn't see inside
space-time so it's really over for space
time and and the Gold Rush is on to find
out what's beyond space-time and they're
finding some some wonderful stuff so
this is all in the last decade that that
physic at least high energy physics you
know a lot of there's still a lot of
people doing space-time physics of
course but but the high energy people
um who who are the ones who really need
the better tools they're they're done
with space time they're beyond it
so
this gave us an opening we said look the
physicists
um say the space time was doomed we've
been saying that from our own points of
view about Consciousness and they they
give us a structure beyond space times
that they found so I said let's connect
with that if can we take our
mathematical model of conscious agents
and connect with this structure Beyond
space-time so decided to try doing that
doing that about six months ago and we
we did it we found
um the decorative permutations it turns
out um we discovered that there's a
canonical way to take markovian Dynamics
and project them onto decorated
permutations so that was apparently a
new contribution to the mathematics it
was the one that we needed to make
because our dynamics of conscious agents
is
markovian so so we the paper just got
accepted it shows how to take our
malkovian dynamics of conscious agents
project it down into space into
space-time using decorated permutations
um with this new map that we came up
with Wow
we make a new postulate and then I'll
stop and I'll our postulate is that we
propose that a particle is based on an
elementary particle like bosons leptons
and quarks those are the current
elementary particles that those are
actually projections of so-called
communicating classes of conscious
agents and that that particular proposal
is is precisely because of this mapping
with decorated permutations it dictates
that that has to be the the
correspondence particles are projections
of communicating classes of markovian
Dynamics so so we're now working on the
follow-up paper now is to get momentum
Mass spin all these things come porting
down from the theory of conscious agents
into space-time and predicting specific
scattering amplitudes with specific
dynamics of conscious agents so it's
it's conscious imperialism we want to
show that all of physics starts is just
a projection in fact not just a
projection it's an artifact of the
projection of Consciousness even our
perception of particles is an artifact
of projection not an insight into the
deep properties of reality so that's
that's that's that's fun
wow
what would you say it's very impressive
what you say Don and I I don't um I
haven't the advantage of having been
able to research what you're researching
and I may might well not understand it
if I tried but what would you say
to the idea that this looks like a
process whereby everything of reality is
stripped away and this is of course your
title
um
and this leaves the ordinary person
philosopher physicist or simply
um the everyday guy on the Clapping
order but with a problem which is that
something is must be considered more
real than others and there must be
something that our Consciousness has
some awareness of other than purely
itself this process seems like one in
which you have done what Burton Russell
said mathematics and physics did which
was simply to strip all the reality from
the world from the cosmos and produce a
very thin texture of equations and
numbers now if you do that then you go
oh goodness realities disappeared I I
find this a little bit worrying because
I don't know how you can even say
anything
in English rather than just an equation
without involving space and time
at space and time are the fundamental
ways in which we structure everything we
think
and so yes of course you can invent an
abstract platonic realm in which
everything's been disappeared by some
clever Mass but I suspect this is not
getting closer to a truth but further
and further away from it I'm a follower
of Lees Mullins who says I mean he's a
great physicist it can't be dismissed
who thinks there is nothing more real
than time unless we'd start dismissing
time you've you've lost the plot
basically
right right so so those are of course
very very natural objections to raise
um and so I would respond in two
different directions one is that um
for the physicists who are doing this
right they what they're finding is that
it's space time that is full of
unrealities
for example the the
the ghostly particles that that you get
from infinement diagrams so you these
virtual particles that that are created
and annihilated and you have to add them
all up to get these scattering
amplitudes it turns out that they're not
needed and and that they're just a
distraction when you let go of them then
hundreds of pages of algebra turns into
three terms that you can compute by hand
and you get the right scattering
amplitudes so so space time is actually
hiding the truth it's not showing you
the truth it's actually and the ghost
particles that you know we get the final
diagrams are are literally just nonsense
and not needed so when you get rid of
them and then you're finding new
symmetries that are true so you're
finding that something called the
infinite yanging symmetry is actually
true of our observations that the
colliders and you cannot see that
directly in space-time it can't be
represented in space-time so on the
physics side what they're finding is
letting go of space-time is actually
getting them closer to some quote
unquote truth not not further and and
they're finding out what parts of
space-time are irrelevant that but from
a now from a phenomenological
perspective and a psychological
perspective
um our theory of conscious agents
um takes conscious experiences at
firsthand it says conscious experiences
are real a headache is a real experience
and and so our experiences are not
dismissed uh and that's so in fact we
take them as fundamental
and so in some sense our approach to
conscious experiences
um takes them as as more Central and
more real than most physicalist
approaches where they say that you know
the brain is fundamental and brain
activity gives rise to the conscious
experiences and and really conscious
experience are nothing but brain
activity
um represented in certain ways and and I
say uh well those theories have failed
to explain even one specific conscious
experience there's no
um
chocolate there's nothing on the table
it's all right
so firstly I wanted to again promote
Michael Levin has Dr Michael Levin on on
the Twitter Don has the case against the
case against reality and again the links
to all of these will be in the
description Ian mcgillicus has the
matter with things and Carlos is here
Carlos is from The scmf Institute and
you'll be able to go into detail about
what what that's about and he's also
Carlos has interviewed Mike before so
Carlos I just wanted to welcome you
thanks for coming on man
get to actually see you I'd always speak
over WhatsApp yes yes absolutely it's
great to see you great to see you Mike
um
uh yes so I should say that Mike gave a
talk at the conference that uh sends SMF
organized uh with an interview and it
was uh I was following the conversation
I was very going very much in the
direction of specialty in space and it
was a very interesting multinational
conference that that we had on on the
concept of space uh multidisciplinary
intersection of this of this concept and
so uh actually some of some of your
profiles came up in the discussion who
to invite to to speak so it's the light
of delighted to be here and it's great
pleasure to be able to say hi at the end
of the year
yeah
so Mike I know you've only blocked out
15 minutes and Ian as well but if you
have to get going then
it was great to have yeah Ian what did
you have to say actually the the
connection the connection is not very
good for me it may be for not to do with
me but anyway I feel uh very delighted
to have been here and to have these
conversations thank you very much and
I'm going to wish everybody a Happy New
Year and I believe you thank you thank
you so much Happy New Year even
fantastic to meet you Happy New Year
okay Carlos how's it going man
absolutely it's great to be here I
should say there's uh this uh big
celebrations uh tradition in Spain is
that you go from the day of Christmas
Eve to uh to the King's day which is the
6th of January and there's a lot of sort
of family celebrations and friend
friendship kind of reunions and things
like that and so I'm kind of in the
middle of of a lot of meetings and so on
but I said no I have to make the time
for this you know family wedding where I
said no no I have to be there I mean
it's it's great to meet you to say to
say hi Andrew you know wish everyone
everyone Good Year and everything it's
it's great I mean the thing you're doing
with the tow channel it's very similar
in the spirit we've tried to do with
with SMF and trying to promote all these
different disciplines coming together
and you know the Fantastic research that
is being done the ideas that are flowing
all these conversations are going it
feels it feels very natural in a way
very human to hear all these
conversations going back and forth uh
and I really I really appreciate being
able to just say hi and be able to see
so the kind of digital version of human
face to face which is not quite the same
but yes it's very it's very it's very
exciting so thanks very much for having
me oh for sure man so Mike you're
familiar extremely familiar with Carlos
I think you've been on several times Don
have you met Carlos before no I haven't
good to meet you Carlos good to meet you
John
so
what was your holidays like
oh uh one of the question is for me uh I
ate a lot and I saw a lot of friends
they normally don't see because I live
abroad and that's basically a summary
for most of my Christmas which is a good
summary I think
and Mike did you get a chance to relax
what was your holiday like
um uh trying to catch up on some uh on
some papers some time with family
Outdoors uh it's been you know fairly
nice except for that storm that we had
otherwise spend some time outside yeah
it's been really good yeah
Don
oh yeah uh spending time with with
family and uh um grandkids and uh which
was which was a lot of fun something
unusual yesterday
um I live in Southern California in in
Irvine and uh you may have heard on the
news that there's this snowy owl
which normally is way up in cold
Northern climates the Arctic and so
forth there's one only a half hour from
my house down here in warm sunny
Southern California so so I went there
with my wife yesterday and I got some
photographs and videos of a snowy owl in
in Southern California sunning when it
should be up in the Arctic wow so so
that was an interesting thing to do on
on a Christmas Vacation
hmm
what what's one of your earliest
memories Don
my very earliest is when I was not yet
four years old again my sister was about
to be born and I was in the hospital and
I I knew I was going to have a baby
sister and I knew that was something
really good and I was really excited
about it and I was telling everybody in
the waiting room how proud I was I was
going to be a big brother and had a
little sister that that's why that's my
very earliest childhood memory so my
sister likes to hear that that was my
earliest childhood memory oh that's nice
that's nice you weren't jealous that you
were having a little baby sister well um
my parents I also have a younger brother
who's just a you're you're in a quarter
younger than me and apparently I was
very very happy to have them until they
were old enough to play with my toys and
then I was not very happy with them
so
Mike if you don't mind me asking what's
one of your earliest memories
um I I have some earlier ones but but of
course I can't be sure I'll tell you
I'll tell you kind of a weird one that
has been corroborated by my parents so I
have some some measure of confidence in
this one sure I was I was very young
maybe three or something like that maybe
four and uh I I sort of became really
fascinated with what was inside my body
like like what's inside there you know
and of course we have no way to get in
there but but I thought I'd heard or
seen something about fishing and this
idea that you know you sort of toss this
thing and you could pull stuff out of a
river and so what I did I got up um I
got a spool of uh of sewing thread and I
just and I just started swallowing this
thread on the theory right on the theory
that at some point I would bring it out
three four something like that and uh
yeah and I just you know I just started
all right I just started unwinding this
thread on the theory that at some point
I'd pull it out and and see what was on
the other end I thought I would fish out
this like I remember having this this
thought that well you know maybe this
fishing thing that you know there's
something to this and and maybe I could
like kind of figure out what's in there
I don't I I don't remember what I
thought was going to be you know what
was going to come up or what it didn't
of course lead to anything anything
positive but um but there you go that's
that's an early memory
that's great Carlos what about you
yeah I think I actually had a very
similar fascination with the with the
working of the body I think that's one
of my earliest sort of intellectual kind
of curiosity kind of like Memories
around saying h45 maybe like how does
this work
um I will go into details because
unfortunately the the thing that was
obsessing me at the time is not very PG
friendly but uh let's just put it that
it was to do with the logistics and
mechanics of reproduction and I just
didn't understand why people kissed I
just didn't get and I was upset yeah
okay
because I knew the mechanics of that
that doesn't seem necessary for the
mechanics anyway but that was one of the
earliest sort of uh bodily function
memories that I have very very early on
that's nice
so
Dawn
search meetings all right thank you
thank you for dropping by my pleasure
thanks for having me good to meet you
Carlos and good to see you Mike and
great to see you Don great to see you
Happy New Year's the case against
reality that will be in the description
as well as links to whatever dawn
whatever you send me next day or
whenever I'm reposting this just send it
to me and I'll put it up very very good
okay cheers see you now thank you
Mike do you gotta get going as well I
have about three minutes then I gotta go
all right well Andy from that UFO
podcast is here
oh I'm on hi hi guys hey man it's good
to see you
it's it's intimidating to be on with all
these intelligent well-spoken guests and
uh that I pop up on people's screens so
and the sound effects yeah
thank you thank you to our jockey
okay
yeah so what's up man what's up Andy ah
a lot especially manic festive period uh
enjoying catching this and then out and
amongst my wife is doing the kids
bedtimes just now so she's letting me
come and play for a little while which
is uh which is nice I've been having a
break from podcasting for a week trying
to do nothing in terms of social media
and anything podcast wise but I've had
little lapses here and there but um this
is nice it's a nice idea I've got as
well and it's nice to see you away from
the the intense interviews cut with the
really intellectual folks And discussing
these huge yeah super loopy I'm on a
ball so I'm just bouncy and I'm just I'm
not even thinking about what am I saying
so after I'm just getting tripped up in
the middle of a sentence there's so many
questions I want to ask him like like
just about I want to humanize you
because well
I want to ask about your hobbies I want
to know what is the like what's your
nighttime routine
what what are you like what do you like
when you're not intense when you're not
working sorry Andy I know I just cut you
off
but I'm curious because Mike I know you
got to get going like a couple of
minutes
um wow uh yeah I don't know uh well
let's see uh uh trying to remember the
questions uh night night routine is is
very simple um uh when I'm when I'm done
with the kids and the wife and my
parents and everybody else in the house
I sort of uh do a little more work as
much as I can until I can see that I'm
no longer being useful and then I crawl
off and collapse that's my nighttime
routine nothing too uh nothing too
exciting there I don't have much trouble
falling asleep I I fall asleep within
seconds in fact uh if I well yeah
yeah no I don't really wish that on
anybody actually because I think I think
it's I think it's some some amount of
sleep deprivation and so uh if I'm left
in my own devices I will pretty much
just just you know fall asleep um yeah
so uh so yeah no I've never I've never
had the trouble I I wake up I get up in
the morning I don't have an alarm clock
I I wake up very early uh just no matter
when I go to sleep I wake up very early
so do you work out
uh yeah yeah
every day
I do something every day so I alternate
some days are uh you know sort of walk
out walking outside and some days are a
little bit of weights and some days are
some other things
um yeah there's something
yeah okay Michael you gotta get going I
gotta get going I would like to promote
your Twitter once more Dr Michael Levin
so at Dr Michael Levin and then you have
a website and I don't want to miss data
so why don't you please let audience
know what it is yeah it's just uh Dr
mike11.org it's one word Dr mike11.org
that's why all the papers are there um
every day you know all the videos
everything's linked there um Kurt thank
you so much I really appreciate being on
um uh you know fantastic so many I wish
I could lots of fun look Mike is a
machine there's so many people that are
just loving you all so many plotteds for
Andy for Carlos for Mike and I and for
Dawn and for Ian apologies if I if I'm
not bringing them up I don't want to
distract you too much and also I don't
want to flatter your Eagles too much
though take it easy everybody Happy New
Year
all right just us podcasters
yeah so what's new man what's new Andy
and I'm not sure if you've met Carlos
before but Carlos please meet Andy no no
good to meet you Carlos uh Carlos is
from The semf Institute correct well
we're not Institute yet it's just a
society for multi-disciplinary
fundamental research is a new
organization we're setting up where we
actually Mike 11 was uh was giving a
talk a few months ago we tried to bring
as many different perspectives as
possible to deal with you know Central
Concepts like space a few months ago we
had the concept of space and we had you
know mathematicians business but also
psychologists biologists
um you know people people from
Humanities and so on bringing
perspectives to have this sort of
melting pot of traditions of different
ideas and so on WOW
that that sounds like something that
would require a two or three hour
podcast just explain to me properly what
exactly it was and uh something that I
would listen to more than be involved in
but that sounds really cool I just talk
about UFOs so um yeah I know Dan was
going to be on at the same time but Kirk
put me in pretty quick so I don't know
if he's he's running a little he's not
behind yet but yeah um I've like I said
had my little break but 2022 was quite a
big year with it with UFOs and stuff
someone saying Ryan Graves should have
been here Ryan Graves only does the big
podcast so cart might be able to get
Ryan on
um I've tried to get Ryan a few times
very experienced pilot knows his stuff
um but yeah 2020 C should be a really
interesting year cut for for UFOs
um if you've seen with the ndaa passing
recently there's potential for
Congressional hearings again uh talking
about UFOs which even for people who
don't have an interest in the UFO topic
because of flying sources Little Green
Men and it's too much nonsense they're
going to be talking about it in a very
clear political setting so I'm pretty
excited for that coming up
Andy I hear I hear your accent are you
from Scotland I am I I live in the
northeast of England but I am from
Scotland yep uh this is my this is my
really proper accent I'm putting on so
everyone borderline understands me I've
lived in Edinburgh for eight years now
oh nice are you in Edinburgh now not now
I'm in Spain I'm in Alicante where I'm
from okay
but I yeah I've lived in Edinburgh I did
my PhD University of Edinburgh I was I
was there for a while yes so there's
there's the difference between you and I
Carlos you've done a PhD in Edinburgh I
lived in Lanzarote for six months as a
holiday rep so that's there's the
different backgrounds yeah you are doing
a PhD and I was a holiday rep for a tour
company but yeah we're kind of getting
the best of our civilizations mutually
absolutely yeah I'm I'm the light relief
I think the light comic relief that's it
no that's that's great that's great
um fascinating spicings and stuff so
apparently Gary Nolan is watching Gary
please join
yeah he's familiar with with Gary Nolan
Carlos
sorry didn't get that Carlos are you
familiar with Gary Nolan uh no I'm not
so Gary's a professor at Stanford I
believe specializing in molecular
biology it could be incorrect about that
or the biomedical
oh here we go here's someone who will
correct me Ben
oh how's it going
hello there good to see you man it's
been
oh it's been weeks and weeks or months
and months
Gary Gary hiding out in a bunker we have
a Gary hello Gary
how's it going man
good to see you
hello hello Gary it's wet and very
ufocentric hi Gary good to see you
yes yeah we can hear you a bit
can you speak again please
before I do let me figure out which of
the many microphones sitting around here
around here yes please do yeah I've been
doing the same thing for the past 10
minutes
and and John vervaki John verbaki has a
new series coming up
after Socrates if I'm not in if I'm not
mistaken is that correct John yep the
new series comes out January 9th on my
YouTube channel it's called after
Socrates and it's uh all about
um
uh being after Socrates in multiple ways
uh try to catch up with him where he's
taken us
um trying to learn how to live a
Socratic life so in addition to like
Awakening for the meeting crisis which
is a continuous argument lecture series
uh there will also be points to ponder
which you can reflect upon individually
or I encourage people to get into a
group discussion about it and
most importantly there'll be a
pedagogical program of practices that
goes along with uh uh every lecture so
at the end of every lecture I'll then
teach a practice that goes along with it
the practices build on each other like
the lectures do and the the idea is to
give you a an exposure to a rich Ecology
of practices that uh will enable you to
live the socratic life and really get a
sense of respectival and participatory
you may have heard of those sense of
what it is to live a Socratic life
well thank you John thank you thank you
Gary so
this was this is just us coming into a
pub
I know John you just went in deep like
you just went into the philosophical
deep end and
just I wish we had shots I don't drink
but
how was your holiday John that was my
holiday uh my holiday was uh well it's
continuing to be really good it's a
mixture I I was able to take some time
off uh but I've also been doing some
work
um I'm going away at the beginning of
January uh to film uh an online course
and
I'm going away at the end of January to
California uh so I mean I'm happy about
that I'm a Canadian so get you know
somebody paying me to go to Florida and
to California is like of course of
course
um but uh uh but today's a warmer day
luckily hey I think it's a record in
Toronto it said 13 I don't think it's
ever hit this before
yeah
Gary what's what's been your holiday
what's your holiday been like
are you able to relax
so what were you up to
[Music]
um actually uh working up some of the
next steps for the UAP studies in my lab
uh we actually were down at uh at a
high-tech uh Imaging facility in uh
in San Jose uh to do some Imaging at the
atomic level for some materials uh that
we've got for the new instrument it's
the beginnings of the new instrument
that we're making for Imaging material
at the atomic level
because I figure that that's one way to
if you want to look for a a Smoking Gun
you want to find things that are made in
a way that nobody else understands how
to make them
or at the very least you can then say
what's in them at a much with a much
higher level of resolution I mean just
knowing that there's
you know silicon and germanium or
whatever in material doesn't tell you
anything about where the atoms are
placed
Gary do you mind explaining
what you do and what your focus is to
John
I know that I'm not sure if you both
have met no before so this is John
vervaki from U of T Gary I mean sorry
John this is Gary from Stanford Gary
Nolan
oh my my pleasure my day job is
Immunology cancer Imaging algorithms for
interpreting bioinformatics things like
that uh We've spun out a number of
companies
um but you know for John and I think a
lot of people on the on the uh on the
YouTube who who know me my interest has
been in how to formalize research in
such exotic topics as uh as UAP right
how do you and I don't mean this in any
kind of a derogatory sense how do you
teach the lay public to ask questions
about science that doesn't presuppose a
conclusion that basically puts them in a
position of looking like you know being
made a fool of which is one you know has
been done for decades and across many
disciplines it's not just UAP so it's
about you know how to get people to
agree that the data is real and then
once the data is real real you can flip
the tables on people and say okay well I
don't have to explain it it's not my
responsibility you can't just yeah you
know turn down and critique everything I
I suggest it's the responsibility of any
good scientist to also suggest Solutions
uh so that's been you know that's been
one of my major ones and then the other
is that more recently in speaking with
philosophers and I wish I saw the people
who were on just previously you know
what are the burdens of proof for
different kinds of observations
you know a burden of proof for a
so-called experiencer is different than
that of a uh of a scientist but both of
these people want to talk to each other
so coming up with with a linguistic path
that allows them to talk to each other
in a way that they're not talking past
each other I think is important
um
very interesting uh do you talk to them
about issues around bias and
self-deception yeah oh yeah I mean
especially the um
what's it called it's uh it's a French
it's a French term for uh the the folio
do right that basically there's a you
know feedback mechanism between two
people who reinforce their delusion if
you will
um and so yeah there's a there's a lot
of that I mean most of the work that
I've done with people who are let's say
uh orbiting the the government uh on
this issue
um are scientists who spent a lot of
time especially with the psychological
aspects of this actually verifying that
the people that were collecting data
from don't have some other kind of
mental health issue I mean the problem
is that many of these many people are
they actually are both they both have
kind of a mental health condition
because of the experience and because of
society's reaction to that
um so there's a you know disentangling
that is is just as bad a um a problem as
anything else
yeah it's been related work on potential
overlaps between what you might call
foolishness which is an epistemic and
moral failure to address self-deceptions
like that and then
um and mental health issues that also
have that kind of uh biasing of
attention and salience dysregulation and
so there's a gray line where I would
expect you to find a large number of
people where it's hard to disentangle
those two yeah no I mean it's I mean we
use in some ways the same things that we
do for the clinical studies that we're
involved with with cancer researchers we
do a lot of
what's called inclusion exclusion
criteria you have to make sure that
you're comparing Apples to Apples yes
um so that your statistics can be more
powerful because you're focusing on a
um on a more uniform group I mean the
problem with uniformity of course is
that it misses all of the interesting
stuff in the middle you know it's often
stuff in the middle that's that you can
explain the edges usually but the stuff
in the middle is where the fun stuff
happens and it might miss stuff that
transfers right it doesn't generalize or
transfer appropriately to the individual
differences that pick out a particular
pathological population either so you
get the you get the problem the other
way too that you may be missing other
than causal factors that way
you know for me I mean I think the
pilots were brought up a moment ago
people like Ryan Graves and others you
know that here you have experts who are
then let's say turned upon by I'll call
them pseudoskeptics uh and grouped with
you know the uh let's say the less
Savory characters uh in the UFO
Community or you know basically people
who do have you know issues or saw the
wrong thing and and so they're very
credible testimonies and observations
are basically brought down to earth if
you will by commentary that Associates
them with absolutely ridiculous you know
comparisons or comparators
so I mean that's that's part of the
problem but my you know my push has
always been uh you know always go after
the inevitable right always aim for the
inevitable the things that you know must
be true I mean obviously that's going to
be very self-serving uh objective and
that you you know what you think is is
inevitable might not be what somebody
else does but I think if you can Define
what's truly inevitable and then focus
on it and just ignore the critics you
know it's it's three parts confidence
you know two parts ignorance that
actually is what drives progress
in these kinds of areas so
um you know that's always been my
Approach
people I remember you know people have
said Gary you're very confident I said
I'm not confident and I just I just want
to do it
right and if you don't have a decision
of something a hypothesis you're trying
to
test
then there's you know then you just you
know you're just left in this kind of
wishy-washy area of never proving or
disproving something
you know I've always uh I I like using
this analogy that one of my mentors from
grad school you know told me Lee
herzenberg and she was saying look
there's two kinds of questions there's
the Las Vegas question where the answer
is yes and no and if you waste you spend
six months on no you're interested you
know that's a bad thing obviously the
Las Vegas outcome might be great but
sometimes there's a kind of a Zen Twist
of the question that you can apply that
makes any question interesting no matter
the answer and so that's where I think
it kind of flips back to the UAP
phenomenon is that the answer is
interesting no matter what
right whether it's We're Alone
how fascinating and sad
or there is something how amazing uh you
know the question the real open question
is how close is the something is it here
or are we just is it just more hopeful
thinking
I'm curious John and and Gary what is
your earliest childhood memory
John if you don't mind
I was laying on the living room floor I
was three and something I'm wondering
what school was like
how old are you oh it's really three and
a half or so just before I was gonna go
to about it about eight months or so
before he's gonna go to school
you were anxious about it like no no not
at all you're excited I was curious I
was I was wondering what my sisters my
older sisters did at school what school
was like that's why so I guess I was
destined from the beginning to be an
academic my first memories about what's
school like exactly yeah
and Gary
um I have like three or four from like I
mean
like before we came to this country when
I was one and a half on a ship actually
from Liverpool
and so I remember
being passed out the window at one point
in Liverpool to my father
uh who put me on the back of a motorbike
I remember being for the first time
actually put a toilet I remember seeing
the toilet in front of me
um and I remember being on the ship left
alone by my mother because my father was
already in the United States so these
are all kind of frightening moments you
know I mean I I don't really remember
much Beyond those but those moments
where oh I remember being brought out to
the front of the ship and it was just
sort of this Misty thing so I must have
been before one and a half but they're
just like flashes no cognizance
right just kind of these flashes of
stuff that I can still see I don't think
then the next memories came until I was
around three which were kind of little
stories
and Carlos and Dan and Andy sorry if I'm
monopolizing if you have any questions
for for Gary and John please
please ask it's a bit difficult because
we're doing this virtually and so
interjecting is always tough but please
I've got like a million questions
especially for someone like Gary I could
speak to on a daily basis
um but not to waste too much time and
Gary Indiana directions yeah you both
mentioned though mental health in terms
of the in the UFO topic and it's a huge
a huge area especially in 2022 going
into 2023 and Beyond and I just wonder
how how do you navigate the conversation
in terms of the UFO topic especially
when it goes into the political Arena
when you're hoping to have hearings in
the U.S Congress and further afield
without it coming across like it is a
massive mental health issue because
that's the way I think a lot the general
public or even if I have conversations
with people I work with the way they see
the topic is people are either crazy
or the misidentified something
well I mean
you know you should see my email inbox
sometime with some of the you know the
longer the email the less usually
five-page you know diatribes and it's
like I don't even have
um you know I I tried very carefully I
mean look I'm not an MD and I'm
certainly not a psychiatrist
um but uh I think one of the good things
about the openness of the topic is
amongst the many emails I get are
actually emails from psychiatrists and
uh um Health mental health officials
um and uh you know they say hey how can
we help right what can we do to organize
uh and provide
um you know more than just a little
local groups sorry about the dog
um
and uh you know I think it's again
similar I mean I don't I don't have the
wherewithal within the right communities
but it's similar to what Ryan Graves has
been doing uh with the um American
Institute of
uh
quiet all right Aeronautics where he has
created a group of people who can talk
to the other Pilots uh about the
observations that they've had and give
them the kind of feedback that allows
them to not have a fear for their jobs
or fear for their sanity
um so I'm involved with a number of
others uh to actually set up um an
independent Institute uh that will um
amongst several things among policy
papers and other things that we'll write
around the whole UAP project also to
have an arm around uh the social aspects
of things and so hopefully we'll be able
to announce that later this year we've
already got some of our first major
donations
I mean what's exciting to me is the
amount of interest that is here and the
amount of available resources is
extraordinary it's really just about
coordination and ignoring those stupid
articles in the Wall Street Journal and
Julian Barnes and all of that
Ridiculousness I mean just don't pay
those kinds of people any attention
because they're really
um I think their objective is to
demoralize those who are working in the
area and not so much as to spread
disinformation right I think
disinformation is one thing
that's been done but I think the attempt
to demoralize uh is more uh I think
dangerous
uh it's demoralizing those who want to
do it who want to invest who've already
made a decision that this is something
that should be worked upon
um sorry to interject but why is it you
think that they're interested in
demoralizing do you think that that's
their their conscious
aim or that's just an artist I think
it's both I mean I I know I don't want
to get all conspiratorial but I mean if
you're doing a psyop it's not just about
throwing litter into the conversation
it's about stopping your opponents from
even wanting to win
so Andy had a question and so John if
you recall the question
can you answer if not Andy can you
repeat
uh I don't know if John does but it just
generally has thinking around the UFO
topic and and mental health how you have
that open conversation similar to Gary I
get people asking me telling me their
experiencers and they've had these like
Gary says five six seven pages worth of
emails to tell you an incredible story
as a one-off event or that's happened
throughout their life and they're
frustrated that those conversations
aren't being had in a more mainstream
way at the kind of higher levels well
they assume they aren't being had but
the worry is that if those are talked
about in terms of experiences being on
kind of late night news chat shows
they're going to be laughed at they're
going to be mocked and ridiculed and I
just wonder how how those conversations
can make their way into the mainstream
in a serious way
I don't interact with uh UFO people at
all today too that hasn't come across I
don't know if that's just because of uh
the kind of work I do or the community
um so I don't I don't have too much to
say about this specific topic I can
speak to the general topic which I do a
lot of work on which is
um refurbishing our note our notion of
rationality uh we have a far too narrow
and truncated notion that doesn't
actually serve
um most of uh
most of action of actual existence and
living
um
and
for example I think there's far too much
of a priority put on a certain kind of
inferential logical ability
um
that
probably isn't as Central to uh
rationality as overcoming self-deception
is which often involves very different
kinds of strategies around detention
proper understanding of how memory Works
Etc which people can be well educated in
the difficulty comes you know in about
when
issues of irrationality and issues of
pathology are intertwined together
um
because it's very hard in that gray area
to
exclude the people that need to be
excluded because
you have to understand for large groups
of topological individuals allowing them
into this conversation is actually
detrimental
right it reinforces the pathology in
ways that will prevent them from seeking
the help they need
Etc so there are
um again I I'm not trying to take sides
or beacons territorial there are genuine
Quantified cases or groups of cases
where you want to include people through
these conversations because it's
deleterious to them and then how do you
separate that from
uh people who may be saying things that
seem initially very odd or strange but
are ultimately
rationally valuable that is easy to
State as a thing it's very hard to do
um and the reason is they it's like I
say people don't fall cleanly and
exhaustively and exclusively into one of
these groups or another you'll have
people
right who might be saying things that
are strange but epistemically worthy of
Investigation one minute and the next
minute saying things that definitely
indicate there's a pathology at work and
then what do you do with those
individuals you allow them to keep
speaking because of the epistemic value
of what they're saying but that's
detrimental to their Therapeutic Health
do you intervene therapeutically but
then that's at the epistemic cost of
silencing a voice that may be bringing
arguments or evidence to bear it's a
hard issue and it's not specific to this
issue you know it pertains to people who
claim to have talked to Angels what do
you do with people like that and I'm not
saying I'm not trying to reduce one to
the other I'm not doing that I'm just
trying to give you that this is a this
is a very generic problem and we're not
doing a lot to talk about that we have a
category sanity we have other category
rationality how many conversations in
depth have you heard where people are
trying to work out what's the
relationship between rationality and
Sanity
I haven't heard a lot of these
conversations but the conversations we
need to have and we need to have them
not just because of this issue but of
many issues where it's very difficult to
determine how we should be interacting
with individuals or groups of
individuals like I said Andy I can't
talk to the specific issue I I am
virtually ignorant about it uh but on
the on the what you might call the
psychological epistemic issue about
rationality and Sanity
that's something that I I think we need
to be talking a lot more about and it's
something that I do my work is directed
towards I hope that's at least helpful
no absolutely as in I think sometimes
it's nice to hear logic from people that
are thinking who aren't involved in the
UFO topic on the UFO topic to give you a
fresh perspective or at least kind of
word things in a different way so I
appreciate that from yourself and from
Gary cart I have to head off uh but this
has been great thank you Dan hi uh happy
holidays yes and months yes uh and I'll
I'll
see well Gary like I want to thank you
for coming on board Gary Nolan is one of
the names that you think about first
when you think about hard Research into
the UFO topic so you're Paving the way
for further research and I appreciate
that Gary and I think I speak for
several hundred people who are watching
I'm not even sure it's 700 several
hundred six hundred eight hundred one
thousand now one thousand apparently
so thank you Gary for coming on happy
holidays man it's good to see you and
and shut up those dogs
take take control of those dogs I'm just
kidding around man we love it we love
them take care man
nice meeting you Gary
[Music]
I can't quite hear you he said he's
gonna go look up your work he switched
mics okay let me know what you think of
what you said was fascinating all right
bye bye bye bye Andy bye bye Gary have a
great New Year bye guys now The Real
Party begins it's just us let's take
these guys out I'm just kidding denied
okay there we go there's the jockey
comes back
so what's up everybody uh hi John uh
good to meet you I've I followed uh some
of your podcasts uh they were extremely
helpful because I was setting up uh sort
of a group of people here in in Spain
where it based where we're trying to get
together different traditions of
Christianity atheism and different
spiritual traditions and trying to set
up sort of uh I mean I don't know what
they would write word in English is but
something like reflection reflection
groups and some kind of uh ways of uh
coming together and just talking life
and talking so spirituality and I was
wondering right I was wondering if you
have any insights on I I'm sure you have
a lot of experience but if you have any
insights on the phenomenon that a lot of
practices across different Traditions uh
kind of converge into similar so
meditation you know uh praise
yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean I I'm so I'm very much
about not like giving people a set
recipe of practices like do this do this
do this do this what I do instead is I I
look for sort of two things I look for
what I call Design principles what are
the best ways of like designing an
Ecology of practices what kind of
features do you want in it uh you want
important processing you want nested
opponent processing uh you want a proper
pedagogical program so things are
introduced in the right order of
operations uh you want layering so it
can you have practices that appeal to
different kinds of knowing within the
psyche and coordinate between them so
those are design principles I look for
a processing nested opponent processing
uh pedagogical program and layering so
you want those definitely and then I
look for domains what are the domains
that
are the ones that are going to bring
about
um
what spirituality I think of
spirituality as conforming to deeper
dimensions of reality in order to afford
the cultivation of wisdom where wisdom
is the
uh amelioration of foolishness and the
affordance of meaning in life for me
um so uh you look for domains uh there's
mindfulness domains obviously uh there
are movement domains there are nature
connection domains there are biological
uh domains
um
I tend to argue and not uh and this is
sort of bridges between being a domain
and design principle but you want your
ecology to practice you can do on your
own or in a small group and then you
want a dialogical practice for larger
group collective intelligence that
serves as sort of your your your you
know the next Buddha is the saying it
serves as your Sage to give people
guidance
um uh someone wants to know how do you
explain Buddhism to a Westerner John how
would I explain Buddhism to a Westerner
um I would say avoid uh initially
Western versions of Buddhism that have
been cleaned up and make Buddhism look
other than it is
um uh I think Evan Thompson why I'm not
a Buddhist and even Bachelors after
Buddhism are very powerful critiques of
Western Buddhism uh Western Buddhism
claiming the Buddhism is more scientific
which is really a bad argument because
Western Buddhism has basically removed a
lot of the non-scientific stuff from uh
you know uh uh Eastern Buddhism if I
could put it that way and therefore it
made it look more scientifically
palatable
um I would explain Buddhism
um only after somebody has engaged in
practices for some time
uh and do the Eightfold Path
uh and and do it seriously do it as an
Ecology of practices you want to know
what Buddhism is go into the existing
Ecology of practices a full path is a
perfect example by the way what I mean
by an Ecology of practices it has
opponent processing there's a
pedagogical program it has layering
everything is dynamically
self-organizing do that for a while and
then start reading about Buddhism
if you go from the text first
it's it's like well I make this joke but
it's like reading the Kamasutra and
never making love you you won't get it
you won't understand it you're
fundamentally misinterpret it
um and like I say I'm very critical of
Western Buddhism because of the way it
misrepresents
um historical Buddhism and the way it
also tends to reduce why do you think
that is
why do I think that is because is it
just a few individuals who are
responsible for this in some movement or
is there some larger reason uh no I
think it's it's I I don't I don't think
they were Sinister I think they were
responding to very powerful cultural
imperatives right a market bottom line
idea like can we simplified get cut to
the chase what's it all about uh how can
I what's this what's the basic practice
how can I make this work as simply as
effectively as possible and you reduce
all of my let alone Buddhism you reduce
all the mindfulness to one thing seated
meditation which is ridiculous I mean
yeah compared to doing nothing seated
meditation is great but if you want to
transform something as Dynamic and
complex
as a self within a community of persons
within a culture now you've got to do
something way more powerful but it's
easy to Market
mindfulness for stress reduction so that
you will be a very contented corporate
drone
that's easy to Market and that's easy to
sell and that's easy to get people to
jump on board because you get immediate
effects
stress production will start working
within eight weeks it does that's what
it does transforming your character
bringing about the cultivation of wisdom
you really think you're going to do that
in eight weeks could you learn to play a
musical instrument well in eight weeks a
martial art in eight weeks come on it's
ridiculous to believe that
sorry it was polemical but I feel very
strongly precisely because I have so
much value for Buddhism that I dislike
the way it is often uh being presented
in the west and like I say I'm in good
company I know both Stephen Bachelor
I've had dinner with him talked to him
at a conference and Evan of course was a
colleague of mine a friend of mine at
ufp so I'm in good company with people
who we're very critical of Western
Buddhism
okay speaking of good company
Christina Gomez is in the house good to
meet you Christina hi there everyone
hey Christina and I would like to let
everyone know about strange paradigms
which is a YouTube channel and I'll put
the link I'll pin it in the chat as well
as put it in the description once this
finally gets reposted as well as
Christina has a new YouTube channel I'd
like you to tell us about it's ambient
Space Music something akin to that
correct yes no thank you so much I I
meant to like take some time off before
and during Christmas like to take a
break from working online and show
Productions but I ended up just getting
busier so I started a new ambient music
channel called Cosmic portals and it's
really just kept me busy and so like
it's about it's it's to help people such
as myself that suffer with insomnia to
sleep better to relax but also to allow
that imagination to run as well but in a
very relaxed state but it's something
that I've really enjoyed doing I love
making music when I'm not creating four
shows a week on my channel Christina
Gomez but um overall it's it's been a
lot of fun but I do hope to take a break
maybe during the first week of uh New
Year's so I'll see how that goes but I'm
not going to hold my breath because well
you know how that is Kurt uh-huh do you
find John so for yourself like you you
had a difficult time taking a break like
I find that I find that to be the case
for for myself
well I'm definitely amazed at this eight
hour show that you're doing today I mean
you're an absolute trooper I actually
moved my weekly strange news live stream
which is normally at about 3 P.M PST to
5 p.m instead in honor of your eight
hour tonanza today because this is
incredible
yeah thank you thank you man so thank
you Sam thank you so this man I can't
wait to show you all this day in the
life we've been filming this day in the
life of what it's like to work in this
office which is different than working
from home the whole point of getting
this place and getting
a video editor here and and Sam here to
help with virtually every aspect of toe
is to make it less work for myself or so
work such that I could spend time
researching because I just love to study
it's like John as an academic like um I
don't know there's probably you like
researching more than studying as in
producing your own work but I just love
to study I love to learn
and I've and it's been so much work
every day if we leave here at 7 pm
that's like the earliest day we're like
oh wow that's like that's like leaving
it at like 2 p.m at a job
sorry sorry so that's Sam who's on the
syndicated this true feeling toward me
through sound
he anyway I can't wait to show you all
that and then this was just
this well this is just fun anyway John I
want to know about your relaxing how do
you relax
I need to know yes
I mean I do my practices every day every
morning so they they help me a lot
um I'll do an Ecology of practice I
practice what I preach if I'm preaching
that's the right word but Tim uh yeah no
every morning uh an hour an hour and a
half every day
but that's it yeah what I mean is you
don't take time out of a year for
relaxation you take time out of a day
oh do I uh yeah I tend to I mean I'll
I'll take some time off and spend it
with my kids just enjoying their company
or with my beautiful partner uh and her
kids uh but um
yeah I mean I I I don't I I'm I'm not
the person to talk to I'm very
privileged I the work I do is play for
me that's joyous uh I'd be doing uh you
know if I if I had if I ever became
independently wealthy I'd probably just
keep doing everything I was doing uh
yeah and so
um I mean yeah I get stressors uh but um
I'm very lucky and I'm very and I'm very
appreciative of that thought that I get
to do work that I find valuable a lot of
people find valuable and I find it
incredibly meaningful
so let's go around the room I'm curious
what would change sorry
that's okay I was just gonna ask like
earlier we we asked John to explain
Buddhism and he gave us a really great
answer and during the ncu John was
saying about uh how everyone thinks
meditation is a sit-down kind of thing
you know for 10 minutes a day and and I
just wanted you to expand on that John
and just tell us what you think of
meditation as
um so I think I think of mindfulness as
an awareness of mental Framing and I
always I often use my glasses I've been
told this has become a meme
um as you know this is how I'm framing
what I'm paying attention to what I'm
ignoring what I'm focusing on what I'm
backgrounding what's peripheral and what
you're doing in meditation is you're
stepping back and looking at your mental
training
so it becomes opaque to you you can look
at it rather than being unaware of it
precisely because you're looking through
it by means of it uh and what you can do
is you can notice patterns on your
mental framing they may be distorting
how you're seeing the world the problem
is you can't tell if any correction
you've made any changes you've made are
actually making a difference until you
do a complimentary practice which is you
have to put your frames back on and see
if you can see more clearly and deeply
into the world that's why most Buddhist
Traditions have in addition to a
meditative practice
they have a contemplative practice where
you're looking out and seeing if you can
see clearly into the depths of how
everything is impermanent how everything
is in interconnected etc etc and you
have to go back and forth between those
um in order to enhance your ability to
be free yourself from distorting frames
but also afford yourself clarifying
friends and moving back and forth but
you don't you you not only want to do
that in a still fashion
you want to do it in a moving fashion
because there's a there's an important
Loop like the the frontal cortex and
your cerebellum form a loop and you need
to train that that's why you have
mindfulness things that have movement
martial arts tai chichwan uh yoga
especially if it's flowing yoga you want
so you want to you want I still practice
and a moving practice also to constantly
pull and push on each other and then you
want to set that
individual practice of mindfulness
practice into shared mindfulness like
you do in circling or biological
practices where you're bringing in the
interpersonal Dimension into your mind
once you get that sort of
three-dimensional four-dimensional
aspect then I would be saying you're
actually starting to train mindfulness
in in a well-rounded manner would that
help is it as an Amsterdam
yeah that's really interesting answer
thank you I just think a lot of people
think of meditation exactly like you
said you know you sit down for 10
minutes away and just think about
thinking when actually there's a much
kind of broader more interesting add to
it yeah there's a lot going on and you
want to learn it in a way that's going
to transfer but you know
the idea about meditation and stress
reduction is it gives you the idea of
meditation as a vacation from your life
meditation contemplation move all of
these things should be in education for
your life you should be learning them in
a way that is going to transfer as
broadly and deeply into areas of your
life as possible the Buddha actually
talks about this a lot he warns about
people who meditate to become sort of
contented like a cabbage
you don't want to be that contented like
a cabbage yeah just sort of happy to
just be
it's cute
yeah okay what I was going to ask is I'm
curious about all of you what would
change in your life about what you're
doing here
your trajectory if you were to be given
three million dollars right now
and by the way donations are open so
Christina please I want to start with
you
well I'm already planning on purchasing
an RV and traveling the United States
hitting all the Paranormal and UFO hot
spots so with that much money it would
go to a nicer RV and better equipment
than I could ever imagine but still take
everyone uh this this audience and all
the other audiences with me on this
journey of looking into the mysteries of
our universe because with my generation
I'm a little bit frustrated because
whether I'm talking to people in the
University or old friends from school
they're always with their noses in their
phones and they aren't looking at their
phones to learn about our world or the
mysteries of our universe but they're
just there to build up their social
media platforms and being entertained so
I want to change that and I mean I want
to do my part in getting this
conversation going and that's what my
YouTube channel is all about it's a
journal of my adventures in learning
about all of these amazing Mysteries and
looking at the strange world that most
ignore
right Dan Dan I'm curious what would
change if anything
uh well I'm sorry sorry that I keep
interrupting you I feel like we have a
kinship so
so the Christina where can people go
this sounds like an ending question but
you're not being kicked out already but
where can people go to find out more
about what you just referenced
well you can find that on my YouTube
channel just typing in Christina Gomez
there is no h in my name so it's just
c-r-i-s-t-i-n-a and then Gomez g-o-m-e-z
and also you can check out some of my
music at Cosmic portals as well
great thank you thank you Dan
so yeah I was just gonna say like I love
Christina's idea and actually I'm
a few months back off my shackles and
quit my job and gave him my notes for my
flat and I'm on my first part of my
travels I spent Christmas Day at teotu
account
um do any kind of similar thing as
Christina suggested you know going out
and kind of really seeing these places
for yourself and trying to internalize
them and actually appreciate what they
mean for the world instead of just you
know scrolling through the latest things
on your phone
um and it's been really kind of an
amazing experience so I would take that
3 million and kind of invest the travels
and try and include as many people as
possible in it
um and I didn't have to forget but it
would be kind of contribute to something
like project Galileo or you know a real
ongoing scientific study of the the UAP
phenomena
great great Carlos
well I think I would just continue
um and I would donate a big chunk of
that if not all to to stmf to our
non-profit and we will probably build an
Institute with that money try to set up
like an actual research effort that is
not just trying to get researchers
together but actually try to fund some
some research and three million dollars
are about enough to get the research
going for a little bit and and so yeah
so it will go into a physical uh you
know location probably in beautiful
Mediterranean landscape like I am right
now and go for it for some kind of space
for retreat for intellectual Retreats
and yeah do great science do uh you know
this sort of multi-disciplinary across
boundaries kind of research uh that's
where the money will go for sure in my
case
too
you gotta get going John but before you
go if I have three questions I want to
know what nothing this is what Emptiness
is and in terms of the western sorry in
terms of disentangling it so disem
broiling it from the Western notion so
like where are we misguided in the
colloquially and then also what are your
vices man besides chocolate
um
first one um that's a hard one uh
nothingness is best understood as no
thickness which is the idea that we try
to think of Ultimate Reality sometimes
you can think of it as being with a
large B and we try to think of it the
way we think of individual beings
individual things we try to use the same
conceptual
uh
format same conceptual vocabulary
theoretical grammar that we use for
manipulating objects physical things
physical processes and we try to use
that uh to think about Ultimate Reality
per se and the Ultimate Reality is not
in that category so no thing this it is
not nothingness in the in the sense of
privation and an absolute lack
so there's a nihilistic sense of
nothingness which is different from a
superlative sense of no thickness which
is the absolute fullness of Ultimate
Reality that is the source and
sustaining ground of all of this which
is the exact opposite of nihilistic
nothingness and one of the great
criticisms that nishitani in religion
and nothingness actually religion and no
thickness makes a niche because nature
didn't get he didn't go deep enough you
got to the nihilistic nothingness but
didn't push through uh to you know thing
this and I think part of the way in
which which we can address the meeting
crisis is affording people the ability
to make that fundamental transformation
so sorry the way that you're explaining
it was as if nothing so Contracting
n-o-t-h-i-n-g is a step toward no thing
which is no dash thing yes yeah so you
in both the west and the east in the
East you have the great doubt of Zen In
The West you have the dark knighted Soul
there's a place in which when you
originally are pulling free from that
thingy way of thinking about everything
um you you just experience nothingness
before you get the emergence of the
breaking through the Satori dork Brook
breakthrough as Meister Eckhart called
of the no thingness
which is a different thing and so there
it's like an aspect shift it's like you
know you've seen those pictures where
it's like uh evolves and then you flip
and it's two faces right right it's that
kind of aspect shift you're not making
an inferential move because if you try
to make an inferential move you're
falling back into the thingy way of
thinking it's this it's this fundamental
comprehensive of aspect shift
that's the best thing
so many follow-up questions I have John
but before you go then let's just end
light
your vices please
um I laid them all bear
um
I have a bad temper
yes
yes which is why I have to very
um very diligently follow a Socratic
path uh Marcus Aurelius I'm in good
company apparently had a very bad temper
so I take comfort of the fact that he
was able to be Marcus Aurelius with a
very bad temper
um so yeah I mean that's
um
and it's probably related to the fact
that underneath uh this Persona I'm
socially phobic
um because anger is usually a response
to a feeling of threat
um so that's probably my worst advice so
people who know me well and people who
love me in spite of my advice is I will
say if you push me too far too long
um it's not that Vice will sometimes
appear although I have been told by the
people who love me that I have made some
progress towards
not losing my temper okay
okay
yeah yeah okay how about this do you get
disconcerted I'm sorry discombobulated
and non-plussed when you become angry or
do you become more quick weighted
because there are two different types of
anger that I see in people some that are
they actually become more on point
all right others they just lose their
no I don't think I'm discombobulated I I
have I have what's called cold anger I
become very sharp and incisive
um and
um can be very become very cutting
um
that goes against what I aspire to in my
life
um and so trying to properly Channel and
integrate that energy is an ongoing
thing for me
okay John you got to get going yes we'll
end light next time and I'm sure you'll
be back on toe
a couple days from now we're constantly
seeing each other so
happy holidays man thank you very much
and once again everybody January
nice meeting January 9th after Socrates
the link is going to be in the
description and I'm going to highlight
that as a pinned comment shortly now
it's just us podcasters Carlos I know
you got to get going as well
thank you
yes um it was it was a it was a great
pleasure to be here uh and perhaps I
could just say a couple words of uh for
for viewers if they're interested in the
kind of work that you and I Kurt might
be involved together at some point down
the line yep
um so yes it's a particular project for
everyone yeah there's a there's a
project in the shadows uh bringing uh
yes so uh so yes we we've started this
society that is trying to break the
boundaries of traditional disciplines uh
we began with you know our humble
beginnings here in in Spain as group of
students and then we're actually during
the pandemic we realized let's try and
uh you know go for the shoot for the
stars and just try to get all the
possible most interesting people most
interesting interesting profiles for
people in in our conferences which were
virtual during the pandemic now we're
trying to transition into more in-person
hybrids and so on
um and so the basic goal of the of this
Society is to to as I say break the
traditional boundaries but not in a sort
of methodical way that you just do you
know just destroying for the sake of
distraction and just disrupting but we
go after the fundamental mental
questions right we try to really go deep
for instance
for instance uh questions of you know
what is the nature of reality in a in a
in a scientific sense so for example uh
going down to fundamental physics or uh
studies of cognitive science studies of
uh you know complexity science things
like this that are sort of permeating
are transversal to many different uh
many different fields
um and so the way we've done this so far
we have a podcast
um uh you you have a
links to this I'm sure uh but one way
will be in the description you can also
search the semf as one word all capitals
yes
um yeah so so basically uh I think the
best way to understand what we do is to
check some of the conferences in fact
Michael Levin was here earlier I was a
speaker in in the in the in the last
conference we had we choose a concept A
Very transversal you know General
concept like number uh two years ago
space this year and we try to
um we don't really ask for particular
prescriptions on it exactly we try to
get as many different facets of this
Crystal and so for remember I think it
was very very interesting we got
anything from you know uh psychologists
uh you know uh anthropologists to
mathematicians computer scientists
physicists but even uh we've got some
contributions from uh plan cognition
some people were doing uh the study of
plant remission and sort of intelligence
intelligent Behavior implants and so on
and where were mechanisms that were sort
of counting something in plant physio so
we have this you know after a week then
this conference is last you get this
kaleidoscopic perspective on this
centralized notion of space or sorry
number in this particular example and I
think this is basically what we aspire
to right we want to really gather
everyone around deep questions uh you
know have the space and time to really
go in the directions kind of breaking
the Dynamics of the research industry
that we have that it has has many you
were asking about vices before they have
many advices in this industry of
research it's just you know piecemeal
paper production this kind of thing is
very negative for for you know really
taking the time and exploring all the
all the other interesting questions that
maybe don't produce that much uh
Publications but they're you know
nonetheless the most interesting ones
and so that's kind of what we what we
try to do and we you know we're trying
to set up meetings in person to do
retreats to do sort of research Retreats
intellectual Retreats uh but at the same
time we also want to keep a sort of a
constant flow of podcasts and people you
know invite uh I mean Kurt was there was
a guest that when we talked about the
phenomenon of podcasts and what it means
for scientific communication and the
future of of uh just knowledge diffusion
in in society and so on so yeah I
welcome everyone to I mean it's you know
we are non-profits so everything is as
free as possible we try to be as
approachable as possible there is uh you
know the name suggests we're just a
society which is trying to recruit
people to do common goals right so it's
it's a pleasure to welcome you if you
decide to keep some of the links and be
in the community
great Carlos thank you so much the links
will be in the description so goodbye
goodbye Carlos goodbye it was a pleasure
good to meet you goodbye
good meet you
all right let's talk about UFO so we're
all podcast is here so so let me ask you
guys from this year who was your
favorite person to interview and
specifically why wasn't it's even great
okay I'll let Christina go first and
then you well no Daniel asked you first
so go ahead
yeah I'll take the hosts the host brain
I'm gonna mute everyone except you
Christina I'm sorry
okay you're on the spot all right the my
favorite person that I interviewed this
year on Shifting the Paradigm was
retired Navajo Ranger John Dover
um he absolutely blew my mind with the
research that he did with Skin Walkers
UFOs and Bigfoot and to keep in mind
that he has a badge right being a part
of the police force and not the the
Navajo Rangers but aside from that one
it probably had to be the owner of
Skinwalker Ranch Brandon fugle as well
that interview also blew my mind there
were so many burning questions that I
wanted to ask him that I was given the
privilege to do so but I think all of my
guests they have all taught me something
in this entire year of 2022 so they were
all fantastic but those two in
particular I think really stood out in a
very specific way but I mean the
interviews um of those who I have
burning questions for I bring them on
the show I'm like I have questions for
you I'm going to speak to you ASAP
because I think that when we sit on
those questions for too long either they
dissipate or they become more of a
burning question and I think that when
we have those questions we need to ask
them right away of course after doing a
little bit of research beforehand right
so
Dan before you answer I want to ask both
of you all would it be okay if in
another tab you load up your channels
just the video section because I would
love it if you shared your screen just
to
why don't we go through what the heck
happened in 2022 there's so much there
and just say wow like just reminisce so
Dan if you don't mind pulling that up
and then getting to your answer and then
I'll do the same then Christina I'd like
to see what you've been up to in 2022
yeah well I can do that and let me just
pull that up
uh should I just share my screen here
yeah yeah please are you able to
should be able to
thank you
okay
okay so uh five months let's go back
it's difficult for me to think about toe
and probably it's difficult for you all
to think about your channel but at least
for me when I do I I feel like in such
disbelief I can't believe I get to do
this
and it's just it's such a lucky position
and it's so much fun yeah
absolutely and you we have a whole bunch
of audience members here watching us
today but the truth is all three of us
here would be doing this even if no one
was already so it's just so incredible
that anyone pays attention at all um and
it's really cool to be on that kind of
Journey with people
yeah and thank you all for coming on
thank you
it's fun to see you Christina so I don't
think we met I think we just spoken over
email a couple times
that's right but it's an absolute
pleasure to be here and to speak with so
many other like-minded people because
our community is growing every single
day when I mean our community I mean
everything related to the strange and
the Mysterious and science as well so I
am so grateful to be here with all of
you
yeah me too Dan yeah let's go through
let's start from that's one year ago and
then you'll move upward correct so which
one's your first video yeah
so
this time last year we were you know the
the ndaa has passed with the UAP
language in it uh this time last year we
had another set of UAP language and
legislation passing so we were kind of
this yeah we were we were critiquing
that legislation kind of talking about
what it needs to to be more robust
um and as Leo's gone on as we go through
kind of the uh you know people like Gary
talking about essentially how to make it
a more robust legislation
um so this lower stuff come in we've had
the secure system uh for submitting
information on uh special access
programs and things like that uh so it's
been an amazing year kind of seeing that
develop
side that we've had people like Simeon
high
he does a remote viewing course and kind
of does a lot of work with crop circles
and Bowl lighting
um and this year I was lucky on one of
his reviewing courses and actually kind
of experienced that for myself which was
really interesting
um and I've taught a few people in my
life kind of how to use it and what's
most amazing about it is that not only
does it work but secondly that
it brings along with a whole bunch of
mindfulness kind of skills because
you're all kind of inquiring in wood to
find that voice that aids the remote
viewing so I would say it's a form of
meditation uh we also in February
um self and Vinnie Adams from disclosure
team we went out to Colombia to
investigate uh a light phenomena a
mountain uh and they were called the
dancing lights and we were there for
about two weeks talking to a lot of
witnesses and things like that about
this kind of live laboratory and on the
very last day we actually got to film
The Lights as well so not only did we go
and investigate it we confirmed we're
there we filmed HD video of it and we're
going back in I want to say about three
months
um
so the series has been released that's
on Vimeo
um it's called phenomenology
and yeah you can kind of watch out
translations because even a few times
during it where we we prove things back
that we thought were maybe not prosaic
at the beginning so we're all very
honest about it and there's a nice big
people there that some are more
skeptical some are more practical some
are a bit more woo like myself and we
all balance each other out so I think
it's a really good demonstration of how
you can invest these things and not take
it personally you know
okay let's go through this quick and
just find your favorite for whatever
reason podcast of the year
who or guest of the year
okay so my my guess is going to be
Michelle foney
um she there's a great documentary
called fathom that's all about her and
her team working to essentially decode
whale song
um and it's really quite a profound
touching documentary but for me the
reason that I wanted to talk to her was
because actually she's one of the people
the government would send black
helicopters to get if alien landed
um to kind of try and understand the
communicate and translate and it was
really interesting to hearing her talk
about
the the culture of Wales and how they
interact and how they see the world
um and there was actually a particular
they found that all whales make no
matter what no matter where in the world
they are
um and essentially the sound is the
whale shouting I am and they're not
defined until another whale kind of
shouts I am back and I found that quite
uh profound with a statement there uh so
yeah that was really moving and I'd very
much recommend fathom to anyone one of
these UAP adjacent things
hmm
okay let's go through Christina's
so here is my channel these are videos
but I also do a lot of live streams as
well so here the uh my interview videos
also doing the Paradigm those are
pre-recorded but then my lives such as
weekly strange news and Mysteries with
the history are these ones
um right here we also do some YouTube
shorts on the channel as well looking at
very strange videos and doing some
reacts to that which is uh absolutely a
lot of fun as well so there's a lot of
different content on this channel that I
think that everyone can enjoy
foreign
okay I'll try and
put on
mine so it's the present button
share the screen I will share this one
nope I will share this tab just a moment
let's see this
aha
okay
so this is toe for 2022 let's find it
starting from here which
said there were new announcements uh
somewhere here there was a joke changes
coming right here where I said well you
can watch this if you want and then
people took it seriously some people it
was funny
I think 2022 starts with this and then
we had this yoshapak like all of these
are just bangers so just it's difficult
to choose one that's my favorite I love
Carl friston
loved and loved style oh my gosh of
course now look at that guy look at him
how can you not love him
he's so endearing he's just he's like an
uncle a fun killer
Diana pasoka great okay I want to choose
one let's see
let's see
let's see so I generally my favorite
interview is generally the most recent
one just because that's on my mind so
even though chat GPT was disappointing
in certain ways I loved speaking with it
and so that's that's there but that's
not a person so that doesn't count
let's see
hmm
so tough so tough
it's tough to choose isn't it
Sam what's yours
yeah yeah so you just want to putting
you on the spot I'll say Norman
wildberger just because Norm is so it's
a mathematician on whether the real
numbers are real
what does it mean for a number to be
real
and what's its relationship to
being able to be computed okay here we
go on my back was I there the whole time
you could see me as well or was it just
the screen yeah yeah you you were on the
side and you kind of had the screen on a
separate window
okay yeah
so Sam
which one's yours
yeah nap and call and kill her Nicole
yeah and by the way both are coming on
later today so
you better have something
yeah okay so
Dan and Christina I'm curious
for me
when I'm doing these podcasts
I feel like I'm not so I'm myself in a
certain sense I'll say I'm another
question I have for you is like what's
the difference between my podcast self
and then what I'm like off here but I
feel like my true self
is just what I'm like with my wife like
no one knows
me
the true me is this like hey babe like
this this
I can't even do it it's so embarrassing
just I don't even speak in full
sentences that I and it's like cuddly
and I feel like all of this is just some
presentation anything that's not that
that's not just this cuddly
cute and adoring and endearing and
devoted and tender Kurt along with my
wife then it's just I feel like that's
my true self so I'm curious what's the
difference between
the self the one that we see now and
then what you feel like is your true
self what do you like all fair
I'm I myself in my podcasts it is just
me on my channel but I am I'm burning
with curiosity I have I have these
questions trying to talk to my peers at
College about them as and and about
these questions it's completely
pointless attempting to ask them these
things but for me life is just like one
big mystery just kind of like the
questions that you ask on your channel
Kurt and Dan as well like the big
questions such as was there a big bang
and if so what came before it is there
an all-powerful Creator God are we
living in some kind of simulation what
is the source of our Consciousness why
are we here is there life after death
are we alone in the universe and have we
been visited by sanction beings from
other worlds and other dimensions so
that is the kind of search that I live
for and I have so many questions
regarding that Abby hi there how you
doing
I'm doing great thanks for having me
as a Galileo project is here
he has he has a book called Interstellar
and I will be putting links shortly so
Sam what's the difference between the
Avi that I'm speaking to right now and
then what you feel like is your true Avi
which is off camera you I don't know if
you feel like it's your true self is due
with your wife are you with your family
or is it something else maybe you're out
in nature you feel like that's you
well there is no difference and uh by
the way
um the way I view my body you know I
received it from my parents and just
like buying a car from a dealer you're
not responsible for the parts that make
it and uh so I don't feel any special
connection to what I call myself I mean
I just carry it around with me it's not
as if I understand my internal organs
better than I understand other people's
organs better
um and so um all together
um you know what I'm really curious
about is the you know the universe the
reality that we all share and
um to me that that is a fascinating
Journey trying to figure it out and you
know when I will get closer to death and
that would not frighten me but I was
asked actually today on a podcast what
do I want the writing to be on on my
tune Tombstone and uh I said that's
something that is not particularly
important for me because well first of
all I'm hopeful that every year that
passes and our lifespan will increase by
more than a year so that I will live
forever but if it doesn't happen you
know I would much rather have an
artificial intelligence system an AI
system that sort of follows on my
guiding principles and carries my flame
of Consciousness into the future and
um in a way that will be the same Avi
but now machine learning and you would
be able to interact with it and I think
we are getting to that time where AI
systems will replace people after they
die and you know then I would feel much
better about it because the physical
death of my body is just like you know a
car stopping stops working and you just
put it in a junkyard but if you have a
newer car that functions better and does
the same things then nothing is lost
great great answer Dan so Evan also
Jackson ask him about anything
so tonight yes hello guys so this is the
first time Beckham I'm meeting you isn't
it
[Music]
good evening yeah this is the first time
that's that's right that's right um I'm
not a UFO uh I'm not very knowledgeable
on UFO so I I UFO so I don't know how
much I can contribute to this section
sorry you were in the middle
oh yeah so I I just sounded really
curious when everything about transfer
and his his Consciousness into a new car
so to speak
um does that kind of speak to whether
Abby thinks Consciousness is emergent or
fundamental to the universe
yeah I do think that we are just a
complex machine you see and uh the way
to prove it is if we construct out of
silicon computers that would be sentient
you know that we will have a sentient AI
hopefully within a decade or maybe
already in some places
um you know then it will be clear that
it's an emergent phenomena if you can't
tell the difference between uh an AI
system and a human then there is no
difference okay because uh you know we
are complex and obviously we imagine
that there is something extra but
um you know I think death of a person
might be just like unplugging a computer
from the wall and ultimately when we
will have sentient AI systems we will
not be allowed to unplug them from the
wall just like we are not allowed to
pull a trigger and kill a person of
course there could be Electric outages
that are unintended
because there is something I like to say
about this if
you please go Jack please jump in please
yeah it may be stupid but it's uh the
way I think about this about artificial
intelligence it's in the end it may look
like uh sentience that's always the
question does it rather look like
sentient so Consciousness or is it
really conscience but the my main
problem with artificial intelligence
being well conscience or not or sentient
is that sure we do we train artificial
intelligence to do certain stuff but in
the end the program is the one who
selects
which
Direction the AI should go in you
if you're a programmer you have certain
weights to certain
um
endpoints you want to reach so yeah I
assume that you don't have children
no right because if you had children you
would realize that their parents have a
very important role to play when they
educate a child as to what the child is
thinking
and I don't see any difference between
educating a child and guiding a very
sophisticated AI algorithm so that at
the end of the day you know millions or
billions of people will not be able to
tell the difference between them
chatting with that AI system and them
chatting with a person now you can
always think that we are we have a
superiority but this is just wishful
thinking if you if nobody can tell the
difference then there is no difference
well it's necessary not necessarily
superiority it's just there's a certain
thing going on that we don't understand
and that is that is how we we make these
value judgments in the first place so we
can teach an AI to uh approach a certain
direction we like but we cannot
necessarily formalize the way we do this
what I'm telling you is that when you
educate a kid
you are also doing the same thing
yes but the kid already has a propensity
to uh use that same system that that
uses values and we don't know exactly
how that works at least that's that's if
I listen to John for fakey or things
like that humans are not computers and
there are there's there are some good
reasons
you can wishfully say humans are not
computer you can wishfully say oh the
computer is dumb you know it's just a
machine I'm superior you can say a lot
of things but as a matter of fact if I
have the touring test to billions of
people for decades and nobody can tell
the difference between a computer and a
person then to me there is no difference
now you can talk philosophically about
differences but if there is no way to
tell the difference then there is no
difference that's fair enough that's
fair enough because I do agree with you
that that level you know probably in our
lifetime become a point that that we
will not be able to tell the difference
at least through through chat the next
problem is making a side work that
actually looks like a human and
muscles that actually work
we were talking about Consciousness and
if you ever I actually had Stephen
Hawking at my home okay Stephen Hawking
could not move a muscle
okay so it's not a matter of being cool
or not cool I'm just telling you he
could not move a muscle
he could not he barely moved his eyebrow
so then you are telling me that the body
of Stephen Hawking was actually much
more than the body of a computer no
because both of them cannot behave like
a cyborg I don't need a cyborg in order
to definitely Stephen Hawking had
Consciousness nobody doubts yeah yeah I
agree I agree yeah even had affairs with
the people with one of the nurses that
took care of him so obviously he had a
Consciousness it has nothing to do with
having a seaborg reproducing our ability
to run to lift things nothing because he
didn't lift anything he didn't move he
couldn't even move the the chicks on his
face so you would not say that Stephen
Hawking had no consciousness
while on the topic of artificial
intelligence Avi I interviewed back in
2021 and there was one question that I
didn't get to ask and I think now's just
a great moment to ask that and that is
in your opinion what is the percentage
estimate like How likely is it that some
UFOs if not from our world are actually
piloted by AI rather than biological
entities can you give us your thoughts
on this yeah I think it's very likely
because you see um biological creatures
were selected by Natural Evolution to
survive on a rock like the Earth with an
atmosphere and you know quite balanced
conditions if you put them in space
first of all they would not be long
lived enough to survive the journey it
takes even for at the speed of light it
takes tens of thousands of years to
cross the Milky Way galaxy and if you
move with the speed of a chemical rocket
it takes 10
000 times longer so it takes you know
half a billion years to cross the Milky
Way galaxy there is no way a biological
creature would first of all have the
patience and second have the ability to
survive for that long uh in in the
Hazardous conditions of space so my
point is it makes much more sense to
send an AI astronaut once we develop
those sentient systems that can machine
learn adapt to new circumstances they
can be dormant for millions of years so
if we are thinking about those being the
um you know Messengers for us into
Interstellar space other civilizations
probably reach the same conclusions now
this could also include biological
creatures that have augmentation to
their you know organs and with
technological gadgets and devices but my
point is it has to be it cannot be just
biology it has to be technology that
accommodates the you know the weaknesses
of biological systems and and then
therefore if we find anything in our
neighborhood I would you know I would
put my bet on AI systems if they are
functional and then to figure them out
may be difficult may not be trivial we
may need our own AI systems but I
completely agree with you and I think
that's most likely for what we might
find the interesting question is whether
we are really the first civilization
that ever existed on Earth or on Mars
was there a civilization you know a few
billion years ago and when we say two or
three billion years ago we're talking
just about a factor of two uh earlier
and we are we are 4.6 billion years
after the Earth was made or after Mars
were made you know I don't think it's
out of the question that there was a
technological civilization when Mars was
2 billion years old why not a factor of
two on mars or on Earth
apparently sorry you said two billion
years when Mars was 2 billion years old
do you mean that the civilization may
have been on mars or on Earth at that
point
their place because Mars was
similar to Earth in fact it had
habitable conditions before Earth uh
because it occurred earlier and it's
possible that um you know simple biology
started on Mars it's much more likely
that it started on Mars earlier than on
Earth because we believe there was
liquid water over there and all I'm
saying is if it took 4.6 billion years
for us to come to the stage it's
possible that someone else came to the
stage two and a half billion years ago
and in that case when Mars became not so
habitable because if if that
Civilization realized for example that
it's about to lose its atmosphere and
lose all of its liquid water on the
surface they would ask themselves think
about it it would enter the political
discussion on Mars they would ask
themselves what do we do oh there is
this planet next to us called the Earth
and it has no oxygen in the atmosphere
what should we do terraform Earth maybe
we should put you know a mask on Mars
so when when Mars lost its atmosphere
around the same time somewhere between
two to two point five billion years ago
that was exactly the time when there was
a sudden increase in the oxygen level on
Earth before that there was not much
oxygen in the atmosphere around that
time
cyanobacteria started to produce huge
vast amounts of oxygen now of course
most most scientists think well it may
have been just a natural
process that led to that but we don't
know why the Earth's oxygen level in the
atmosphere suddenly jumped at around the
same time when Mars lost its atmosphere
and I say you know maybe someone
terraformed Earth
exam
it's a great response memories
sorry what's one of your earliest
memories and then I keep we keep having
the same intuition just jumping at the
same time I apologize man what were you
gonna say no it's fine
um
I I was just gonna say thank you for
both the question and the answer because
both were really fascinating
thank you uh in terms of first memory to
me the most traumatic memory of my
childhood I had a wonderful childhood
you know in in a on a farm but the most
I mean the the scar that was left by my
childhood was that when I was sitting at
the dinner table with a lot of adults in
the room I would ask a difficult
question and they would just dismiss the
question because they didn't know the
answer and they didn't want to embarrass
themselves by showing ignorance and to
me it was obvious that they don't know
the answer sometimes they would invent
an answer that made no sense and I
thought that by becoming a scientist you
know I will be able to address questions
you know using the scientific method and
figure it out myself but what do I find
in Academia exactly the same phenomena
people pretending they know the answer
in advance not
showing not
admitting that they are ignorant and you
know that's about things that do not
quite line up with what we expect
including the first interest there are
objects
welcome Bernardo castrov of Essentia
Foundation the links will be displayed
on the screen Choice thank you happy
holidays good to see you even sound
effects happy holidays everybody yeah
thank you you're welcome
hey Jack sorry about those sounds if you
keep hearing them that's just this ball
that I'm sitting on I'm it makes noises
so what's New Mexico
and have you met Avi before
pleasure to see you nice to meet you
Bernardo what's new what's what have you
been working on what are you looking
forward to in 20 in 2023 full
um my holidays are over uh in 2023 my
diamond has decreed that I have to write
two books my publisher decreeded that
too so that's uh that helps so I have to
get my act together and not only run
Essentia Foundation but produce
something of my own again as well I only
wrote A Few essays this year nothing
nothing really serious but next year
I'll get serious
do two books do another computer one
computer a year keeps the Mind clear so
that will go on but I have to do some
serious writing that's my New Year's
resolution and my prey
my my wish to God is that the war ends
uh so you are religious is that right
I think I am religious in the original
sense of really God I care very much
about being
connected with something outside time
um and I think that's very important I
think it's the greatest loss of Western
culture since the middle of the 19th
century or so
okay you know if we find X in
extraterrestrial
kid that is smarter than us it may be an
approximation to God
I would I would be very afraid of that
that we would you know follow this this
this this this
alley that leads nowhere saying that we
sort of replace Divinity with
a poor alternative a vessel upon which
we project the numinosity of the Divine
if you know all I'm saying is religious
texts talk about
God creating life creating the universe
and suppose I bring you an advanced
scientific civilization that we can
create life in the laboratory it's not
completely it's not mediocre it's not
inferior it creates life in the
laboratory and it also creates baby
universes in the laboratory it's exactly
what you are hoping for it exists but
it's scientists in a white lab coat that
are doing this it's not something else
would that disappoint you completely I
think that would be literally insane I
think what you just described is not my
notion of divinity at all I think this
is a
we want God to do other than create a
whole universe what else I don't see
Divinity as a personified ego and a kind
of egoic agency that has power over us
that's not my notion of divinity we
didn't talk about ego we just I just
said what that entity can do so what
else can it do that you imagine that is
better than creating a universe
my notion of divinity has very very
little to do with power with what it can
do
we are talking past each other I don't
think we will resolve this in a
15-minute conversation but let the
record just reflect that my my my notion
of divinity that thing I want to have a
relationship with has very very little
to do with everything we just described
that that's not Divinity to me that's
just power it's a very different thing
okay by that by that you didn't Define
it
Bernardo are you able to go into what it
is that you define or you see as
Divinity or you feel as Divinity in a
couple minutes or is that it's going to
mislead rather than probably it will I
would try because uh otherwise people
would think no he makes these statements
and then he runs away and refuses to
Define it so sure sure
just so you know this whole environment
was supposed to be one of a of a pub and
now I feel like this is the one it is
still a pub after a few drinks and you
get into the weeds so let's do the
drinking I'm drinking hydrogen oxide
here and so
I just I mean that's what people know in
case they're thinking that there's some
some anger here this is just like no
it's just how academics talk because if
we just like to question ideas
Divinity to me is not personified it's
not an agent separate from its creation
Divinity is something that transcends
space and time uh Divinity is what
psychology with this would associate
with the notion of numinosity the
numinous Divinity is something that is
because it's outside time you can't say
that it's old or young but you skirt it
you get closer to it if you say
uh it's what was there before the Big
Bang it's what is always there it's the
Fountain Head of
of existence of the Dynamics of the
universe it's it's the most foundational
layer of nature which as most of you
know in my view it is a field of
subjectivity divinity is that field of
subjectivity unencumbered by a
dissociative process and in that sense
it is
um omniscient literally not in the way
we want to understand it as
metacognitively uh conscious of
everything I don't think it is that I
don't think it's metacognitive at all
but it's the foundational layer of our
own being and if you introspect deep
enough which is almost impossible for
the vast majority of us certainly for me
but if I could introspect deep enough
and peel the onion of my being
progressively more and more layers more
and more layers that nothing that would
be left at the end that nothing that is
pregnant with everything that is
divinity
okay I just wanted to clarify I will not
dwell much on this but whatever you said
at the beginning is exactly what I was
saying it's something that happened
before the Big Bang it's just a
scientist in a white lab coat that
created the Big Bang was before time as
we Define it in the Big Bang and is the
source of everything and I just talked
about it as a scientist in a lab coat
you talk about it as something that you
fill your onions on your layers off and
I you know to me I I don't know what
that is I don't know what's left of your
onion layers after you peel them off but
I'm saying the source of everything we
have if it created our big bang
this is a very nice fantasy it's a story
to tell children you know science isn't
a lab coat dressed in a white lab coat
created our universe now cute it's very
cute but of course the intended meaning
that I had when I referred to the Big
Bang was something that existed before
the beginning of time in other words
before the Big Bang of the universe of
your fantasized scientists your super
powerful transhuman scientist whatever
whatever that is that was intended
meaning but look we will talk past each
other because I know where we are coming
from I don't know you but your past few
words already put up you know like an
outdoor board in front of me announcing
where you're coming from and I know that
space very well I spent most of my life
in that space there is no way I will
make sense to you in 15 minutes
this is something we need to spend the
weekend together and then maybe you will
have an intuition for why I say what I
say despite my extremely Western
rational background with two doctorates
and having worked at CERN and all that
stuff
okay
I just wanted to remind you of the
Chicken and the Egg problem you may ask
what was before the chicken there was an
egg and what was laying the egg a
chicken so uh was there something before
the Chicken and the Egg the answer is
yes something else that's the true
answer for what happened on Earth
because we know that before the Chicken
and the Egg existed there was something
else and the same may be true for the
universe that's all I'm saying
okay
all right the theolocution between Avi
lobe and Bernardo Castro's scheduled
it's January 8th 2023. five hours long
so Milestone whilst we're talking about
definitions can I ask Abby Jack
Christina could as well I believe we
were talking about uh Abby you mentioned
Stephen Hawking and and how his life was
you know he he couldn't move uh he used
the computers kind of communicate and
when we think of Being Human we think of
a certain type of person you know two
arms two legs we can talk and that kind
of thing but obviously Stephen Hawking
is a human but just is outside of that
definition so I wanted to ask you all uh
what what do you guys think it mean be
human
um
well I I if you ask me I would say uh
being conscious of the reality that that
we we share uh because many you know at
least some living things we we don't see
a Consciousness in them like you know
plants for example or so of you know
vegetables so in principle uh you know I
would say that being conscious is is
what makes us human it's not so much our
bodily Parts because people lose limbs
you know a soldier that goes to work and
lose a limb uh as long as the soldier is
alive
uh the soldier is human
and then and if you degrade all physical
abilities you end up in a state similar
to Stephen Hawking at the end of his
life but he started from being just like
any of us as a young kid so it's just
that his muscles stopped working and you
know that shows you that if you reduce a
human what remains is simply the
Consciousness that's my take on it and
if we are able to produce AI systems
that are conscious
then we got it you know it's basically
an emergent phenomena that you know
identifies a very complex system
um and there are much more primitive
systems that are alive that are not
capable of this and so when we talk
about humans is because they are able to
understand the reality that they live in
being conscious that would be my
definition and of course many people
would say love you know the fact that we
can relate to each other yeah of course
Dan who's next what's that
uh Christina
okay I'll go next
um first of all I'm still learning what
it is uh to be human and I'm searching
for the answers of like to to what I am
as a Consciousness so I mean like I
cannot fathom death being the end of
Consciousness it doesn't it doesn't make
sense to me it seems like a huge waste
right so I believe that there must be
something more that Consciousness drives
the body but operates from a higher
Dimension that that is where it goes
after bodily death so to be human for me
is to be compassionate to seek answers
and the truth and to share it with
others and to live mindfully with Wonder
and curiosity
beautiful answer uh Jack would you like
to answer
sure I just I never really know what to
do with questions like these like
um what it means to be human
um and the one side you have Avi who
explains what what it means to be what
humans are made of and then you have
Christina asking or explaining what you
can do with that meaning what it means
to you personally
um
but foreign
it's like okay you're conscious you're
conscious being sure but there are more
conscious beings there my God is
conscious too so but my computer isn't
but
um it all happens in Consciousness and
what it means for a human
in contrast to a cat yeah the experience
but how to give a meaningful answer to
that what to do with that information
what what then then I would follow
Christina and and well
and despite what Ivy says love uh love
thy enemy and uh that that that seems to
be like the the way you want to go when
it comes to personal meaning to LA to
what it means to be human so sorry it's
not a real answer but it's all I can
give you
oh I like it positive one uh thank you
so much um Bernardo what would you say
to that question
well we we know what it means to be
Human by being human right there is a
sense in which the question
it doesn't really evoke something that
isn't already known to us by direct
acquaintance we're trying to
conceptualize what we know by direct
acquaintance I'll try to do that since
that's the spirit of the question I
don't think Consciousness is what
defines us as human there is uh
you know we can only infer the the
presence of private conscious in our
life in other beings Beyond ourselves
through their behavior
and there is plenty of Behavioral
evidence that even single-celled
organisms have a private conscious in
their life of their own amoeba build
little houses out of mud particles from
the bottom of the puddle where they live
and they are architected almost like a
snail Shelley it's a conical house
paramecium are known to evade danger
look for food and even have reactions
akin to fear
um so I think that's not what
characterizes our species at all I think
private conscious in their life is what
characterizes life
not um Humanity I think being human is a
it's a state of mind it's a particular
configuration of Consciousness with
certain dispositions
um that that Define what being human is
and and even that is not a very sharp
definition I think because
you know in the undertals were humans
too in the sense of being members of the
genus homo
um but they were not Homo sapiens
sapiens uh so do they differ much from
us I mean I have the Neanderthal genes
as almost all Europeans
um so
now even that even the definition I just
gave you is not a very sound one
AVI has a book called Interstellar he
also has the Galileo project and there's
also several podcast interviews with Avi
as you search His Name Across YouTube
I'm sure you'll find I just I just did I
just did but he's he's his visit card
with me was the worst possible dropping
dropping on me the the alien Gods Theory
and the first opportunities I know I
know but it didn't work very well with
me no but that's fine that's it again
just imagine we're coming into a bar and
you hear different conversations and
they're different Corners nothing's
going to be ideal or well everything's
ideal to you idealism but you understand
what I mean so Dan the the my answer is
that I don't I don't have many
I have ill-formed thoughts about it so I
think if we're to take a rational
approach we would conclude that it's
illusory virtually everything would be
illusory because you take sobriety's
Paradox and you say well if I remove my
finger then I'm Still Human but I've
removed this and and so on the molecules
change so what's the what's human
and then you would say well it's nothing
that you can grasp and there are many
people across the age who have said
something similar I forgot one in
particular maharajan or naharaja
who said about the Chariots look well
what makes the Chariots if you take away
its wheel it's still there and is it the
horse well if you take away the teeth of
a horse and so on so I think that
somehow if you analyze it logically or
rationally quote unquote that you come
to the answer of nothing or that it's
illusory but I don't think I don't think
that that's where you should stop I
don't I also don't think that well
anyway I think some somehow history has
to do with it okay so this is what I've
been thinking about recently
I've been playing around with
mid-journey which is
I can spend
it's talking about an eight hour lesson
uh eight hours 16 hours yeah generating
art on mid-journey but then there's
something soulless about it but what is
it exactly it it's to me almost
certainly in every case produces better
art than the average artist
okay so I'm saying average as a
people when they say you can't say that
but well the average artist is not what
you see most of the time because you see
just uh the Pinnacle sure
okay and I'm including well regardless
but when I was younger and I would go to
museums and I would see there's this
card on the side of a painting I would
discard the card I wouldn't I don't care
about the history I don't want to know
why this person created I don't care
about who who they are I just want to
look at the painting and now I'm
thinking maybe that card was the most
important part of the art
that that knowing about the turmoil of
someone who produced it and what they're
trying to convey what they think they're
trying to convey and the the history of
the place at the time that's a part of
the art and that's what's missing in the
AI art you can generate a picture and
it's fantastic but there's no history of
why the AI is creating it the the
government it's fighting the the
personal issues it's trying to work out
you don't get a sense of that it may be
there and if it's there I would enjoy
the art more if I knew about that if I
could even comprehend what the heck the
AI was trying to express so then I
wonder if there's something about the
way that we got here that makes us not
only human but certain experiences more
real so for instance if you put on a
a VR helmet and you were to you were
able to go to the Grand Canyon to think
there's this thought experiment like is
it different what's different about it
if if like imagine 20 years in the
future when every pixel you cannot tell
the difference and they have wind and
sound and warmth
well what's different is that you put on
a VR headset rather than going there's
something that's different about the
path that you take to get there so
something about path dependence which is
a concept in physics by the way so
there's something that is not just about
the state but how you got to the states
as well that's important so I think
that's important about that's a that's
an important factor that makes us human
but I don't know how to articulate that
[Music]
hello Tony hello hello
meet Bernardo meet Dan meet Christina
meet Jack if you haven't already
some backup
so Bernardo I'm I'm sorry Tony like
because I just got you just came into
the middle of a fairly deep conversation
like one of the deepest what what does
it mean to be human
okay Bernardo what's correct in your
estimation and what's incorrect about
what I just said
I think
um associating
context a life context
to to humanity is perfectly appropriate
I think
you know while we are alive we are state
of mind I think that would be my my sort
of objective hard-nosed answer but uh is
schopenhauer human
of course but he's not alive he's not a
state of mind that's currently out there
what is the humanity of schopenhauer it
is his journey as a human it is the
context of his production as a
philosopher his life context uh it's
it's it's it would be so easy to dismiss
schopenhauer as a misogynist because he
was one if we uh
ignore his life's context the fact that
he was reject and and by his mother very
early and was basically thrown out of
the house by his mother after his father
was already dead
um so yes Humanity the humanity that
survives us as humans is the humanity of
context without that context we will
pass judgment on everyone in history
very bad judgment
okay thank you I'm not apologizing for
his misogynism by the way it was bad
it's bad it will forever be bad it's uh
it's surprising for somebody who is
otherwise so intelligent to to to to
take the Jabs that women that he took
now and then but again context doesn't
allow us to forgive it but allows us to
understand it
mm-hmm
okay well that's a deep topic because to
me there's something about understanding
that
allows for the Forgiveness or it's the
same as but we can talk about that
another time so I have to urinate and
this is a live stream and I'm not
supposed to leave for like eight hours
Christina I'm gonna put you on the spot
and say can you host the toll podcast
Christina for the next five minutes or
so I know that's a long time to urinate
I also want to stretch I just got here
Kurt you can't leave okay yeah Tony I'm
coming right back and you're staying on
for a little while and Bernardo Jack Dan
if any of you have to go in the next
five minutes I'm just gonna say bye now
right here
all right welcome everyone Kristina is
the new host of toe and see you all in a
few minutes
You're Gonna Hate Sam by the way
Christina
all right we're now one two three four
I'm not sure how many hours into the
actual tonanza I wanted to promote a
couple aspects so number one podcast dot
a i is a website where they've had Joe
Rogan interview Steve Jobs and Lex
Friedman interview Richard Feynman the
next one is going to be Kurt J mungle
interviews most likely Carl Jung we're
working on the exact guest this is just
a plug for play dot HT who
powerspodcast.ai you can look at their
technology by going to podcast.ai or
play.ht another aspect I would like to
promote is the patreon again as you can
see this was a tremendous tremendous
amount of effort I'm luckily right now
well rested but this was many restless
nights in the making as well as we have
other plans for the future many many
large plans for 2023 if you would like
to support then visit patreon.com Kurt
jaimungal it's on screen right now you
can support with whatever you like
whether it's a hundred dollars fifty
dollars one dollar every bit makes a
huge difference you may not think so but
every bit helps it certainly helps in
terms of morale so thank you so much the
link again is patreon.com
kurtjimungel the last component that I
wanted to promote is the Discord and
that link again will be shown on screen
here's the invite code in particular I
wanted to thank some of the moderators
Gibbs mystery bear Rajesh spiral Source
name is Namaz J I'm gonna mispronounce
that Nam as J big fill combo and other
users who are frequently commenting and
putting out quality conversation kubaj
or cubbage I'm not sure how to pronounce
that time cake Eric lordy benjay endless
Kettle Kali and Pythagoras whole there
are countless others you can just look
through and you'll see that this is a
place where people propose their own
toes critique other people's toes delve
into certain aspects of existing toes
and again that link is on screen there's
also a subreddit reddit.com R theories
of everything there's also memes place
are slash Kurt J mungle memes
well since since Tony just entered Tony
gives a little bit of a background of
who you are and what your research
entails for those that may not be
familiar with your work
well
um I'm a design build contractor in
Tennessee and I live in the bayports now
I noticed most of my most of the most
intelligent guests had libraries behind
them so I'm I'm broadcasting from the
Trinity College in Dublin Library and so
that's the only way to do it Tony so I
represent the uh the Layman of the bunch
I think but I haven't I've been
interested in this field you know for I
mean all my life practically and
um I I really wanted to share something
that I created when Kurt gets back and
this goes along with with something
Bernardo was talking about it's a graph
that I created and um
so I don't want to get into it too much
if you don't mind until Kurt gets back
because I want to hear his input but um
I appreciate being here and uh it should
be fun I hope it does lighten up a bit
because I I know I've met I've talked
with Avi I I've actually volunteered
um the Galileo project early on doing
some CAD work I'm a design build
contractor I do design work and they're
they're really just like by the book
they're like like you if you get them in
the bar they're still going to be you
know
you know down the line you know straight
straight by the book and uh oh God I do
find it easier to to debate on you when
he's not here so I have I drew this for
when after he left so and I'm also aware
that you make some music as well is that
correct
most of the music is made by my sons a
very
I was a musician earlier in life uh
that's I got them involved with music
when they were young and now they're
professional you know Alex is a
producer you know of music and Barrett
teaches and also is a content creator so
I've tried to I've tried to you know
influence them as much as I can they're
obviously much more talented than I am
now regarding music but um
my music changed her much more you know
Tennessee Deep Woods banjo and there's a
little more hip than my
mind so well I have a question for the
entire room and that is what was your
favorite news story of 2022 about UFOs
or whatever mysterious topics that
you've looked into throughout the year
let's start with Dan
so I'm gonna go I'll go for one of the
kind of low-hanging fruit here and say
the James Webb Telescope over the past
year we've seen it go from a thing that
maybe would work we weren't really sure
we were thrown out into space and see if
you know it could produce images that
were better than Hubble then the test
blew people's minds that was like a
thousand times better than Hubble and
then it keeps giving us these images the
the makers reflect on on a kind of in
condition and asking what's out there
and questioning what we know about the
cosmos and already it's kind of upending
some of the science you know
10 15 years ago we didn't think they
were exop and it's now they're a kind of
dime a dozen then the James Wood is
constantly just
made us look at the universe through a
different lens I think my my favorite
particularly new story from it wasn't
the first image but was the image of I
think it was uh Neptune with the rings
around it and people weren't kind of
accustomed to seeing the rings around it
but they beat it they've been there for
as long as the planet's been there it
took us building that lens to be able to
see reality in that way and I think
that's kind of a a potent point about
how we look at the universe
and if you don't mind me asking Dan if
you can just very briefly touch on
what's so special about the James Webb
Space Telescope for those that may not
be aware
yeah so I mean in in a kind of a tldr
what
um it's like going from VHS to DVD
um whilst looking at the universe it's
looking at the length of light it has a
few different instruments that look at
wavelengths
um so we're literally seeing things that
we were unable to see before
very cool and Jack what about yourself
what was your favorite new story of 2022
tough one I think I have to choose
between the Nobel Prize for the
physicist who could prove that
local reality isn't true I think
Bernardo could expand on that if he
probably much better than I I can but
but I think I read today or yesterday
that they found bacteria that could eat
viruses and somehow I think that
personally much more interesting I don't
know why but because I also found
bacteria that could break down plastic
so there's there's that's some hopeful
news
there you go that's very cool and
Bernardo what about yourself
oh my heart is torn across three I'll
mention him briefly and you take a pic
the proof of principle of nuclear fusion
was something that will be in the annals
of history for centuries to come
um and two breakthroughs in
immunotherapy for cancer
one for rectal cancer and one that's
probably applicable to many many
different forms of cancer one in the U.S
one in the UK it's for the first time in
my lifetime that I hear cancer news that
truly may be the beginning of something
and not just you know something that
cannot be replicated or is only
applicable to a very specific form of
cancer now these two things these opened
doors here so I think we will remember
2022 first and foremost for the
catastrophe of what Russia is doing in
the European continent after we thought
large-scale war was a 20th century thing
but we will also remember 22 2022 for
the fusion breakthrough and the
immunotherapy Breakthrough for for
cancer therapy
and Tony what about yourself
I literally was going to say you break
these breakthroughs and fusion
um also because
you know one of my disappointments
honestly with science is that and I drew
this graph while Avi was speaking is
that I feel like that our I'll just say
it
um this is this is scientifical okay I
can get it to where it's not so this
devil the devil dashed line is the
this is AI okay and as what's the
background is going crazy in it so as
the as the ability of AI
gets greater over time
than the Practical knowledge of humans
uh goes down
like this and at some point at some
point there will be a point where humans
cannot uh decide you know between the
two because of our I believe at some
point we will the knowledge the uh what
am I trying to say there's a gap but
that's widening between practical
knowledge and science you know practical
science and theoretical science there's
a the Gap is widening right a lot of the
you know this is just my intuition one
of the things I was born with I think
was a great intuition and my
intermission tells me that there the Gap
is widening so to the to the extent that
the the Practical things like the fusion
discoveries and continuing how long have
we been working on Fusion Bernardo for
40 years or something fitting longer
than that 50.
um that 17 17 yeah yeah so so that that
it seems like there's a gap and it's
growing and the more scientists that
make the jump to just being theoretical
then maybe I'm wrong but again this is
my intuition that's talking not there's
no proof of this well I think you are
120 right and you touched on one of the
greatest dangers to civilization
[Laughter]
but it's just you know you get this this
um
I've seen it in one of my challenges for
people you know in 2023 is to get back
to the new and away from the woo that's
my new that's my challenge for and the
new is to get going back to the Grind of
science you know grinding out those
those experiments doing the hard work
you know people give Einstein a hard
time because of his reluctance to you
know to jump on board with the quantum
mechanics but he may end up ultimately
being correct you know so uh
laughs who were you talking about oh
Einstein yeah yeah
that and again these are not I'm not you
know these are my my Impressions I don't
have a lot of knowledge to back them up
these are just Impressions I formed over
the last I turned 60 in October so Tony
thank you so much for answering that
Kurt before I pass a show back on to you
let me ask you that same question what
was your favorite news story of 2022
about science physics UFOs or whatever
mysterious topic that you've looked into
you you should answer this as well
Christina because you probably have a
great answer
it has to be mysterious it can be
anything that you found fascinating in
the year 2022. so so maybe this was
because I was going through
remember earlier John verakee referenced
The Dark Knight of the Soul so I was
going through some extreme turmoil
and
what fascinated me the most was the
Johnny Depp trial
I go oh my gosh I was just tuned into
that
I'm not a reality TV person but I can
understand what it's like to watch
reality TV
that was riveting
so
so that that I I absolutely loved I know
that's not a terribly intellectual
answer in the sense like maybe there's a
Nobel Prize in physics and then there's
no confusion
and then there's more heavy topics
events like the Ukrainian War
well for me in terms of what enthralled
me the most well it was that but mainly
because I had to distract myself because
I was so pulled in some other direction
and as for something more serious
something more research-based I have to
think about that what's your answer
Christina well I was going to say while
that Johnny Depp thing was really
enticing for many it was really
unfortunate that the UFO Congressional
hearing happened at the exact same time
as that celebrity hearing so there
weren't that many people interested in
the in the UFO Congressional hearing but
everyone was all interested in Johnny
Depp and Amber Heard is that her name
and so I found that like kind of sad but
I did really enjoy
um that particular hearing especially
with Gallagher I think he was the star
of the show asking all the hardball
questions to Moultrie and Bray but I
think as for the most
interesting news item of 2022 I'm gonna
have to agree with Dan on this one I
think the when we we got our first
images from the James Webb Space
Telescope searching for biosignatures in
the atmospheres of exoplanets that's
really exciting and our future seems
bright in that aspect
thanks Christina it's amazing I think
that how much data they've like brought
in and they're still going through the
data I saw someone in the comments say
they should take a photograph of both
with the James Webb Telescope and and I
wanted to write back where I couldn't
but they have and we'll see that data
soon and it's going to be really
exciting to see what they think about
what it looks like so we can compare it
you know
um it doesn't need to be now but uh
before I leave I wanted to amplify what
Tony said I don't think every anybody
else is latching on to that but I think
he just
he just said the thing that needs to be
said and I would like an opportunity to
amplify that at some point doesn't need
to be in our career well I I if I if I
hear you correctly it was going to be my
next point if I'm to speak about
something more cerebral or scholarly
that has captured my attention this year
it's about AI and I think that so
there's so many advances in AI in Ai and
there are different critical points for
different types of technology so for
instance when it comes to
electric vehicles apparently when you
hit the five percent Mark of people
having electric vehicles that's a
critical point because afterward
adoption accelerates
I think this year we've hit a critical
point in AI
to the point where
this podcast is going to focus more on
AI and it's it's something I never
thought that I would and I'm focused I'm
interested in it from its technological
applications how it works its
relationship to Consciousness but also
the threat I think that the people who
are and I said this on someone's podcast
Martin so sorry Martin if I didn't give
you an invite to this I apologize by the
way I was on Martin Willis's show where
he interviewed me about UFOs physics and
Consciousness the link is in the
description
I think that the people who are working
for open Ai and Google Google brain and
Microsoft and so on that they're like
the engineers sorry they're like the
physicists of the
late 1930s and early 1940s working on
the bomb the atomic bomb where they're
so
jazzed about the physics of it that
they're not thinking about what are they
creating
and I think that something will happen
where they're going to be like Einstein
who said I'm paraphrasing he'd burn his
fingers or he'd burn his hands if he had
known that his creation would have
produced that
I think that the people who are working
for open AI they think in terms of
like like I mentioned again this to
Martin that we're having such fun
talking about these subjects but it's
much more fun to work on these subjects
to engine to actually work on the
engineering
they're I don't think they're thinking
about
I don't firstly I don't think they're
thinking much about the implications
unless it's something positive and then
they're deluding themselves that it will
only be used in a positive sense or that
it could only be used in a positive
sense and I also think that they may be
thinking well look if I'm not working on
on AI someone else will that reminds me
of this movie I think it's called Lord
of War with Nicholas Cage where he said
hey I'm gonna be a weapons dealer
because if I'm not someone else is just
going to take my place and I think
that's a poor an extremely poor position
to be in and a poor decision to be made
I think that you should constantly worry
about am I keeping my own hands clean
and not worry about if someone else is
going to dirty their hands in place of
me
so I think that I think that the people
who are working who are engineering
these
these monstrosities in the positive and
negative sense
may they
I say may because it's uncertain but may
burn their hands
or may wish that they had okay Bernardo
I'm going to let in I'm going to
introduce by ashdakar physicist here and
then
I'm going to let you wrap up as you have
to leave
and and perhaps even say hi to the
founder of loop quantum gravity one of
the founders of I asked the car
legendary physicist
thank you thank you for coming on this
screen it's an honor
it's an honor
thank you it's a pleasure for me to join
you all
so just just to give you all some
context
ashdakar has been on the tow podcast
before and he if you've heard about
quantum gravity there are there's an
approach called Loop quantum gravity and
ashtakar is one of the it would not be
the whole field of loop quantum gravity
wouldn't be here if not for ashtakar or
maybe it would just be it would be
pushed by decades and advancing he's a
humble person so he would disagree with
that but
either way it's just it's an honor to
have you here and and I also respect you
because you talk about the two spheres
that is the inner world and the outer
world and that physics just explores the
outer
thank you for coming on
hello it's my pleasure
so we were talking about what is it I
believe Christina I didn't hear the
original question but it was something
about 2022 and what sticks out to us
scientifically from it or your your
favorite news item of 2022.
in the field that you specialize in
and I believe Bernardo Castro Bernardo
you have to get going so no no no if you
don't I don't have to get going I just I
just didn't want Tony's point to be lost
as we move on to other things okay so
I'm I'm not sure if I hit Tony's point
so Bernardo do you mind just touching on
it before this gives Professor some time
to think about that 2022 question so I
will express my possible
misunderstanding of Tony's Point
um I think the graph he showed what he
shows is that because we have so many
tools that automate things for us and
with the Advent of AI this is
accelerating
um everything is getting automated we
don't need to think about things anymore
we are retreating into a world of pure
conceptual abstraction and sort of
losing touch with reality with the
reality of building something with your
hands with the reality and it doesn't
need to be low Tech even high tech I
mean if I can express some of my
perennial frustrations there are two
Fields very close to me which sometimes
I fear are getting lost in in conceptual
abstraction one is computer science it
has separated itself from computer
engineering to the point that computer
scientists now that are doing the
talk show around and the podcast round
they don't really know what a computer
is because they're operating on layers
and layers and layers of abstraction
libraries and apis and whatnot and and
and then you can get into a situation
there you say well if the Silicon
computer is sophisticated enough maybe
it's conscious that's what you get when
you get lost in abstraction another
field that I think and and this is not
uh I'm not saying this because because
ashtaker is here and and I don't
think he is an example of what I'm about
to say an example of what I'm about to
say is precisely the person who wrote a
book called The Lost in abstraction
um which is theoretical physics if it
departs too much from experimental
physics from you know the raw reality of
what you have to do to see a physical
effect on a measurement surface
I don't think it is good
um
I I worked at CERN uh for for a couple
of years and to mention an explicit
example I'm not going after this
person's gratuitously it just happens to
be a good example for what I'm trying to
say zabini hosenfelder who is famous for
the statement loss and abstraction
I think she's completely lost in
abstraction
I think the the entire point of super
determinism is based on those hidden
variables that nobody defined
and you're trying to propose an
experiment that needs to control for the
initial conditions of these variables
without defining them I mean if somebody
had spent time doing experimental
physics you would know that we would
never have found the Higgs boson if a
physicist Peter Higgs hasn't had hadn't
defined for us what the Higgs boson is
what is the energy range where we expect
to find it what does it decay into very
important because we never measure the
Higgs boson directly it decays quickly
what interacts with measurement surfaces
are are the footprint of the Higgs it's
what it decays into and Peter Higgs gave
us hints about that to bottom quarks
maybe a w and z boson now we know even
two muons uh can can be the result of
the decay of the Higgs boson and I was
there building this stuff to to find the
Higgs boson and we built it based on the
knowledge of what it would Decay into so
the second level trigger in the data
acquisition system of the atlas is based
on rejecting events that have Jets and
no heavy electrons or muons it's it's
part of it so without grounding theory
on experimentally verifiable things that
allow us to build an experiment one is
lost in abstraction and super
determinism is a is a
is a cruel example of that because it
comes from somebody who makes this point
that we shouldn't be lost in abstraction
well congratulations then don't be lost
in abstraction give us a theoretical
handle that allow allows us to verify
and disprove the hypothesis and not to
propose experiments that are so vague as
to be impossible to do and even if we
could do them they wouldn't never
disprove the hypothesis because you can
ever you can always say well the
experiment failed because we couldn't
control the initial conditions for the
hidden variables well why not because
you haven't defined them how can we
control for the initial conditions and
and these are examples I think Tony I
don't know whether I'm taking you too
far but these are examples where we lose
touch with the concreteness of things we
can hold in our hands you know I don't
know scintillating scintillating tile in
a tile calorimeter you know touch that
thing see it feed a photo multiplier and
then you are close to reality or in
computer science build a darn computer
no one computer a year keeps the Mind
clear build one build a toy computer but
ground your computer science in real
stuff
and not in a lost world of pure
ungrounded conceptual abstraction and
that's what's happening and AI will make
it worse how many people today own a car
and a house without knowing how
to change a fuse or a tire
I mean or to fix uh something in the
roof I mean this is concerning uh I
I used to be in semiconductors
manufacturing for many years I I I would
tell you a few years ago I think it's
much worse now that there are about 2
000 people in the world who know how to
start from Sand
and end up with an Apple Macintosh
about two thousand it's probably less
now you know if those two thousand
people tomorrow selectively die we're
screwed
and and and that's the problem and and I
think Tony's graph shows that this is
only going to get worse especially with
AI that is replacing us for the basic
things with which we maintain
friction with reality
all right thank you Bernard I guess
since you mentioned me as a theoretical
physicist I I just want to say that I
completely agree with you that you know
that that has to be much more grounding
with the with the reality of the
experiments with uh so but I don't agree
that everybody has to build a computer
if I try to build a computer myself I'll
probably break so many things and it's
not worth it but on the other hand I
should be aware computer scientists
should build a computer yeah okay but I
mean I'm not sure that I can actually
things do things the photo multipliers
either
but on the other hand you know I know
what they do and I know you know so that
I the basic point I agree with you and I
think that there is a tendency for
example in string theory to move way too
far away from the actual physical world
and then you just Define certain things
to be interesting even though they have
nothing to do with the actual world we
live in and I think that is not a good
direction so I basically the fundamental
level I agree with you
I feel passionate about this because I
got burned very early in my life when I
was at CERN I was in my early 20s and
you know the media talks about you know
the LHC and the atlas the CMS being all
about finding the Higgs boson people who
were there knew it was not about that we
had events of the Higgs boson since the
LEP
um that we just didn't have the
statistics I was doing this for Susie
for supersymmetry because I thought this
is so beautiful it has to be true it
just has to be true it cannot not be
true and it's not true
and and that burn be pre-band and uh so
that's yeah it's echoing in my heart due
to this day yeah I have a I have a
question for both of you
um if you don't mind
um well we not at some point in the
future find that there is a physical
connection between things like
Consciousness in our brain and then
physical connections between entangled
partial particles you know what I mean
I'm a physical type of person and I
would I would love to think that it's
not woo that eventually we will be able
to drill down enough to be able to find
these connections between
there's so many people outside of
science especially on social media have
this tendency to create this uh sort of
mysterious world around you know it's
like living in a simulation you know we
can't imagine that there might be a
physical connection between entangled
particles light years away or I mean is
that is that question even makes sense
oh I'm sorry Professor I just wanted to
introduce Kevin knuth is in the house so
Kevin knuth thank you for joining
and thank you for having me
yeah of course I'm so glad you can make
it as well
you're I I don't want to butcher your
introduction and I apologize if I'm
asking you to introduce yourself but I
will bolster what you say and I know
that you're the editor-in-chief of the
entropy Journal as well as as well as
being a physics Professor but but please
could you just briefly introduce
yourself and then ashtakar Professor
ashtakar I miss colleague you asked
constantly sorry about that no no you
can finish what you were saying and
there's so many people that are so glad
to see all of you Bernardo Tony Jack Dan
Christina avai ashtakar Kevin so thank
you all for coming out to this like this
just fun event on our on a New Year's
Eve Eve I'm just hanging out thank you
Kevin
oh great thank you well thank you so
much for having me I'm
excited to be here and um I'm a
professor Kevin knuth I'm an associate
professor of physics at the University
at Albany
and um
and I also work with uapx to study uaps
and as Kurt said I was I'm also the
editor-in-chief of the journal entropy
great great okay Professor I interrupted
you please well I'm just saying that in
general terms I completely agree that uh
that there is actually a con kind of a
relation between you know our
Consciousness or like equality in the
world and also the Auto World
uh there's that and I think as
Neuroscience advances to what is
actually finding circuits in the brain
which give us this sense of me I
Etc and then when these circuits are
Switched Off by meditation for example
and this is something that actually has
been done at the Yale
the Yale Laboratories that one actually
finds that these people have an
experience in which there is no such
contact with the with the usual sense of
ego
and there's a very different kind of
existence people have been talking about
it forever you know I mean both in the
you can go back in literature all across
the world uh starting with you know in
India and the
vedanta literature Buddha literature Etc
uh then we also have the delicious in
Turkey the literature that came down to
Eunice and Embry for example uh the the
beautiful poet poems you wrote I mean
you you see some Universal experience
and it seems that that Universal
experience is actually being connected
to actual Science Now namely that it is
I mean it's not explanation of these
experiences but it's a correlation
between those experiences and what
actually happens in the circuits in the
brain to me that is kind of a very nice
coming together gradual slowly
of this various ideas as for
entanglement specifically that you ask
there doesn't seem to be any direct
relation between that and uh and and the
Brain I mean the brain seems to be a
little bit too not too wet too hot place
that could cause Deco areas rather
rapidly and this is a hot debate that is
being you know that has been going on uh
but at the moment I mean this the
scientists from Neuroscience actually
are of the opinion that that
entanglement does not have a big role to
play and they may be wrong just because
of the coherence effects
yeah I'm sorry I meant the connections
between particles not connection between
our Consciousness and entangled
particles ah yeah and before you answer
that Professor Dan has to get going so
Dan thank you so much for for being here
I appreciate it and there's the signals
on screen right now as well as that UFO
podcast is the podcast Dan's a part of
and there's also a fundraiser if I'm not
mistaken
yeah that's right so so we're doing a
fundraiser where you can win
um a whole bunch of different prizes
some really awesome ones but the top
prize is a call with lu Elizondo himself
um so the URL for that is tinyurl.com if
you need forward slash UAP media raffle
um and that will be drawn you've got
until March so there's plenty of time
um so yeah to help out two great hoses
uh it's for the Humane Society
International and cash flow kids in the
UK which really directly help families
around this time of year so both really
good courses so any any entries that are
appreciated but
I just wanted to say thank you so much
to everyone for helping me Christina you
smashed hosting so uh Jack lovely to
meet you bonado amazingly provoking
points
um answers and Tony I think this is the
first time we've met but it's amazing to
finally connect
um ashtaker I wish I had more time to
kind of listen you talk it's fascinating
and Kevin
I think I've hit about 20 hours of
listening to you give lectures and I
know everyone here is in for an absolute
treat with you just coming in so thank
you for your work and thank you for
putting this together
have a great New Year everyone
thanks for coming down
bye-bye sorry Professor astric are you
were in the middle and then also Kevin
just something to chew on in the media
in the meantime is the question which
I'm taking from Christina of what is it
about 2022 that is at the Forefront of
your mind
so what strikes you as something that's
most memorable
yes not for that question but for
answering Tony's question
yeah so told this question was about uh
entanglement of actual particles is that
what you're saying
I was I was asking is there is the
current you know schema to think that
there are actual physical connections
between entangled articles or I guess
this is really directed at the woo I I
would like to get back to more of a
physical science than a physics science
you know no yeah that's right so the
entitlement actually is real and there
is no question about it and that
actually that that can be Quantum
entangled or kilometer scales and this
is I mean the person answered the
Christina's question was one of the
exciting things for me was this Nobel
Prize which was given for Quantum
information and particularly for Antoine
ziding there who was the first person to
really push these things I mean not
entanglement but the technological
aspects of an attacker meant to showing
that in fact this thing doesn't really
exists or several kilometers you know
that is actually being used for things
like you know this course for for
banking systems so it's actually
actually has had because it can go
kilometers so it is like I mean it's
real there's just no question about it
and thank you may be physical particles
is absolutely real and it's even finding
applications
so Kevin
what so Professor knuth what what about
2022
is most memorable to you
I think the most memorable thing is the
fact that there are now a large number
of scientific groups or scientists
groups of scientists that are studying
uaps and
and we are to some degree working
together we
you know many of us know each other and
and talk to each other and have you know
well before these groups were set up and
and some of us are just meeting each
other for the first time now so um this
is
I think they that you have uh a
Groundswell you have
a significant change and
this is now pretty much what I would
think to be unstoppable
um the study of these objects or
phenomena
um you know there's always a concern
that
oh the you know the US government will
lock down and they'll stop disclosing
information or you know and we keep
worrying about disclosure but I don't
think disclosure matters anymore I think
it it now is up to
up to scientists to study these things
is real phenomena and
and learn about them find out what they
are and how they work and I think that's
that's happening and it's and the number
of people are growing
our uapx team we I think we added four
or five new scientists this year so it's
um and probably going to add even more
still
congrats man
oh all right
okay let's be let's just
oh all right that's fine that's also an
option
so let's talk about
something light-hearted what what is it
that you do Kevin for just for fun and
and same Bernardo and Tony I'm curious
for fun
yeah that has nothing to do because
often we'll say well yeah we can there
are many hobbies that we do
to disengage but the point was in order
to
to to allow us to fully engage later
well that's like we're taking time off
work in order to work so I'm not
counting that just your vices
right oh I see
um I love I like to
uh restore and identify ancient coins
like Roman coins and Greek coins that's
a hobby that I have that's
relaxing
and collecting them too like like
collect them and yeah I typically
um get unclean ones so they're horribly
dirty with 2 000 years of crud on them
and and then you work to clean them and
restore them and and find that
relaxing and fun and it's fun when you
you know realize that you could actually
figure out what the coin is where it's
from who who's on it and all of this and
then then actually doing so is also fun
it's a bit of detective work so that's a
fun thing that I do
yeah the other thing is I do is I'm
working to build
um my own astromeicroid like a large
life size if you will R2D2 like building
my own oh Droid Droid so so I work on
him as well and so
do you like the Mandalorian or any of
the new Star Wars shows on Disney oh and
it was fantastic I Thought I Loved I
loved Andor
Tony what's your answer
uh I think um I love this idea of trying
to I just turned 60 in October and I'm I
guess we all go through the space where
we want to kind of document our life for
our children I do because when I was
growing up my parents weren't very like
they were very Elusive and I didn't
learn anything about some of their past
and feel like late in life so I'm
writing this book called The Artisan
philosophy and it'll be out in January
I've been working on it for like seven
years and here's a picture I'll share
it's me on a roof in
1979. yeah it's getting
removed so I'm ready to put it in front
of me don't just hold it over your body
yeah here we go it's more like a a
picture book of um
you know of the past and some of the
history local history and uh then it
goes into
[Music]
um
how how we've lost the uh the uh idea of
mentorship and apprenticeships and how
you know people I think if have a
certain skill level when they get my age
let's just start mentoring young younger
people and inspiring them to become you
know
that they can become successful and
happy and just normal jobs you know I
started off as a child playing with
talking trucks and now I'm a design
build contractor and I'm very happy so
I'm just trying to learn how to write
it's kind of funny you mentioned chat
GPT earlier I took a couple of
paragraphs of my book and put it in
there and it slaughtered it and so now
I'm all worried that I'm concerned about
it anyway I was just kind of kidding
around about that but yeah I'm trying to
learn how to write to be honest with you
that's a hobby turn to learn how to
write yeah I'm trying to I'm writing
this book and I'm not a very good writer
so I have a quandary Bernardo
[Music]
I love building 8-bit computers from
scratch
yeah I do about one a year
open source so it gets picked up by
companies and the latest one was just
picked up by a company from Eastern
Europe called olimax they are selling it
now
I restore very old compute actually I
can show you
uh let me see if I if it will work do
you see a computer more or less in the
center of the screen right now in the
shadow
that is a q1 computer
it's the q1s were the first
microcomputers in other words
self-contained Computing systems with a
microprocessor inside they came out in
December of 72 and there are three or
four surviving units one of them you'd
have just seen and I am reverse
engineering documenting and restoring it
in a collaboration across three museums
one in Sweden one in Germany one here in
the Netherlands I I volunteer for the
one in the Netherlands
and um and this year I'm building
um a mini computer
using now those Old 74 logic chips which
are like the little building blocks of
the original I I can show you but I I
have I have to go to my workbench back
here to pick it up but um it has
hundreds of chips four different cards
just for fun
I'll turn off my camera for a second
yeah sure sure bring your cat too
all right I'm gonna let in
Anthony mativier
hey how's it going
good to see you it's been how long
well definitely long
longer than short that's for sure
so I'm gonna place the links to your
memory detective in the in the
description and just for people
Anthony's a memory expert so if you have
any questions about how do you increase
your memory or you want to memorize some
set of facts or some
I don't know a ritual whatever it is you
can you can place those questions I will
help you stick it
I need that great okay Bernardo
sorry this one I just finished the
computer has five boards
this is the control board it's the most
important one
I just finished two days ago
then this is the addressing logic board
here yeah cool cool
and then oops oh no oh shoot oh I'm
sorry Bernardo dude
good job that's a good one man and the
final one the ALU board so this is what
I've been doing for fun
great man
okay well we'll talk after Bernardo
because I need some I have some
questions about that no that's it it's
just an old-fashioned mini computer with
a custom risk CPU that's and everything
that you do that's for fun is something
I consider that to be cerebral maybe you
consider that to be more bodily because
you're now like a carpenter where you
can you don't have to think much as
you're creating it yeah I can I can
measure the signal with an oscilloscope
I see what it is I use a Multimeter I
probe and I see and I and and the
wonderful thing about Computer
Engineering which we don't have in
philosophy yet is that your [ __ ] is
short-lived if you do something wrong it
doesn't work that's it it's the end of
that story one philosophy people insist
on their [ __ ] for an entire career
because there is no immediate and and in
controversial way to just say this is
nonsense stop it move on abandon it it
doesn't work and and and computer
engineering is very grounding for a
philosopher like me
so Christina has to get going in just a
few moments Christina I want to say
thank you so much for for being here and
co-hosting a bit
thank you so much for the opportunity to
be and to help you co-host as well that
I think that's a it's off my bucket list
of things to do but but thank you
um for bringing so many Brilliant Minds
in this eight hour show which again is
insane like that that's a lot of
dedication right there but I am so
grateful to to be a part of it so thank
you so much um for those that are
interested you can find me on YouTube at
Christina Gomez no h or on my website at
strangeparadigms.com
thank you and the links to all that will
be in the description okay now Anthony
you just came in please introduce
yourself if you don't mind
I'm so bad at introducing myself because
I'm the guy who's working on having no
self as scientifically and
philosophically as possible
because uh to sort of follow on what
Bernardo just said there I think that's
absolutely right but the thing about
philosophy at least as I construct it
or have learned to construct it probably
better said is it's the thing that we do
when we don't have science and a lot of
philosophers just kind of forget that is
that you know there's things that
science can do and then it doesn't need
to be philosophized about anymore so to
speak so anyway I try to in my work uh
do that sort of analysis like where is
the memory philosophy where's the memory
science where is some sort of absence of
the scientific answer for what memory is
useful to us where is it that you know
we could draw some things from rituals
as you mentioned when you were saying I
could help you memorize a ritual like
where might that be useful and how can
we get the best of all these possible
worlds expand our working memory so that
in the present moment we could actually
juggle as much as possible know our
memory biases and whatever other biases
that there are out there and uh or in
there as the case may be and you know
live the best possible life because of
working on our memory with a deep
what should I say metacognitive
awareness of what this thing is that's
running the different engines if there
is such a thing and that's what I work
on and it's just a blast all the time
so is that an introduction I don't know
that's wonderful that's wonderful and
Jack and and so Jack I know that you're
just here watching but please if you
have any questions well I actually do it
for Anthony yeah I was just yeah sorry I
just popped up
um so
um it's about memory and I heard John
profaky oh I sadly missed because I was
here later than he was yeah I think he
said something along the lines that we
do not have um
um
there we have the memories is fallible
that we do not have an exact copy of
what's happened and that memory is tool
to predict the future not to accurately
describe the post is there something you
can do you seem to be agreeing with me
already or
yeah well I mean the the starting Gambit
is the most
interesting recent memory science to me
they want to get rid of the word memory
it's not sufficient to the Cause right
there's too much like intrapersonal
stuff going on and when you mention for
Becky you know or however I didn't know
how to pronounce it properly but that's
already the interesting thing right
there's so many people pronouncing it
differently and that says that the
memory of that guy is not just in my
head it's in all kinds of heads and then
we can figure out who we're talking
about when there's name pronunciation
stuff so
memory is just so many different things
we're Shifting the ways that we talk
about it as we talk about it and that
makes my work so exciting because
sometimes people are saying well I need
help with this and they're talking about
semantic memory where semantic memory
meets I don't know procedural memory or
other times they're talking about things
that really aren't memory issues but
because in their minds they think oh the
memory guy must be able to talk about
this really what they're talking about
is something that maybe touches memory
because what doesn't but you know I I
and I just say to them you know that's
not really a memory issue that's maybe
something where you got to go and see a
doctor that was just you know a thing I
have to do more often than not so I
didn't hear what uh was said earlier but
I do think that some of the recent
memory science is on to something when
they said we need a better term or a
broader constellation of terms because
the word memory is not sufficient to the
cause of what we're trying to say about
retention
and recall essentially
interesting thank you and thanks for
being here Anthony oh thank you
someone wants to know Anthony can you
introduce memory methods because the
West is unacquainted and it's very niche
oh well I mean memory methods really
come down to
the idea that you can
elaborate information in a variety of
ways that will help it be more memorable
and just like in a Tai Chi or a Qigong
or any martial art
you can go as deep as you want to go in
terms of how can I elaborate information
to make it more memorable so one of the
key historical strategies has been what
some people call the Memory Palace you
can call it the journey method you can
call it song lines you can call it all
kinds of things but the idea is is your
first level of elaboration when
information is incoming is you stick it
in space
and if you have developed these things
called memory palaces in advance you're
going to be faster at a sort of decision
Matrix where you're going what is that
information where am I going to stick it
and then the next level of elaboration
would be can I add a kinesthetic layer
can I add an auditory layer can I add a
visual layer Etc so if I just look at
Jack I want to remember Jack I'm
thinking well I know a guy named Jack
I'm going to think about his house I'm
going to have Jack Nicholson in his
house I'm going to hear his voice
rattling Batman's cage I'm gonna feel
that weird little thing that he had in
his hand in the uh Batman movie with
that Tim Burton made right and I'm gonna
think of the concept of crime genre meet
superhero and all this stuff right I'm
just elaborating it this is this happens
a lot faster in the memory Champion's
head than it does uh to speak it out
loud but I'm not gonna forget Jack right
I can do that with mega stone toppo
cementa garcori just as easily as I can
do it with a string of digits Etc and uh
some of us get really nerdy about it I
just interviewed yesterday John Graham
who won the 2022 memory championship USA
memory champion chip and he had won the
2018 memory Championship I don't know
exactly how it happens but he said that
I was his mentor on that first win and
uh he's just an amazing guy and all that
stuff that I just said about feeling the
buzzer in the Tim Burton movie and all
that stuff he's like dude you explain it
better than I ever could but that's
exactly what happens when I sit there
and win these competitions and I was
like
good I guess I'm doing my work properly
then but you know it's coaching effect
right sometimes the coaches can
enunciate
better than the the star athletes which
you know I've competed and I've done
okay but uh I can't do as well as he
does but I can he says I can explain it
better than you can still it's a win
without conducted yesterday it's on your
Channel
sorry no I just remembered yesterday I
just recorded it it should be next week
or the week after
Jack but anyway yeah I mean that that's
the core of it we can go on into
how the layers of elaboration work but
there's also see the thing that's
missing in a lot of the ancient
tradition is a
uh well it's not missing it's there but
it's not enunciated as much as I've
enunciated it and the memory Champions
don't enunciate it because memory
Champions tend to memorize information
so they can win the prize and then they
forget all this stuff right so what we
need is
and what helps me and helps many of the
people I help is a strategy to use that
Mary Palace to harness Primacy effect
recency effects here of positioning
effect uh fund restaurant effect blah
blah blah blah there's all kinds of
Science words and um if you learn this
simple process and you use the Memory
Palace in several patterns then your
speed to getting information into
long-term memory is going to be faster
than rote learning some studies show
it's like 88 percent
retention rates as opposed to like 24
obviously studies can do all kinds of
things they never actually ask the
questions in the studies that I would if
I had the budget and uh I I one maybe
one day I will have a budget to do
studies that I think would be more
interesting but nonetheless the
retention rates when you have
elaboration and you have some sort of
recall strategy that is
that that that as I say harnesses or
optimizes things like premising and
recency effect
it just leads to higher and higher
retention rates and what I'm most
excited about is if you're applying that
to knowledge then you get through
diffuse thinking and interleaving
effects and all that kind of stuff you
get aha moments and insights the only
problem is is the martial art it's a
chess like very few people actually want
to show up and learn it and do it to a
degree that they would get those effects
but you know that doesn't stop people
from teaching chess or martial arts so
okay well I want to talk to you all for
so much longer but we have to take about
15 minute breaks I'm kicking you all out
it was lovely to see you Kevin sorry I
didn't get to speak to you for much
longer I would love to and I'm sure
we're gonna speak well we're going to
speak in a few months on the within a
few months maybe even within one month
or so on the toe Channel we'll go in
depth into your your new toe you have a
toe a theory of everything I'm looking
forward to delving into that Bernardo as
always like it's great to have a
pleasure man and Tony it's great to see
you jack great to see you Anthony thanks
for coming on thank you
thank you
okay
thank you
thank you everyone briefly Jack I don't
know what you're doing you gotta move
that move that hand click on that you
said you're gonna take this out thank
you Jack
thanks well I want you
I'll kick you out I just feel bad about
clicking that and saying leave all right
there we go all right jack it was great
seeing you Jack
all right everyone I have to move my
legs and what's coming up next is Jeremy
Corbell George Knapp after that I'm
going to announce the pace One winner so
that is the physics and Consciousness
explication contest winners Lily and
dindo is coming up and she talks about
ACT therapy or was on about ACT therapy
so you can look in on that and several
other guests let's see
foreign
Jesse Mitchells is coming up Greg
Henriques is coming up
Ross coltart Robert [ __ ] Colm Kelleher
plenty of people okay see you soon
okay I can hear the music okay
let's see
I think so
would like to promote the Discord I'll
leave the Discord again this is a place
where if you want to converse on Poe's
theories of everything it's a place to
go the patreon so that's patreon.com
if you feel like supporting the show and
contributing with whatever you can
there's no obligation it's just if you
want to contribute then
and thank you there's also the subreddit
so it's reddit.com theories of
everything
I see you I see you who's in the waiting
room I'm not gonna announce it I see you
just give me a moment Jeremy just one
minute one minute thank you
oh I just announced it okay well people
know who it is now
welcome to tonanza welcome Jeremy
Corbell George Knapp
how's it going man good to see you good
to see you
good to see you both we'll see one of
you and hear you both he'll come in in a
second yeah sure do I need to click
something here
maybe okay I'll let you I'll let you
figure that out all right
uh let's see yeah
so in the meantime how are you doing
Jeremy how are you doing George George
is being mysterious over there it looks
like he's in a in a cloud my face is not
fit for the camera anyway but
we have a jockey now here who's on the
sound board
nice nice job man good to see you Kurt
it's good to see you too so great great
to see you George
you too
so just so you know the person on the
soundboard he said his favorite
interview of 2022 was yours on the toe
Channel
I know he's fighting he slighted me and
you Jeremy so that's uh okay so it's
good to be with you Kurt I'm excited
that you're doing this it's nice to
bring everybody together around the New
Year kind of look back at what's
happened you know with your show with
your with your podcast and everything
you've covered but also in the fields
that you cover such as our favorite
topic UFOs and I think this is going to
be what is it exciting 2023 George and I
have a camera already yeah so what's
going on in 2023 Jeremy and Jordan
what's going on what's going on what are
you looking forward to
I I'm looking forward to George and I
have some stuff coming out a lot of
stuff we've covered that we're going to
be able to reveal a lot more information
on Direct witness testimony just you're
gonna hear from people that you wouldn't
expect you'd be able to hear from stuff
George and I have talked about but now
you get to hear directly from those
individuals so I know in January that
the UFO subject is going to blow up
again because new information will be
coming to light
this was an exciting year the end of the
year the signing of the ndaa and and
what that means uh moving forward I mean
it's great in a sense it's sort of uh to
coin the old cliche it's sort of the uh
the end of the beginning not the
beginning of the end because we're we're
finally as a society moving toward
trying to figure out are these real and
are genuinely asking the question and of
course Kurt as you have learned the
answer is yes they are real and now
maybe you know in the years to come
Arrow NASA uh various scientific
organizations that are now openly
interested in the topic can can it
address the bigger questions the really
important ones where are they from why
are they here who are they what's their
interest in us you know once we get
beyond the obvious question that that
our society has struggled with for 75
years and we can start digging into the
good stuff and and the tools are now in
place to do that uh Jeremy and I are
aware of some of these whistleblowers
who've been standing by ready to to
chime in and tell Congress and others uh
what they know and in fact we'd know
that some of them have already done so
um and when this comes out it's assuming
it comes out man it's going to be an
explosion so Kurt what what George is
talking about is what the The
Whistleblower protections laws are are
being implemented for we're talking
about reverse engineering UFOs we're
talking about our government physically
reverse engineering physical Hardware
that they suspect is from another world
so we're talking about programs that are
actively reverse engineering actively
exploiting these non-terrestrial
Technologies that's the claim and and
he's also talking about the idea that
people have already utilized some of
these internal mechanisms to establish
where the hardware is
so so this is something we have
knowledge of and we're hoping that this
gets out to the public because it is
happening this education is being given
on the inside
expand on that point where the hardware
is expand on that what do you mean I'm
not I'm not going to expand on that
right this second but this is something
that's being told you know within
Congress within the Senate intelligence
committee within whistleblowers coming
forward you know under uh IG
investigations they're looking into this
this is something that that George and I
know for sure is happening the people
involved all the mechanics of it and we
we hope it becomes public through the
through the right channels but I'm just
it's important for people to know it's
happening this is not something
theoretical yeah it's happening I'll
tell you Kurt my first foray into this
idea the Preposterous idea that we've
got craft and materials from some other
world some other intelligence was 33
years ago with Bob Bazaar and I know a
lot of your listeners will have problems
with Lazar story I don't care anymore I
I don't care but at the time that I
proposed that that and and presented
that information in a new series it was
ridiculous even among a lot of UFO folks
not so ridiculous anymore because what
Jeremy and I have reported over the last
couple of years is there were Legacy UFO
programs that have not been made public
there were efforts to take these
materials exotic materials of Unknown
Origin put them in the hands of
aerospace companies the big players and
try to figure out how they work and when
Bob Lazar had that story a long time ago
uh you know people uh tisk tisk and and
denied it and and ridiculed it now not
so much because some of these
whistleblowers were talking about
or appearing before Congress now have
already given statements are there to
tell them about the Legacy programs that
they are real that there are these
exotic materials that reverse
engineering programs have been underway
the big question remaining is will the
public get to know about this and can
those materials be retrieved if you hand
them over to say a Lockheed or a
Northrop or a company like that is there
a paper trail that says the ownership
should be with the American public that
it has to be returned and we don't know
these whistleblowers that we're talking
about know where the bodies are buried
literally and where the material is I
mean down to the building
um
you know it's going to be really
interesting to see if uh if congress
makes that information public because we
know that they've heard some of that
testimony already
and they've verified some of that
testimony we know
great just so you know there are a
couple people in the waiting room I just
want you all to know that I see you
thank you please hang on for a couple
more moments okay so so can you tell me
Jeremy and and George Well whoever wants
to time in what is the significance of
this whistleblowers act specifically for
people who don't know what the
legislation is what is it when does it
come into effect and why is it is it
groundbreaking do we feel like do you
think that this is just well much like
hey there's going to be a report coming
out then then the report is delayed and
then when it comes out you're just
disappointed it's going to be
disappointing should we get our hopes up
and what are we getting our hopes up for
several questions in there
just tackle them
go ahead Jeremy yeah I think we we both
have a a different perspective on it but
I think that we're in agreement that it
it is a huge invitation it's an
invitation and not only an invitation I
mean they're telling you that you need
to tell if there were illegal UFO
programs being done so this is kind of
like a duty so will people come forward
let's pretend like what Harry Reid said
that's from Lockheed will people come
forward saying I worked on reverse
engineering of non-terrestrial
Technologies well you have to be
motivated to do so but now they're
they're saying you know you need to come
forward so I think this is a this is a
big deal it's protections this is on the
the lines of like the church committee
or whatever they called it when they
were discovering all these things the
CIA was doing back you know on American
citizens this is that big this is big
enough that people have already come
forward now this is in the mechanisms of
government that are going to keep it
within the intelligence communities but
but some people are going to come
forward publicly and we know this for
sure so I I think this is a huge deal
we've never seen this kind of thing for
the UFO topic this type of
acknowledgment and I think someone like
George who's been seeing this for 35
years or however many years now this is
unprecedented so I'm an optimist I'm
super excited I think you know we're
kicking the doors down but
I am the pacifist I'm the glass is half
empty if there is a way to bury this if
there's a way to keep a secret they'll
find it and we're already seeing some of
that kind of pushback Kurt you saw this
recent Wall Street Journal article there
was a New York Times pre-bunking piece
that came out in advance of the report
which wasn't even written at the time
that said oh yeah this is all
explainable that's exactly what I've
expected for a long time and I think
we're going to see more of it the closer
Congress and the public get to answers
the closer we get to actually seeing or
learning about the goodies The Meta
materials pieces of scrap metal of
Unknown Origin craft maybe bodies the
harder the pushback is going to be if I
were Lockheed and I had this stuff I
wouldn't give it back to us what you're
seeing is a significant pushback already
by the Department of Defense at the same
time they're speaking out of this side
of their mouth saying oh yeah we're all
about transparency behind the scenes
they're feeding this disinformation to
people like that reporter at the New
York Times who kind of try to dismiss it
I will bet you Kurt that you have had
pushback yourself for the fact that you
even dare to tackle this topic in a in a
very curious way that you would even
dare ask the questions I'm sure your
colleagues have given you crap about it
and there's going to be a lot more of
that the closer we get to the goodie so
if they can find a way to bury it and
hide it they'll continue to do that you
look at the U.S Air Force they got more
information on the subject matter than
anyone and there's nowhere they don't
have a seat at the table they're not
showing up giving statements they're not
making press releases they haven't shown
up at any of the key Rings where are
they
um they're not going to give it up very
easily so I'll believe it when I see it
I'm hopeful
in a sense but I'll believe it when I
see it yet people continuously and with
increased frequency come forward to
George and me and they provide
information and data and footage and
images and you know we I've been kicked
around people saying oh you said you
know you're going to release more it's
been so long I'm on Cosmic time oh yeah
we're just starting so starting in
January of 2023 providing more for a
couple days a couple days from now
we're going to start you know providing
information that we've thoroughly vetted
and now where should they go where
should the audience go to find this
information out is their website is
their Twitter is there a YouTube right
now just go to our social media uh mine
and George's social media there's going
to be a location for that you know
that'll be you might be better but right
now I can write it in the chat and pin
it and also put it in the comments sure
so I'm at Jeremy Corbell and like George
on Twitter is G underscore nap
I would send people to mysterywire.com
that is still an active website it's a
repository of all the stories that I've
put together for 30 plus years including
interviews you know uh yesterday marked
the one year anniversary since the death
of Harry Reid five years ago this month
he got things started by talking to the
New York Times about what a program at
that time they called atip there's still
a lot of misinformation out there a lot
of things that have been made murky I
think on purpose but all those
interviews that we did with Harry Reid
with Lou Elizondo uh with other key
players in this it was all still on
mysterywire.com I would add this we did
a story if people are looking at big
events of 2022. we did a story about a
defense contractor named Radiance
Technologies they're located in
Huntsville Alabama they put out news
releases about the hiring of two people
one was a guy named Jay Stratton who had
been with the Office of Naval
intelligence and Dia the other was Dr
Travis Taylor whom we know as a UFO type
scientist on the History Channel and
Ancient Aliens and the secret of
Skinwalker Ranch in their release radius
Technologies bragged about these two
guys for their UFO work uh Jay Stratton
had been the head of the UAP task force
he'd been part of atip and OSAP as well
and they when they put out a release
about his hiring they bragged about it I
think that is a major step for private
contractors defense contractors to go
ahead and say yeah we're interested in
this in fact not only are we interested
in it we'd like to get some contracts
for it big step for industry to make
that and I I just wanted to mention
that's a pretty good story that I think
probably has fallen through the cracks
yeah so so a question that's coming up
several times on today's show is what
story from 2022 ignites you the most now
which now I'm going to rephrase that for
you all which story from 2022 regarding
this topic is most relevant to something
that you can't reveal now for whatever
reason for later so that if I want to
put some pieces together I can
yeah I mean I'd say say there everything
George and I have reported on we've dug
really deep and we've really vetted
people and and now we're at a place
where we can bring stuff forward so I
think the 2019 swarms over the USS Omaha
USS Russell actually 10 Navy warships we
initially reported on that like what our
government said we obtained and released
information that was confined within
classified files originally but we were
able to get out the unclassified parts
and that story is going to open up
there's been a lot of attempts at
debunking it talking about how there's
red green and white lights well you
haven't heard nothing yet so I think
this is great I think that that story is
so important the one that we broke and
and I think the 2019 swarms it's just
one of many by the way that that we've
looked into but it's one we could
provide corroborative video evidence on
I think overall that story is a great
place to start we're going to learn a
lot more about that and I even say the
Bob Lazar story everything Bob said to
George in 1989 we are looking at it
through a different lens now and I think
there's there's more to tell on that
story so yeah I would I would say
something more that's coming is about
OSAP you'll recall Kurt the
Congressional hearing first public
hearing before Congress on the UFO UAP
Topic in 54 years and the defense
department was asked are there any
programs that existed in between blue
book and atip and they said nope sorry
nothing well that is absolutely not true
and a year ago we put out a book called
Skin Walkers at the Pentagon that had
details about the OSAP program it was a
predecessor to atip it's the one that
got 22 million dollars that went to
Robert Bigelow's bass organization they
created the largest UFO database in the
history of the world more than 200 000
cases public hasn't seen it Congress
hasn't seen it but I can tell you that
in the year since that book came out
there's a lot more more information
that's come our way interviews with key
players that we're going to be making
public in 2023 and I think uh I think
it'll blow it wide open I hope I agree
yeah and I think also Kurt so people
right now is kind of neat because we're
I'm just kind of celebrating the fact
that we have a few movies out and
they've done well and I'm trying to kind
of get people to all catch up and watch
them so uh on extraordinary beliefs for
free you can watch all three of my uh
initial movies so all three of these are
now free and go check them out uh this
is a good time to get caught up for what
you're going to be learning starting
January
so I know Jeremy and George that you got
to get going soon if you want you can
hang out you're more than welcome to get
some popcorn answer questions but if you
have to get going now then I'm just
going to introduce the next guests do
you have to go
okay I have to go but hi guess how you
doing I'll be listening okay
guys have a great have a great New Years
everybody and I'm real excited for for
the next year I'm extremely grateful to
for you all taking some time out on this
day Lily and Greg Jesse George and
Jeremy so so thank you all for coming
out and Jeremy and George we will have a
conversation when whenever you'd like to
come back on toll you're obviously both
welcome and we have a much longer
conversation this is rushed like mad
keep up the great work Kurt and I'll be
listening thank you man that's all right
okay thank you bye okay so the next
guests and Grant is also here Grant
Cameron okay Grant Cameron Lily and
dindo Greg Henry Jesse Mitchell's Jesse
it's good to meet you publicly I think
we only met once so Grant and also I
don't think we met publicly either Grant
no I I have something that's fairly rude
of me I would like you all to introduce
yourselves but I'm gonna do a cursory
introduction first
but I'm not going to cover everything so
Lily and dindo is a clinical
psychologist and she has a website
called
actfinderpath.com
yes great and by the way for people who
are interested ACT therapy stands for
acceptance commitment therapy that has
saved my life when I was going through
what I've been told is called The Dark
Knight of the Soul so it's something
like uh it's a Well we can talk about
that another time but I've watched much
of Lillian's work on YouTube her
her lectures and they keep like man oh
man like every time I'd watch it it's
like taking what I imagine is a
benzodiazepine it's just just and and
and an anxiolytic okay Greg Henriques is
someone who's had me on his podcast I'm
lucky for he has his own toe called the
unified theory of knowledge and is
someone that I would like to have on the
toe podcast but much like almost anyone
else who has a toe and wants to come on
toe I have to study for months in
advance so I haven't had you on Greg
until now because I want to go deep into
your toe I know that sounds a bit odd
and Jesse Mitchell
like we're friends you have a great
YouTube channel that everyone is jealous
of including myself
and it's called
Sam is here Sam is also corroborating
that he it's called it's called American
Alchemy so I'm doing this all for memory
just so you know and Grant's Cameron
UFO researcher fellow Canadian we worked
behind the scenes on a
on something or at least we try to and
and I want to well I want to thank you
all for coming I know that this is an
odd Bunch but none of you are odd I'm
saying the mixture the confection
good morning
the interweaving okay so what did I miss
out Greg can you tell me that we'll go
Jessie Lillian then Grant what did I
miss
um I'm a professor of psychology cool to
have a act person here uh I love act I
talk I talk a lot about act uh
um and uh I just uh released a book uh
so you said Shameless plug here a new
synthesis for solving the problem of
psychology addressing the enlightenment
gaps the sort of the latest articulation
of kind of how some of my work and
theoretical Clinical Psychology can uh
dress the bridge between biology and
psychology the social sciences
foreign
yes and then Jesse and then Lily and
then Grant what did I miss him most of
your podcast Kurt but I I which I love
and thank you for having me and I think
it's so cool uh to get this odd
intersection of people together but um
uh Jesse Michaels I have a YouTube
channel like you mentioned American
Alchemy uh before that I I worked for
Peter Thiel who's kind of you know
venture capitalist an entrepreneur for
four years and before that I was at
Google actually so uh kind of have a
tech background but am really interested
in in media and also just kind of uh
similar to you Kurt I think I have a uh
basically unsatiable uh interest in
getting to the the fundamental nature of
reality and then I think you do it in a
far more kind of analytical math science
way and I do it in like a wacky way it's
the way I would put it
yeah great great and Lillian please hi
hi everyone nice to be with you all
um I think you covered it I mainly
um a researcher a clinical I'm a
clinical psychologist but mainly do
research
um on how to find innovative ways to
disseminate act actually into the
population because
a regular type of therapy going weekly
every week for months doesn't actually
reach most people so trying to find
innovative ways to reach more people
great and before we get to Grant I want
to touch on that point something I
recall from your lecture so you can
correct me if this is incorrect
is that you have a program and I think
this may be generally
offered where it's four hours long or
five hours a day long it's an intensive
which means that you go and then you
learn about ACT therapy and then you
don't it's always useful if you continue
to go to therapy but you don't need to
and you can see several benefits whereas
traditional therapy or Psychotherapy you
go once a week and if you don't go once
a month or so or once every or bi-weekly
you see a huge tapering you don't get
the results now so what's correct or
incorrect about that yeah so I developed
a one-day act Workshop so it's kind of
like a retreat style and it's about five
to six hours uh very experiential
um so you get essentially the entire
protocol in one day and that's meant to
kind of
get behind you know
get the whole treatment in one day
because the problem is treatment
adherence and completion is a big
problem and so yes and we've done
multiple studies that are funded by NIH
and the VA that have found that actually
this one day intervention is effective
at reducing depression improving anxiety
functioning quality of life so on so
some people do need boosters I need a
booster myself all the time uh so I need
one right now yeah exactly so but it is
you know you learn a lot of the
processes experientially during that day
um and it's quite intensive and Powerful
I found while research has found
empirically Grant Cameron
what did I miss out in your introduction
man
um I've been in the Paranormal business
since uh shortly after they invented
dirt
um I have um I I have a podcast uh
called uh paranormal UFO Consciousness
podcast and I have a YouTube which is uh
the White house UFO YouTube site I've
just released three books and I guess
the the main book that is just coming
out now is on the UFO Sky Pilots which
deals with 36 plus Witnesses who claim
that they have flown the craft and I go
through the pattern of what they
describe they're all describing the same
thing how it relates to Consciousness
and the theory of you know reality and
all this kind of stuff and and I've also
had released a weird book called it was
actually called weird the Paranormal
world of ports and manifestations which
I think is one of the first books ever
written on it and that's uh whether you
have physical mediums or Poltergeist
Geist or UFO experiences where things
will appear disappear move around the
room and this sort of stuff and I have a
whole collection of stuff from various
places around the world
okay well I have no plan for this
collection of cats it's difficult to
herd
so let's see
well firstly just like man this is just
fun thank you all for coming out
spending December 30th it's a fairly
sacred day it's almost like Christmas
near the end of the year thank you thank
you so let's see what what is it Lily
we'll start with you because you have to
get going in about five minutes what is
it about 2022 that I know that's putting
on on the spot like what story from 2022
sticks out to you the most it's most
relevant and what is the best Insight
from your work
right right
um what's your second question second
question comes from the audience
quote unquote the best Insight from your
work
the best
in my work
um I think after years and
you come to recognize that like
awareness is the most important first
step to things like you have to be aware
of
your triggers you have to be aware of
your thought processes the emotions of
the moment like if you don't have that
that awareness first then so much is on
autopilot I feel
um and so I've just come to realize this
awareness idea is just so important
um
you know we can ask you a question about
that if you don't mind of course
so what about if someone's issue that
they're coming to act for is because
they have too much self-awareness
where they feel like I'm constantly
thinking about Consciousness and I feel
like I'm almost having a psychotic break
so I'm speaking about my former self at
least and somewhat my current self and
so to say oh I need more awareness like
no no awareness is hurting me right now
hurting me right now
well I think what you're describing is
more like rumination and obsessiveness
actually it's not so much true awareness
in the way I'm thinking of it I mean
awareness is recognizing like okay I am
going down a rabbit hole here I am I am
being obsessive now I am ruminating now
um so it's actually more like developing
an insight into where you get stuck and
then
um where you get triggered
and then so even being aware of where
I'm so sorry to interrupt you it's so
difficult when it's over Zoom because I
I apologize but what I was going to say
is like so in that case you would say
being aware that what you're calling
awareness is too much like just being
aware it's almost like a meta awareness
it's like stepping outside of yourself
and recognizing like okay like right now
I am ruminating like I am in this you
know phase of rumination or I'm
obsessing about this thing and how does
how does doing this move me forward in
my life you know so it's Step One is the
awareness and step two is
is this is you know is being stuck on
this thought process is being stuck on
this
um you know what whatever you're
ruminating about is this moving me
forward in my life
or is it keeping me stuck how does
buying into a particular thought
um affect my behavior next
so
I I'd be interested in hearing what Greg
what you think about this too you're a
psychologist yeah no certainly I mean uh
I'm a big fan of act I'll I'll certainly
start there I cultivate in training my
uh doc students awareness acceptance and
change uh active change in relation uh I
built a thing called com Mo which is
basically it merges act in what's called
interpersonal neurobiology uh and
certainly this capacity just step
outside become an observer in
relationship to that be able to accept
where you are and then be committed to
motivated stop valued states of being
and be able to reflect on that in a way
that isn't reactive or defensive or
brittle or rigid that's a beautiful
thing if you can learn how to do it so
I'm all in support
I I'm willing I I'd like to ask everyone
before I leave to just
think about something if that's okay
Kurt you said we could just ask
questions so I'm going to ask you yeah
please please do
um and I think I'm I'm gonna do this
just because it's the new year coming up
and
um it's an act move so let's do it so I
want everyone on here today just to
imagine that it's 15 years from now you
know that it's 15 years from now and
you've continued living your life
exactly as you're living it right now
you don't make any changes
so I want you now you're referring to us
five as well as the people in the
audience everyone just everyone I mean
this is an exercise I like to do pretty
regularly
um
so imagine it's 15 years from now and
you you're living exactly as you are now
and you don't make any changes
so complete the following sentences
I spent too much time
I spent too little time
and if I could go back in time what I
would like to do differently is
does anyone want to share
if you can briefly share because Lillian
I know you have to get going in maybe
three minutes can you stick around for
three more minutes Lillian okay great
who wants to share
okay I'll go
um basically what it would come down to
is you look at near-death experiences
I'm sure I've learned from that is that
I spent too much time down the rabbit
hole not enough time with family and
when it comes down to the last minutes
of your life what's most important is
your family and the time you didn't
spend with them
yeah so for me I pictured
I always picture my wife whenever I
think of exercises whenever I have
exercises like this and I spend I always
prioritize her but I I could spend more
time with her and definitely I could
spend more time with family so my mom
and dad and and I feel like I work too
much though I love it and interestingly
enough I feel like I would be more
unhealthy I love junk food like I love
it but I abstain from it I abjure it and
I and I feel like I can I can indulge
some more but anyway Jesse and Greg
if you don't mind if you could be right
you want to go sure I mean uh you know
I'm I love contact with the present
moment and I still get pulled away
further than I do
um so I'm always looking to expand uh
the Deep appreciation the awe that I
have for being in the world
um and taking time for gratitude and on
relationship to that uh also then
connecting to that which I love
um which I'm fortunate to be able to do
because I you know I have my work and
I'm able to do that
um but being that and having gratitude
for being that I'm able to achieve some
of that I can always do more of that
I'm similar I think I'm uh
way too kind of goal Orient or future
oriented rather like I live I sort of
sacrifice the present for the future a
lot and I don't sort of you know wake up
and smell the roses and just enjoy
myself and do kind of uh spontaneous
things on a whim and uh often the best
things come from that kind of childlike
Instinct and so I wanna I wanna indulge
that more over the next 15 years
yeah did those were those correct were
those okay
do we get points there's no I mean it
doesn't matter how many times I do this
it's like for me it's always like I
spend too much time worrying about if
I'm doing enough if I am enough if you
know and
it's just incredible that that that
stays no matter but it's a good reminder
like okay I want to be
you know I want to be more in the moment
like you said Greg
um and then you know I'm sure you've all
heard about this book
um the top 10 regrets of the dying yeah
have you heard about it it's like it's
such a beautiful
um book that a palliative care nurse
wrote you know she just documented
um all the things that
these dying patients said they regretted
and what's amazing is that you know our
regrets are all very similar you know we
worry too much we don't connect with our
families too much we're not spontaneous
enough so
yeah there's always that question that
they ask you know when somebody's
ruminating about something and say are
you going to be worrying about this on
the last day yeah and you're going to
die it's like no well then don't worry
about it now
okay Lillian I know you got to get going
I for everyone happy New Year website
again is please say it
please Lillian can you repeat the
website and then also put it on sorry
Act
findyourpath.com
Act findyourpath.com is also going to be
on the screen in just a moment thank you
so much Happy New Year everyone happy
happy New Year and I hope to speak with
you again maybe one on one at some point
all right Greg Grant now it's just it's
just
all right it's just us
so what's up what's new
I'm in Argentina which is which is cool
wow oh wow yeah
yeah everybody's fired up I uh I
unfortunately have a little fever I
might have the flu or something so I'm
trying to get better but I couldn't miss
this
yeah thank you I appreciate that yeah of
course but I've spent a lot of time
inside this hotel room so I'm ready to
be ready to get out
foreign
what's new and Grant what's new
I just drove down to my brother's uh I
wasn't sure if I discovered a last
minute thing invited me down so I'm in a
new place just popped in and I was like
hey but I gotta get on Zoom so I'm on
this weird setup I haven't been on this
before but uh I popped in to say hi so
but you know just drove down to
Charlotte North Carolina and uh good
seeing family and ready to party it up
for the weekend
how much time can you spend here another
five minutes or 10 minutes
but I can for me certainly another five
or ten sure okay great great and Jesse
and Grant another five or ten yeah sure
so some of the people who are watching
who are chatting and there are some
people who I've invited on it seems like
we're gonna have to limit future people
to about 10 minutes you all are
exceptions from now on
okay
yeah
all right
what are you most looking forward to in
2023
Grant
answers always answers always
um looking for the next sort of uh break
in Chasing Reality what's going on how
does it actually work because that's how
I started I mean I had these two UFO
sightings the second night the thing was
flying away and I wondered why is it why
isn't Carmen Manitoba which is middle of
nowhere and had nothing important about
it and I've just been obsessed with this
what's going on why am I here all this
kind of stuff and I just I mean I just
look forward to the next day and I even
keep heart the evidence is sort of
accumulating so fast that it's hard to
keep up so I'm just thrilled with this
somebody else described the the the
moment with the the Gratitude and I I
did have that in my I wrote a book on
psychedelics and I did 25 second
avocados sessions and I did have the
compassion and the Gratitude meditations
so I'm very much aware of that in in
terms of uh what they put me through in
in these psychedelic things so uh you
know that's what I'm looking forward to
I'm very grateful that I'm here and it's
almost like playing in the Super Bowl I
always tell people you if you realize
what's actually going on in the world
and you're on this Leading Edge of
trying to figure out how the world Works
you're in the Super Bowl of all stories
and you should recognize that most
people live lives of quiet desperations
and haven't got a clue what's going on
and we are on the sort of Leading Edge
and it's it's like uh Bill Hicks the
ride you know you're up and down around
and around and lots of noise and stuff
it's just like the most thrilling ride
you could possibly be on to be on on the
edge and learning you know what the
world is about and why we're here
because most people never ever think
about it until someone says you've got
three months to live
huh
Jesse I don't know how to follow that
what was that my connection lag for a
second this is what we're looking
forward to in 23. right yeah okay uh oh
man so much I mean I think it was really
cool to get catch the tail end of um nap
and Corbell and I I hope a lot of stuff
moves on the UFO front
um uh sort of conditioned to be
disappointed on stuff like that but uh
with the new uh yeah right I do think
with the new legislature there might be
some interesting
stuff and then you know it's always like
they'll they'll let you know what they
want to let you know or whatever so
um yeah sort of maybe
cautiously optimistic I what I do think
is like it's like the surface area of
interest is growing so much in that that
it's like the dam is going to break at
some point so like I don't know when
that's gonna happen but that's cool to
me
um and I don't know I'm excited to just
keep going with the show and and
oh hello Jesse
okay well
so I'm I
well okay we can talk about that
afterwards Jesse is lagging anyway Greg
if all if if you have any comments about
what Jesse or Grant said you can also
comment on that but as well as the
question is like what are you looking
forward to next year
yeah no well there's certainly so much
excitement going on in the whole UFO
world I'm looking forward to that that's
not my particular world but I'm
fascinated in following it
um you know I'm I'm excited about
building you talk uh there we have a
gonna release a new platform on a Utah
Circle uh there's a consilience
conference that's coming up in March uh
that's uh we'll be announcing that more
John barbecue give a keynote there'll be
about 30 or 40 people given talks uh
that's March 17th and 18th on Zoom uh
we'll be getting that out and I
mentioned it you're gonna have to repeat
that slower so we can write that down
and put in the chat do you mind
repeating it yeah
a consilience conference is consilience
unifying knowledge and orienting toward
wisdom uh a bunch of people in this
corner of the internet will get
presentations we'll get discussions I'll
be talking with you Kurt a little bit
more uh John verviki will kick us off
and uh we'll have people from like the
Stowe Peter Lindberg and other people
will be engaged in a conversation about
that so I'm looking forward to that um
in person
no this is a zoom conference uh online
Okay okay so but it'll be open to the
public uh and uh and so that'll be free
uh but we'll be announcing that
uh March 17th and 18th of uh this year
so that'll be an open conference
so I'm excited about that uh my book
just came out so I'm excited about that
and I want to try to get everybody's
name
we're writing it down uh a new synthesis
a new synthesis uh for solving the
problem of psychology
psychology addressing the enlightenment
Gap
and so my goal is to have everybody know
what the problem of psychology is
and uh understand why I think it's a
really important problem like it should
be as well known as quantum gravity uh
the problem of psychology but it's not
um so
uh and that's basically the the short
version is is that the physics and
chemistry biology uh they all have
pretty clear topics uh that they're
about in the world as Sciences uh but I
like to say nobody knows what psychology
means
um and that's interesting what do you
mean
uh I mean that there are many many many
different reference in the world for
what people mean when they use the term
psychology uh so unlike chemistry uh
people can't know that chemistry is the
science really are the structural matter
from particles to atoms to molecules
um but psychology is different it does
not have a clearly defined topic area uh
so there's a wide Community a different
uh reference for psychology is that why
science doesn't want you as a science
that's exactly why science doesn't mind
because unlike the other hard Sciences
what they really mean by heart is that
the ontology uh meaning the thing in the
world that they're about is much clearer
the ontology of psychology is is
enormously confused
what are your hobbies
it's just the questions I've been asking
everyone what are you looking forward to
what are your hobbies what's your
earliest childhood memory
I think these are some questions that
you know
there are some prohibitive questions
that you can ask some anyone and then
you get to know them
like let's say 100 times the rate of
just a regular conversation I think
these are some of the questions I'm
terribly interested in what people's
earliest memories are
and
and what what are their Hobbies like
what do they do
I feel like all of us right now we're
putting on a Persona I mentioned earlier
that I think the real me is just me with
my wife it's this cuddly version of me
and I speak in baby talk and it's so
embarrassing I'm not even going to do it
here but I think that that's actually a
big example I think that that's actually
me and then everything else is some
affectation
but anyway I'm curious though like what
is the real you what are your hobbies
and what what's your earliest childhood
memory grants let's start with you
I don't really have many childhood
memories I have a sort of a total blank
I was almost my life started with my UFO
experiences with going to University and
spending my whole life at a university
uh uh and that's basically uh before
that I don't remember a heck of a lot of
anything or did a lot of working very
early Hobbies I really don't have I jog
I jog to McDonald's I drink coffee I jog
home I work on my stuff and then I jog
to McDonald's and I drink coffee and I
come home and I do that three times a
day otherwise I work on my
um my stuff
uh my Consciousness stuff which I'm
mostly on now the theory you know a
reality uh but that's all I basically do
I'm a minimalist I don't really own
anything or do any you know I don't have
anything I I've just sort of dedicated
my life I'm just the most obsessed
person you can ever find in terms of
what I do
Jesse and Greg and can you keep your
answers short because I got to kick you
all out I forgot I'm sorry about three
minutes from now
um
yeah I do you're right I need some
vitamin C
um my earliest I don't have like a
distinct individual one but I I think I
you know I was I was in my room a lot I
I got I was either getting grounded
because I was kind of rebellious or my
family life was somewhat tumultuous and
so I would like recede into my room and
I think a lot of my imagination came
from like my time in my room with like
you know playing with action figures and
stuff and like having to like make up
narratives uh and so I I'm weirdly
grateful for that time as much as I
think it was sort of lonely and you know
not it probably didn't feel amazing at
the time then hobbies-wise I love to
Surf I like to play basketball I like to
read I like to listen to uh your podcast
Kurt uh I appreciate that that's great
ending on that Greg
if we just go straight Vivid when I was
about five and a half I fell off the
monkey bars and hit the back of my head
and then I pulled up and had my hand was
all bloody so I still have that pretty
seared into my Consciousness a bloody
hand uh when I was about to fall over
here about five and a half
um but anyway uh in terms of hobbies I'm
pretty obsessed with you talk so it's
just kind of maybe like Grant in my own
way a little like that's the kind of
building that and fooling around with
that and living that but of course then
relationships and everything else not
really a hobby but just connecting with
people
right and to be clear when Greg
references you talk it's spelled
u-t-o-k standing for the unified theory
of knowledge which is Grant's Theory of
Everything or his version of some
synonym of a theory of everything and
you and Greg Grant Jesse I got a I gotta
kick you all out sorry thank you all for
coming I appreciate it so much you
should mention just just before we leave
you should mention that you and I almost
brought Canadian disclosure to uh open
disclosure in the Canadian government
and it all blew up at the last moment
you should put that what I want to hear
more about that I will talk about that
that's that's something Grant can talk
about all right so if you want more
information you can talk to Grant about
that okay
thanks for having us on
Grant it was good to have you on and
Grant you're still here you can hear me
yeah I can hear you you have to have you
on man good to have you on and okay
thanks shortly and tell Nicole to
message me because I believe that we are
supposed to have a video call at some
point okay okay I will do that thank you
all right bye-bye
okay now we got a message sorry not
message we gotta go over the pace one
entries Pace stands for physics and
Consciousness explication contest
the winners are going to be announced
now I'm going to read a script actually
I'm going to read this script
in the finalized version because this is
just this is a treat for December 30th
the actual announcement which is the
same the the exact same winners the
exact same Runner UPS sorry not
runner-ups honorable mentions are coming
out on
on a fully edited video January 3rd
January 4th sometime mid-January but
anyway the point is that
we had a Consciousness and physics
contest for creating explainer videos
akin to what Grant Sanderson did for
three blue one brown which is for
mathematics but we did it for physics
and while he focused on undergrad slash
High School level we said let's focus on
The Graduate level and so that was the
difference but it was heavily inspired
if not almost a copy and paste of what
Grant Sanderson did and I just love
Grant's channel so hey why not put out a
contest and if more people can hear
Advanced physics explanations and
Consciousness theories and their own
toes and and elucidations of such well
why not and some people are just on the
cusp of putting out content but they
need a push they need a they need some
reason
so I thought this could service that
that was the primary reason and I was so
me Sam like the whole team and the
people that we showed it to and even the
other people who submitted we were all
extremely surprised at the Quality and
the quantity of the submissions I
thought that we'd get like five
submissions or even ten and we got over
50. and they were all
extremely well almost all extremely
impressive and to narrow it down to even
a top 20 was
look at that
it was extremely difficult we did that
over the course of weeks with a process
called peer review and then also showing
it to
other academics as well as ourselves and
debating and so on so I'm going to on
I'm going to give the honorable mentions
right now
these are not the winners and just so
you know each of the winners
they get one thousand dollars from
brilliant so the honorable mentions
please
okay
the ctmu in five questions by just here
for Theo
links to all of these will be in the
final
the final upvoted uploaded video in
about a week or two weeks but I'm just
saying hey this is an honorable mention
anyone who's honorably mentioned feel
free to DM me on Twitter and I'll invite
you onto the stream again we got to keep
it short maybe even five minutes but I
just want to say hi to you
regularity and non-standard models of
arithmetic by
Nicole
Nicolette k
how I stumbled upon the best Theory of
Everything yet by the memes of
Destruction
an interconnected system of energy by
Hassam Wadi
toe for Kurt Alexei novitsky sorry I
didn't want to mispronounce that jumping
continuity Theory by Daniel Barca
unified theory of thermodynamics
space-time by Sandro Guerra who are we
what are we where are we going by
knowing geez those are okay some deep
questions double slit experiments
misconceptions part one by dose of
science these are all the runner-ups
sorry not the runner well honorable
mentions
the matter of space by Brian
the easy solution to Consciousness by
Inner sense Loop quantum gravity and
group feel Theory a very short overview
by Dr
nadarajan the infinity limited by James
ciros
narrative Theory Of Consciousness by
opt-in optimist
intro to the quantum harmonic oscillator
in nine minutes by Richard behel that
one I love the
well I don't want to comment on anyone
in particular because then but it was
great lagrangian mechanics three by
physics fluency Theory of Everything
s-g-t-o-e Evolution one by Sonic gravity
podcast what is E8 good for by quantum
gravity research that was also great the
cosmic detective evolving Dimensions by
Divergent Unity man I'm sure you all can
tell just by these titles alone you want
them written down somewhere I'll write
them in the com it's difficult for me to
write them in the comments but once this
is re-released this will this will be in
the description as well as there's a
video which will outline each of these
and I'm sure you're enticed by the
titles alone the cosmic detective
evolving Dimensions by Divergent Unity
number six
this is not number six
sorry I don't know I said number six
during the live stream I had forgotten
to mention unzeker who's one of the pace
one honorable mentions here is his video
and of course unzicker will be listed
alongside the rest of the honorable
mentions in the final Pace one video
which is coming out in a couple weeks
I'm going to announce the winners right
now triadic idealism a model for the
fundamental nature of reality
that is a fascinating video
so we will place the YouTube Links of
all of these in this in the comment chat
shortly time independent Solutions in
electrodynamics
by nood
Sorensen
space-time metric by dialect
foreign
just two left can math explain
Consciousness by astonishing
and the last winner is EP no in the
beginning surreal physics
[Applause]
a special mention has to go through
theories of everything the how-to guide
by Tyler Goldstein it's not a winner
but I feel like it deserves a class of
its own it's not an honorable mention
it's not a winner but it needs to be
super honorably mentioned
the well theories of everything the
how-to guide by Tyler Goldstein you can
look this up and again the links will be
in the comments section and once this is
finally reposted this is a live stream
it will be in the description
congratulations to everyone thank you
all thank you all so much for submitting
to this again if you heard your name you
heard your video title or you heard or
you heard your name message me on
Twitter tow with Kurt DM me my DMs are
open and I'll give you a link to come on
you'll come on even for two minutes just
so that the audience can congratulate
you
it's not enough for me to and you have
put out put out so much put so much
energy so much effort so much creative
goodness goodness goodness in the in the
world hopefully goodness
and
thank you thank you for that I I can't
be thankful enough I think it's like
it's just astounding it's astounding
staggering what you all were able to
produce
geez so red panda koala was supposed to
come out he cannot make it today
that's unfortunate
a bit slow
while I'm waiting for some of those
people to message
how about we take a break five ten
minute break I'll play some music I'll
stretch my legs thank you all Daniel I
see you're here 10 minute break okay
I'll come back in 10 minutes and then
we'll speak for a couple minutes how
does that sound just nod
Daniel can you hear me
Daniel can you hear me
just give me a thumbs up if you can hear
me yeah yeah great okay 10 minutes okay
Daniel and then
we'll come back and you'll be in for a
couple minutes I want to say hi to you
personally thank you
Justin a little while longer and if
anyone is wondering what the heck is
this Channel about my name is Kurt J
Mongol I have a channel here called
theories of everything which is about
exploring fundamental reality
Consciousness mainly from a physics
perspective there are plenty of plans
for 2023 that don't just involve the
podcast format I also want to thank
brilliant our sponsor for this if you're
familiar with toe you're familiar with
brilliant but for those who don't know
Brilliance is a place where you go to
learn math science and engineering
through these bite-sized Interactive
Learning experiences for example and I
keep saying this I would like to do a
podcast on information Theory
particularly Chiara marleto which is
David Deutsch's student has a theory of
everything that she puts forward called
Constructor Theory which is heavily
contingent on information Theory so I
took their course on random variable
distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive formula
that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order
Daniel welcome everyone welcome Daniel
Alexi and James and soon
the memes of Destruction
will also come on as well as well thank
you all thank you all
good to see you
hello hello
thank you so much for your videos
you I I appreciate it and I'm I'm just
curious you want to give an overview as
to what your video was about to the
audience and then obviously give the
title give an indication as to where
they can find out more about you
so starting with Alexi and then Kurt I
just want to say very quickly thank you
for hosting the competition you know
letting us create these this content and
getting it out there and I think it's
great
um yeah well thank you for producing
content for you it would be nothing
without without you man yeah I know for
sure it's awesome um well my uh video
was called uh tow for Kurt but the title
I had on the presentation is from
relativity to infinity and it primarily
discusses
um how you could say almost all
energetic relationships stem from a
primal Vortex of creation so a very
esoteric
um
but in in some sense the easiest way to
put it is is the universe really
expanding or are perceptions being
stretched away based off Einstein's
theory of relativity so a very quick way
to put it in a couple sentences
Daniel
all right uh hello everyone I'm just
really grateful to be here and just have
the opportunity to show our Towers
I'm just working about this in the last
10 years so and I just holding back in
the last three years I even sent Kurt
email in two two years ago I'm all I am
from Hungary so it was a long time to
coming but I am here and I am sharing my
ideas and my video called jumping
continuity Towery this sounds really too
specific but I really looked into every
details on our reality and I'm using a
big historical a big perspective a
generalist emergent issue so that's why
this might be really deep for anyone to
really go into in the video there is
lots of description and please watch
those uh
you know references and then you you
might start to understand what I'm
talking about it's it's a little bit too
deep to just uh without the background
knowledge to get into but I try to be as
specific and as uh grounded as can be so
I didn't imply too much predictions but
I have
plenty of predictions but I wanted to be
really
um grounded in this uh video and also I
just I would like to mention I'm really
grateful about this whole setup because
we meet with James actually a bit in
between this contest and we are arriving
an even greater Towery together it's
called Unity Towery and we are working
on that with even another person from
the uh contest so
I'm just really grateful thank you
thank you thank you Daniel and and James
and by the way James the link to yours
and then the link to Daniels and Alexa
it'll be coming up shortly we're working
on that and then I'll pin the comments
for people to look at and again it'll be
in the description
all right thank you thank you continue
James please
no problem just wanted to say uh thank
you as well for the contest like uh
Daniel mentioned it brought us together
and uh out of which that Unity Theory
came about so that was very great and um
yeah uh I'm also from Canada from
Toronto too so I found that oh I didn't
know that one we're both filmmakers and
um what part uh Parkdale grew up in
Parkdale
where are you right now without giving
away your location right now I'm in
Tunisia but I'll be moving tomorrow
morning to Colombia actually so kind of
crazy
all right
um
so my theory was really it's uh it's
called paradoxism
and it's based on coexistence Theory
that's the theory that underpins it and
out of out of which
uh emerged my equation it's called The
Infinity limited and really what it does
is it reconciles physics and metaphysics
uh because I I like to be as clean as
possible in Theory of Everything try to
understand what it is that
um
what is that creates uh the coherence
between people and I think if we're
going to find conciliation between
theories of everything then ultimately
that's what has to be done is the
reconciliation between physics and
metaphysics so that's why I discuss uh
void nothingness and existence in my
theory so that's what it was about
okay thank you and just for the person
who is waiting shosh which or Shosh
please just continue two weights
for another about five minutes or so
okay thank you thank you so the memes of
Destruction is here oh hey guys what's
going on I know some of these people
here and just that was one of the
greatest Parts about this whole thing is
just because as soon as you have a goal
as soon as you have a purpose for doing
something and we all have a purpose in
life you can actually start to integrate
with other human beings different ages
coming together sharing ideas and all of
a sudden somebody may have had a great
idea but they just need that one little
extra bit that one little extra push and
all of a sudden somebody's just having a
conversation they mentioned something
it's like I didn't know that existed let
me go to the Wikipedia oh look hey
here's some links to some articles and
everything and we can start a moment
just a moment just a moment because I
think that
I don't know if it's you or if it's me
is anyone else hearing the audio
feedback there is some feedback I don't
know somebody's not here one moment okay
I'm sorry it's interrupt you can you
complete can you complete your thought
please finish oh no no absolutely it's
just yeah I I I I'm used to it I've came
from some dark areas of YouTube at one
point so I'm used to different feedbacks
but it's one of those things where it's
just no matter what's going on it's just
you have the ability of different folks
different areas to actually start to
integrate to actually communicate I
conjecture this is the Internet working
as intended thank you Kurt and thank you
everybody
thank you all I'm gonna have to kick you
all out and I I mean that in a polite
way and we'll all talk again and hey
Alexa thank you and it's good like we
had a misunderstanding I apologize about
that so we'll we will fix that up and we
already have but we'll also talk again
James thank you Daniel thank you the
memes of Destruction thank you
thank you Kurt appreciate it okay
okay so yep
is good you call me Bryn I have way too
many names hi nice to meet all of you
just uh this has been such a fascinating
I've been on since it started listening
and taking notes and just uh yeah it's
an honor to be here what what fun thank
you thank you so much it's a it's a
pleasure to have you on can you please
tell them what podcast you have so that
of course and before I jump on is there
any chance that no words if not my
colleague nifa is from the eprc and does
amazing work um connected to you I was
wondering if is it okay if he jumped on
at some point yes yes and just so you
know
the person who whose first name I don't
want to spoil it starts with an R who is
waiting
can you please wait for another four
minutes so Josh nephe I don't mean to
just rush you all but we only have four
minutes and I just want to talk to you
all I want to say thank you for for just
connecting over LinkedIn and to let
everyone know about your work absolutely
yeah so my podcast less important is
called the brains and banter podcast I
would love to have Kurt on at some point
same with nifa
um but yeah I'm an assistant professor
at University of Bishops uh limited term
appointment right now but I'm hoping to
stay forever
um but yeah I'm really interested in the
Neuroscience of the imagination and of
empathy and also um you were talking
early about poetry and creativity but
specifically AI
um so I do a lot of work too on whether
AI can create poetry in the same way
that a human would
um and whether people can recognize
whether a poem written by AI is written
by AI or human I try to trick my
students often with it and it's very fun
um but yeah just just so interested I
wanted to mention quickly
um I think it was Bernardo who talked
about nothing being pregnant with every
thing and I just thought that was the
most beautiful quotation so I wanted to
mention that but yeah thanks for having
me and I'm also a member of the emergent
phenomenology research Consortium which
is how I know nifa he's also a member
um but this it's an amazing group of 100
plus researchers well over 100 now from
across the world and different cultures
looking at emergent phenomena which are
like spiritual phenomena that result
from practices such as yoga or the use
of psychedelics or meditation or
chanting and some of the facts that come
of that so it's an amazing group of
people but I'd like to get a chance to
talk about his work because you two are
going to be best friends in the next
week
and I apologize We have basically two
minutes and I'm so sorry I don't mean to
like put you on the spot and say hey
just have two minutes
but we gotta that is totally all right
totally all right thank you so much for
having me Kurt I really appreciate that
I appreciate you coming on
so I work with uh Bryn in the emergence
uh phenomenal phenomenology research
Consortium just like she said uh I'm a
physicist and uh applied a probabilists
on my first degree was in physics then I
worked and applied probability and in
the PRC we're doing some really cool
stuff where we're trying to
figure out how to
um bring together all of the meditation
and psychedelics reports that people
have made online like literally all of
it if we can and
um let loose some neural network stuff
on it to see if we can figure out uh
what the actual effects of meditation
are as reported by tons and tons of
people online for years and years so
that's what we're trying to do
um so if you feel so inclined please
help us out with with that work in
whatever way you can it's awesome
absolutely and quickly The Dark Knight
of the Soul stuff too so important as
well
um so Anna you've talked about her too
Kurt but I have a feeling that the next
guess is coming on
yes yes yes yeah okay so I'll say
goodbye to all of you and then R I will
let you in and then
person with the last name K I will have
to can you wait five minutes down there
okay thank you thank you goodbye so good
to see you yeah
thank you bye
okay so the next guest doesn't need an
introduction I can just say his initials
and you'll probably guess Rd r d is
coming on
what's up
okay good to see you Richie
such a good one everyone Richard Dolan
is here hi Kurt hey thank you this is
you've been going for five and a half
hours I see I'm kind of Blown Away by uh
your and I think you're setting an
endurance record here so uh well done I
only caught a little bit but it seemed
like you're doing a heck of a job
managing the flow of everything so uh
well done man yeah it's a bit hectic so
so rich
what are you looking forward to in 2023
no
um building a little bunker digging a
deep hole I'm just gonna hide as deep
and as far as I can but when I'm not
doing that I'll still be looking at the
UFO subject I'll still be looking at the
dissolution of global geopolitics and uh
the world around us and seeing how long
we can hang on before
things get really crazy if you think
they're crazy now I think it's going to
be a lot more a lot more ahead in 2023.
I don't think there's going to be a
respite from the insanity
and I wanted to tell the audience where
they can find more out about you or what
you have going on next and I was
supposed to take that link I don't know
if I did uh it's just fine don't worry
about it I have a I had a new book that
I uh I just did a new edition of one of
my books
but I have it here can I show it on this
little yeah my latest UFOs for the 21st
century mind uh the old Edition had a
bit of a Monty Python look this is
actually a little you're close for the
21st century this is Richard Dolan's
work I'm pinning it so people who would
like to search this and buy it or at
least check it out here is the title and
again it'll be in the description once
this finally goes thank you thank you
it's I wrote quite a bit more to this so
it's an updated version of a book that I
wrote almost a decade ago and I just
wanted to bring the UFO story up today
to the end of 2022 which I just did so I
was happy about that
um but I keep myself busy with all kinds
of analysis of the UFO situation is
there going to be a disclosure in the
next year or two or not we're going to
progress we're going to regress and I
have conversations with people pretty
much every day
uh about that matter it just never stops
I think we're in a really uh you know
I think when we were all of us were
little I don't think any of us had an
idea of just how fast-paced the world
was going to become
uh it's always been fast but my goodness
it's just gone into high gear so
uh I'm definitely going to be looking
forward to monitoring and commenting on
everything that happens in my little
area for the coming year that's for sure
and your YouTube channel is Richard
Dolan you just search that correct
uh Richard Allen intelligent disclosure
yeah uh name of one of my programs and I
do have a website I have a member's
website Richard olamembers.com where I
do a lot of work there as well uh for a
really cool community of people
so uh that is that is what I do yeah
okay you're staying on you're not
getting up that easy but not that easily
I want to let in Dr Brian Keating
as well as one of the runner-ups for the
contest his name is Brad from Sonic
gravity
hello Dr Brian Keating the legend the
legend is here and Brad I've heard so
much about you so you're a legend as
well at least to myself we're gonna
stick with Brian keating's intro first
so Brian
Brian is a I don't I don't know how you
do it man like
not only if you just read Wikipedia as
to your accolades and your current
status so you're not only a professor
you're a particular kind of Professor
the chancellor chair of someone so like
you're gonna say it much better than I
can I don't recall it just like
six adjectives before your name usually
and then you have a podcast and then not
only that but you put up way more
content than myself which I'm
desire yourself and you know yeah
extremely desire yourself
you also have kids you don't just have
one kid which is more than enough you
have five kids
and then I think there's something else
you're doing which I I think you're also
working upon or at least you used to
work on the Galileo project and there's
probably other projects and you have PhD
students and jeez man holy moly like I
work like a dog right and I work like a
dog and probably get like 10 is 50 is at
most as much as you so welcome Dr Brian
King I need you so the podcast is Dr
Brian Keaton podcast into the impossible
thank you guys thank you Kurt it's a
pleasure honor to be here you're one of
my early Inspirations and my continuing
um I would say you're you're sort of a
mentor to Meeker you've done a lot
you've inspired so many millions of
people around the world and uh you know
I'm just trying to grow a quality
audience like you've done and doing so
in the in the kind of nooks and crannies
as you mentioned you know I have a lot
of obligations and responsibilities at
the University and the thing I'm most
looking forward to outside of my family
and my home life and my friends is to
grow and develop the
uh the Simon's Observatory which is the
world's highest operating astronomical
Observatory it's actually the highest uh
construction project in the world it's
at 5200 meters above sea level in the
Atacama Desert and I was just there a
couple of weeks ago
spent uh about a week there and it's
it's just Paradise for nerds when you're
up there and there's nothing you can do
there's no Wi-fi all you could do is
work and you've got this massive
telescope array of three enormous
telescopes and it's going to be joined
by a six meter diameter reflecting
telescope my three refracting telescopes
this is you know kind of what I dreamed
of as a kid uh I just didn't have the
110 million dollars that it takes so
thank you Kurt thank you Kurt's patreon
but she funnels to me no no he doesn't
do that I do support Kurt so I I want to
ask you all out there if you can give
Kurt a little bit of of feedback and the
way that humans have done this since the
Phoenicians invented the the concept of
fungibility and coinage and and money is
to become a patron of kirchi mungle uh
who who has promised
buy and I have it as proof he's going to
visit me in Southern California where I
am not right now I'm in an undisclosed
Subterranean bunker where I'm hoping to
go skiing with some of my kids uh but
um but please support Kurt so I need he
needs a uh he needs to make a proper
introduction come and do a live podcast
in my new studio at UC San Diego where I
am the Chancellor's distinguished
professor of physics and we're going to
do a video together and I've already
started
foreign
okay all right I will go for eight hours
so I'll record one with you you record
one with me and by the way don't just
support me support Brian support Rich
support Brad who is about to be
introduced Brad please sir introduce
yourself if you don't mind and I want to
just thank you for submitting not only
submitting but but I want to thank you
for producing a quality video
hey thanks I you say quality I know you
you're defining That Tune very Loosely
because uh I mean I my tech is really
low can you guys hear me it might sound
okay yeah but uh no I just want to say
Kurt uh well I'm a I'm a vet uh I'm a
engineer and a lawyer
um and when the Navy said that UFOs are
real
just my brain started spinning and I
just got really focused on how to how
could it possibly happen
and uh so I just started like you do any
other engineering project I said well
they look massless what caused this Mass
it's the Higgs field at least that's
what
um space-time Dr Matt O'Dowd said and
then I was like well how do I get a hold
of higgsfield and he said I had an
episode that said the left-handed
electron uh
is getting snagged by the Higgs field
so then I said well what how do I grab
left lane electrons so I create a
faraday disk create a magnetic field and
I found some research from Dr Lawrence
Eaves at University of Nottingham that
said if you pass it through a hexagonal
molecular structure like graphene or
bismuth or nickel it teases out left and
right hand electrons
and so then I see that oscilloscope
behind me with that platform that that
scale
so I built that Faraday disk
put that plate on top of it turned it on
and I got about two pounds lighter
so now I'm trying to
um essentially you know if you shake the
left hand electron the left arm's
holding on the figs field of course I
have a non non-consensus theory that the
Higgs field is negative energy density
gravity and so just a moment Brad
because if people aren't following this
I want to leave a link to your work so a
link will be imminent and then I'm going
to pin it that's just for people who are
wondering what the heck is happening so
please continue
yeah so if you can shake 246 gig
electron volts into that left-handed
electron that you caught in your in your
Faraday disk magnetic field so you can
see behind me there's the oscilloscope
it's dual Channel it has one polarizing
field and then it has a harmonic one
that bounces the field I run through a
car stereo to jack up the wattage
but um but essentially it shakes the uh
hopefully I mean I'm hoping that what
I've hit is a resonant frequency that
reduces the Hicks to the ground state
and lowers the mass of whatever's inside
of it and then it just kind of after
that sort of hey that's what quantum
gravity is and then it just kind of led
me down this complete rabbit hole and I
started learning quantum physics and
just kind of seeing how everything fits
and I think and I don't Dr Keating is a
privilege Kurt it's a privilege to be on
your Dr Nolan I mean you guys are all
great I mean I'm crying right now inside
and I screenshotted it so I can like
show my family that I was next to famous
people but I think space time blows out
of black holes which is why the universe
expands and the further you look out I'm
so pumped to just even be in your guys
Aura thank you so much
um but yeah I just I do it in my free
time uh I have a regular day job and
everything and I only have four kids
though so well Brad quite as engaged
is Dr Keith
I I
saw firstly
so thank you for your comments about
that that's that's incredibly kind and
I'm Richard and Brian I'm sure we're all
like super flattered by that so so thank
you and and I do have to let you go now
only out of fairness to everyone else
who is at The Honorable who is honorably
mentioned I only gave him about a couple
minutes so I'm Gonna Let You Go and
it'll join Brian and Richie but thank
you and we'll speak again okay
sure it was a pleasure for people who
are interested again I will leave the
link right
[Music]
it'll be in the description I'll leave
the link in the description I placed it
on the on screen several times already
okay thanks Brad
thank you yeah man talk to you soon
Okay so
all right Rich Brian
oh we're still here yes better still be
here
so I want to know
Brian I don't think I asked you what do
you have
what are you most excited about about
2023
I think this year is going to be a year
of transition where we take discoveries
and we subject them uh to really intense
scrutiny I think we're coming out of a
dark period for science where science
was subjugated at the will of political
and media
imperatives and I think you know thanks
to Elon musk's generosity and and buying
Twitter I think a lot of that has been
liberated and because of that I think
there will be a new sort of Renaissance
and I like in the last three years to
sort of a Dark Age like you you almost
couldn't have a flourishing of say
engineering you know during the during
the Dark Ages so so-called Dark Ages it
turns out they weren't that dark but
let's get into that some other time
um we couldn't have like flourishing art
and architecture and then like
suppression of of thought and uh and and
Science and all sorts of things in other
words concomitant with the overbearing
social uh pressures that came from
political uh factions with those being
alleviated
uh that has really uh stemmed a tide
that made me very nervous very worried
and I say that I've had two
conversations in the last month of my
podcast one with actually three one one
with professor Charles seif just last
week about nuclear fusion and they
claimed you know Revelation and
breakthrough which kind of showed the
governmental
um you know hype cycle I call it the
academic media
complex industrial complex I'm gonna
have a video about that soon
um along with things like the quantum
Computing Wormhole which I have an
upcoming video about as well these are
hype things and then you have
of legitimate scientific discoveries or
practice of science like the James Webb
Space Telescope that was uh embroiled in
a controversy recently over the name
being named after James Webb and he was
accused falsely of being a homophobe and
this actually caused a great deal of of
uh of pressure on a good friend of mine
past guest hakima lashayi who's a very
well-known physicist himself who happens
to be black and he set on a campaign to
investigate did James Webb practice
homophobia found negative did not and
yet his life hakeem's was turned upside
down because of non-scientific reasons
people that just hated this notion that
gays and lesbians should be persecuted
which we all should abort but at the
same token uh this this came about
and then the last thing was Dr J
bhattacharya uh one of the co-authors of
the Great Barrington declaration who
promoted Common Sense covid navigation
and he was called by the most powerful
two people in all of science right now
to the extent that you can identify
scientific bureaucrats as being powerful
uh Francis Collins director of the NIH
and Tony fauci who needs no introduction
um he's not coming on is he is he Kurt
is he coming on a live stream I hope not
yeah so uh to hear the treatment of Jay
and how much has changed just in the
last few months is really a breath of
fresh air so I'm looking forward to
discovers I had an epic tweet thread I
posted yesterday predictions for 2023 in
science also the UFO project I'm uh very
good friends with the NASA UAP study
director doesn't give me any special uh
favors Dr David spurgle who's been a
two-time guest on my podcast uh he's
leading the NASA study and he's going to
do a phenomenal job when that comes out
he's promised to come on my podcast and
reveal you know some of the inner
workings of how they came to their
public findings Dr Shelly Wright is a
colleague at UC San Diego she studies
Optical study incredibly interesting
using looking for laser light Pulses
from distant civilizations so I'm
looking forward to all that she's also
going to be a guest on the podcast so
stay tuned for that I like to do and as
you know you're You're The Theory of
Everything I almost changed my channel
from into the impossible to experiment
of everything because you cover all the
theories of everything someone's got to
do the Hands-On instrument building
Hardware technical things I said we're
Hodge dual to one another
that's right
yeah we are we are I don't know who's
who's the complex though of the two of
us
so so Richie sorry if I keep calling you
Richard I just mean that in an endearing
manner Richard what
what are some things that ordinary
people can do outside of petitioning
their government
to facilitate UFO disclosure or to help
get some
get less befuddling of the UFO scene and
more illumination
uh I'll answer that but I just want to
say this is the first time I've heard
Brian Keating speak and uh I kind of
like the
political analysis I agree with musk and
Twitter
um and pretty much I think everything
else you said Brian uh I'm looking
forward to seeing how that NASA UFO UAP
study goes I have a little bit less
confidence maybe than you do that will
be according to what I think it really
ought to be but that's just based on
NASA's long long history of UFO
obfuscation and actual dishonesty that
they've had and a lack of um
really good work done on it but maybe
this will be different and I'm looking
at that uh
uh carefully and critically as well as
far as your question Kurt
um
well I think the conversation we're
having on UAP or UFOs in our society
it's much much better than it's been
five years ago uh and long before that
where it was utterly impossible to have
a an adult mature conversation about
this subject in the public domain it was
just it got shut down every time so it's
a little bit better now we're still at
the tiniest of baby steps in terms of
really grasping what this phenomenon is
about uh we're still at the point where
we have scientists saying gee I wonder
if there's something out there is this
anomalous and so forth
um I've been looking at I've looked at
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of cases many Declassified military
case is not simply from the US but from
other nations as well and there's no
question that this is not simply
something that's real but it's a
significant high level National Security
issue that at times is taken on
uh Monumental and Ultra grave
proportions more than once so it's
obviously something very serious it is
enmeshed with the intelligence and
military communities primarily of the
United States but also elsewhere there's
a lot of obfuscation you know I did a
lot of time looking at the Davis Wilson
notes I was one of the few people
initially who really stood by them in
2019 and 2020 when a lot of people were
still trashing them I knew that they
were legit I know they are legit and the
implications of what are in those
documents is those notes are quite
significant describes a
deeply deeply clandestine classified
special Access program series of
programs
that are
maybe with the legal fiction of having
some government purview but in a sense
in essence they really don't have much
government oversight and anything
meaningful at all
and
um appear strongly appear I would say to
have
to do with the possession of non-human
technology and even bodies I think all
of that is real the other thing that we
need to be talking about is the ongoing
massive daily presence of these unknown
craft over people's neighborhoods every
single day
uh you can look around there are a
couple of repositories that accept good
UFO cases
they don't all get great investigations
it is true but when you go through the
data I think it becomes undeniable to a
reasonable mind that every single day at
two in the morning three in the morning
there's a craft that might be hovering
over your neighborhood at 200 feet
people see these things all the time and
I would like to know who the heck is
behind them what are they doing what's
the mission
are these aliens or not I don't think
they're black budget so there's there's
a lot of uh progress that we need to be
making on the UFO matter what can people
do
well this is a subject with a steep
learning curve I've learned that 25
years ago I thought I'll take uh two
three months out of my life and get up
to speed on it right and that was a long
long time ago so it takes a long while
to become what I would say is genuinely
sophisticated in one's understanding of
a subject it's been laughed at for years
and decades and I think uh and I and I
don't know
um you Brian so I would never make an
assumption but I do find that many many
highly intelligent people with great
education underestimate this subject and
they think that they've got it when in
fact they're at the bottom of the
mountain so there's a long way to go
yeah I agree Richard I think there's a
lot of um there's a lot of hubris right
there's the kind of Camp the Elon Musk
camp that we've had great cameras for
decades and they've been improving in
the quality of UFO sightings has got you
know it's easy to dismiss and elon's a
brilliant man I hope to have him on my
podcast at some point uh then there's
actually an abundance of excellent video
autographic evidence that is out there
that just gets ignored
right quite a bit so what I what I like
to do is think about it as an astronomer
that's what I'm trained as I do build
instrumentation I like to think of the
physics implications and you know for a
long time I simply applied Pascal's
wager to this whole problem if it is
real the penalty for you know not
believing it is infinite almost right we
could lose out on four centuries of
physics progress another hand if it
isn't real whatever that means I'm not
going to debate it right now but it
isn't real and you spend some time on it
first of all you're learning a
tremendous amount right let's not forget
all the things we've learned about
um just from the consideration of the
existence of extraterrestrial life we've
learned about Material Science we've
learned about Imaging and we've learned
propulsion systems and and then I'm also
a pilot I fly little planes around here
in California and um one of the things
that's interest uh you know to me and I
know I'm interested in NASA outside of
the alien issue is how could these
objects be threats how could they
interfere with the safety of of the
public and I think that's actually been
downplayed I mean Kurt and I hosted
along and people are still talking about
that that's probably my most popular
video in the last couple years and that
video you know people are making fun of
it now on the other hand I also I don't
shy away from upgrading you know the
Believers the so-called you know I want
to believe type folks I say look I asked
Tom this point blank I said you claim
you have evidence let's talk about the
evidence where is it how'd you get it
how did you come to it can we test it
can we subject it in my laboratory well
we can do some of those things but you
know we lost track of it we don't have
provenance we don't at a certain point
Richard you know you scientifically
minded per people and like you and me we
would say look at a certain point that
evidence doesn't fully rise to to you
know the point of scientific
um this positive in other words it may
evidence as eyewitness evidences I mean
I don't use eyewitness evidence and
cosmology because there were no
eyewitnesses to the Big Bang but uh I
think we have to be we have to be
um open and not have that hubris that
you're speaking about on the other hand
we can't also say that because I want to
believe something that I'm almost going
to be as accepting of of technology and
claims and and visitations and sightings
and so forth
um and and kind of not use our
scientific training I I don't know if
you'd agree with that but that's right I
use my historical training so I'm not a
scientifically trained man I'm a
historian and so what I've been
interested in doing is trying to figure
out a historical puzzle which is why
have leading uh directors of the Central
Intelligence Agency four-star generals
three star generals of the US and
elsewhere taking this problem so
seriously and why has there been so much
obfuscation and secrecy around it that's
undeniable fact and and then furthermore
what is what could be the meaning behind
the many hundreds I would say thousands
of Declassified military reports that
describe rather dramatic encounters with
UFOs so that's the situation that I'm
interested in so rather than explaining
it scientifically it's trying to
understand it historically and
understand why it was taken seriously by
some of the most brilliant responsible
National Security people and in our
lifetime
what do you think Richard um
yeah yeah I'm sorry oh no I'm just gonna
ask Richard and YouTube
yeah I just want to ask Richard and new
Kurt
um one of the things I've been thinking
about is sort of the analog of a Turing
test but for classifying you know
sightings encounters or whatever and um
and that's very this is something people
can really latch on to and they can
participate on in fact before I joined
the show I had to prove that I was a
human being you know via a recaptcha
type system right
um and so Richard and Kurt I wonder you
know could we sort of crowdsource you
know these things and kind of the the
citizen science Brigade and call for
that in addition to professional
scientists like myself actually working
on Avi lobe Gary Nolan you know um Etc
working on this phenomena but like have
a recapture you know how can we classify
things just at the data level is that
even possible as a way to engage citizen
scientists
there are ways to do this absolutely
there are um projects going on right now
and I wish I could remember the German
professor's name who's doing this I was
just chatting about him the other day
who has um a proof of concept that he's
working on essentially having cameras to
uh with with AI of algorithms to
identify uh conventional objects but but
to have the cameras dedicated in a
portion of the sky so that it would
capture
um increasingly would capture unknown
objects I think uh you know there's all
kinds of projects like that which makes
sense and which are feasible and uh that
could have results
um you know I think there's a lot of
smart people out there with all kinds of
uh ideas you could try to capture
objects and other elements of the
electromagnetic spectrum
um whether it's IR or anything else and
that's one thing and you know the real
the real meat and potatoes comes down to
whether or not we can actually
unlock the secrecy and I'm a firm
believer that there's been a
long-standing cover-up conspiracy you
want to call it
um in which ET Tech has been acquired I
and I I'll just add I don't know how
much more time I have here but
I think that our species
uh you know we've existed as Homo
sapiens for about 300 000 years last
estimate from um paleontologists
and only in the last generation or so
have we been
maybe let's be generous and say the last
century have we really had a truly
modern society
you know up until then we were just
horses pulling wooden carts and not even
that so we're in a place right now that
if there's anyone out there who has the
ability to watch us I would be quite
sure that they will they're sure as heck
going to want to watch us right now
because we're about to LEAP right into
their world we're on the cusp of very
strong AI Quantum computing
uh genetic modification of the whole
thing I mean we're Reinventing our
species we're moving into a new phase of
human existence
we're going to want to know that
that was uh the Angels were chiming in
there
anyway so I think I think where an
object of uh
probably we've brought the whole
neighborhood in to check us out at this
particular time wouldn't surprise me at
all
I want to introduce Matt O'Dowd who is
the host of PBS space-time a professor
of physics as well as the launcher or
the filmmaker behind inventing reality
which is in its fundraising stage about
several of the topics that you've heard
on the toe channel that is what is
reality what is physics what is physics
relationship it's a consciousness
Matt
thank you thank you for coming on again
Kurt it is a pleasure to be here again I
feel like I'm home yeah yeah the first I
think the first podcast I had in this
setup was over here and you were
speaking to me so it's yeah it's nice to
nice to have you back on I'm not sure if
you've ever met Brian or Richard oh
Brian Brian and I go way back hey Brian
it's good to see you again hi Matt Happy
New Year
you too so Richard Dolan is a historian
and focuses on the the UFO phenomenon
but I'm sure I'm I'm not even giving the
proper introduction so please fill in
the gaps Richard and Matt I just give
the introduction Matt's a professor of
physics who has a wonderful
YouTube channel called space PBS space
time
hi Richard good to meet you nice uh same
here Matt
what are we talking about
it's uh we're just hanging out Toronto
Blue Jays they're talking about
talking about baseball
yeah
so so Brian are you able to stay for a
bit longer or you have to get going
yeah yeah I can stay until uh until I
get hit in the head with a nice Ice uh
great great a couple more minutes so
Richard so we're going to start taking
some questions from the audience and
well we should have been doing that the
whole time there are many questions
already but I'm saying that right now so
please because the rest are scrolled far
up I can't find them
one of them that came was what do you
think Richard this one's for you but
anyone else you can feel free to riff
off of Richard what do you think the
relationship is between some of these
ancient myths so religious myths and the
phenomenon
yeah I've been I've been on the show
Ancient Aliens about a million times but
I'm actually not someone who uh
really tries to make a lot of strong
connections between uh our ancient
history and E.T I'm I'm a very strong
student of ancient history and uh and
prehistory it's a big interest of mine
uh and also the origin of uh of myths in
our world
and uh whereas I do think that there's
there's reason to think that we've been
monitored uh by let's call them others
for a long time uh I think I've
characterized it as a fairly low level
thing I think it's totally different
than what we're dealing with now in the
in the 20th and 21st centuries so I um I
don't know if we really have enough
information to to make any of these
connections I think when people talk
about people like Zechariah sitchin I
think that was way way just off base
not a not really a supporter of his work
and I and I I'm very hesitant I guess
I'll just say to make strong connections
about that I'm not saying it's
impossible but
um I don't think I'm on board with most
of it
Matt have you have you been asked
publicly about your opinions on the UFO
phenomenon
not publicly
um well not not publicly loudly
um I'm sure there have been some YouTube
comments but
uh are you are you saying that because
you're about to ask me or
preparing me yeah this is uh
so
you know those
um those fighter pilots uh extremely
highly trained uh
rational human beings
um and and and they saw some [ __ ] and
and we don't know what it is
and it you know apparently the Air Force
doesn't know what it is so I think I
think
it I think they uh verified
flying objects that have not been
identified so
um so the question is
what are they uh
my gut instinct is to
hypothesize aliens last
but that is because really because I
wanted to be aliens
but I don't want to fool myself
or the exact opposite I don't want it to
be aliens but I think it is
why don't you want it to be aliens uh
I'm not really too crazy about the idea
of aliens being here
um not really in love with the idea but
uh I actually do think that that's what
we're dealing with I think uh
you know when I look at the long history
of the modern UFO phenomenon
um
you know everything that we know about
from the so-called Tic Tac UFO incident
of 2004
or the USS Roosevelt 2014 2015 in all of
these cases and then the elites to
Jeremy Corbell in 2019 2020.
that's all recent but those types of
events have gone on
they were going on in the 90s and in the
80s and in the 70s and 60s and 50s and
the 40s 1940s we have documents military
Declassified showing these objects or at
least having been tracked at 9 000 miles
per hour
what what the heck is that supposed to
be at high altitude 100 000 feet
altitude
um you know they had the other lights
that were very very good at measuring
speed and distance in Azimuth and so
forth and um
I trust their ability to know what they
were doing
so they came up with data that is not
easily comprehensible
unless there was a very very clandestine
science project that no one has known
about here
um that's that's got a global presence
and has had one since before the turn of
the middle of the 20th century
I don't know what else it could be and
in fact when you look at uh you know the
few classified studies that we have
access to or at least moderate access to
um within the US military you find
there's always factions that were
convinced that this was an
extraterrestrial or as they would say
interplanetary phenomenon that was
always a very significant group of
people
um and how deep does it go is a real
question so no I think it's actually
quite
I mean I think about Occam's razor quite
a bit and I think that the ET hypothesis
is probably to me it makes the most
sense it makes more sense than anything
else that I can imagine
that's just me yeah I so
I I admit I haven't done
my due diligence
um
I've watched a few can you speak a bit
louder oh yeah sorry I I haven't done my
due diligence on this particular topic
um
uh there there is however a great uh
video by Joe Scott so I don't know if
you guys know Joe Scott he has a uh
science physics YouTube channel also and
he did a
uh what I thought sounded like a
compelling dissection of the UFO report
um
and
I got the sense that it was plausible
that it was a a light phenomenon
as opposed to being actual physical
matter traveling at that speed
um but like I said I you know you've
clearly uh read and researched far more
than I have so I don't want to pretend
like I know but I would I would
recommend that video and be curious
which report was he commenting on
this is a year ago the most recent UAP
task force report exactly I imagine
so a question that I get asked plenty
and I'm curious to know Matt
Brian and also Richard your response to
is how can one
scientifically test this phenomenon
given that it's
unrepeatable
so what would be the best way one way is
to just reject the premise and say no it
is repeatable and then here's some way
but well what would Brian
yeah well I I yeah just uh I did did ask
Avi Loeb this very question multiple
times and I've never gotten a
satisfactory answer so he claims
of course uh Interstellar uh object uh
prepared by extraterrestrial
intelligence uh some star system that we
can't or you know reconcile with uh
because of the difficulty in orbital
mechanics and reconstructing it
we just do know that it's velocity is
consistent with origin or coming from an
extrasolar location so I said Avi look
you know if I had access to a
billionaire in the way that you have
access to a billionaire instead of
slingshotting you know a bunch of iPhone
cameras to proximus and Tory B I would
uh actually redirect them and and send
all my energy to go after omuamua uh
because he he's convinced that you know
over 90 which for Abby he's actually
going through the math he's not saying
ah 90 chance you know I flipped a dozen
coins and you know no he really has gone
through the math and scribes a very high
much greater than even odds to this
object's extraterrestrial origin
and um and I said well why don't you
convince
um uh you know Yuri Milner to give you
uh you know 10 million dollars to
immediately go after a muamu while it's
still in The Helio you know pause and
and it's still you know within our solar
systems you know nearest boundaries and
it's not so far out as going to four
light years away as it would be for
project Starship I said oh no no no no
one is uh characteristic uh you know uh
chastising voice he said no with Vera
Rubin we're going to discover Ruben
Observatory which is the largest kind of
it used to be called the LA lsst large
uh synaptic survey telescope in chela
it's a a meter class telescope and we'll
be using parts of it data and they'll be
using some of our data from the Simon's
Observatory down in Chile as well to
look for planet nine which is a totally
other side project of ours on the
Simon's observatory in addition to
looking for inflationary gravitational
waves anyway he said no we're going to
be basically filthy the sky is going to
be you know blotted out by how many
discoveries of these extrasolar objects
we can make but I said do you still do
you have a plan do you have confidence
this thing is could not be repeatable as
you said Kurt why not take your chance I
mean the number of like super anovas
we're overdue for about four supernovae
right Matt I mean in our galaxy we
should have had about you know a
supernova per Century last major one was
in you know 1594 you know Kepler
observed it so fortunately they don't
Stack Up
they don't line up and and all go at
once if they're like
okay so so in other words you know don't
don't you know wait for the next one to
come around because your math predicts
that it should go after the one the bird
in the hand and he's been kind of
dismissive of that I I sort of would
would say no if this is not repeatable
we have to make every effort to actually
confirm this object is is real
um and uh you know so he and I have a
friendly debate about that but yeah it
is true a lot of these things are
one-off events on the other hand if you
look back to like what was Aviation like
in
1922 so 100 years ago 1923 100 years ago
um you couldn't really get on an
airplane and get you know stuck by
Southwest I mean you could you could get
on an airplane if you had a lot of money
and a Barnstormer happened to come by
your neighborhood uh Airfield and just
pick you up and take you up for five
minutes for a wing walk
um and and nowadays of course it's
incredibly common unless you're on
Southwest as I said uh but the the fact
is uh where if we're in this you know
nascence of a technology as perhaps
Richard is is hinting at you know that
it's going to be this explosion you know
I would ask the kind of Nancy Kerrigan
question you know why now what you know
why why us you know why here and it's
not really clear
um
as the uh you know as the technological
you know blueprint of us going forward I
do believe we'll be visiting Mars you
know in the future and it's not so
far-fetched to do that because we are in
that barnstorming phase of space flight
so in 100 years from now on you know
when Kurt's great-grandchildren
rehearsing hosting you know Theory of
Everything You know the the second
generation third generation then they'll
be talking about it but would it be
possible that there's a there's a
there's a you know Mass Evolution and
mass
um sightings and actual encounters and
why would that be happening now as
opposed to 400 years ago or a thousand
years from now and I know I've heard
some of the arguments for it but curious
what Matt would say
Matt so to answer the first question
what do we do for a non-repeatable event
that
is how do we test for it I mean it you
know if the stories about UFOs coming
regularly uh true then it's a repeatable
event you just don't know when and
presumably these things are made of some
kind of matter so we might build uh
various detectors radar-like things and
put them across the planet to detect
objects made of matter flying around and
and indeed we have
that across the globe who have
objects built to detect
you know icbms
um traveling between the continents uh
so
that I mean we we have the technology to
detect these things and and so
this is why I think it's
you know in order for us to say we
haven't detected them it
requires some kind of very high level
and very very consistent conspiracy and
a a conspiracy of a consistency that I I
don't think our governments have shown
the competence to be able to sustain you
know across
you know multiple election Cycles
um you know and across multiple Nations
um so then
if these things aren't detectable by our
current technology I mean they clear
they're clearly detectable from their
light because they're seen
uh so they're at least detectable that
way perhaps they they hide from radio so
you know we could scan the sky
um more thoroughly than we are but I
feel like
um I feel like you have to look a little
bit about at the pattern of of when
these things are detected and who by and
you can do a numbers game you know if
these things are detected with this
frequency by Air Force pilots and by
um you know
midwesterners and and whoever sees them
more frequently then it's not hard to
extrapolate to estimate how often you
know the average person would see a UFO
and you can ask whether that happens you
can ask whether
they're
um their sightings are somehow
correlated
in a way that points you to some other
potential uh origin for these sightings
um as for things like um
[Applause]
um
I I not only do I not think was
technology
uh I I think it's impossible for it to
have been Technology based on the very
numbers that Avi lope has crunched uh I
I did the calculation I can't remember
what it was but but I think the I think
RV statement was that okay so this thing
is tumbling it must be a defunct probe
that is that is now tumbling because
it's lost its power or whatever
um
therefore it's not that and if it's not
guided then you can estimate the
abundance of defunct probes in the
interstellar space in order for one of
them to have fallen into our solar
system and the number you get is
insane in that you would need you know
more uh defunct Interstellar probes than
there are
ordinary rocks floating between the
stars and and so you know I think
uh although Avi is a brilliant scientist
I I think
um
he may be expressing more confidence in
his belief in this than he actually has
yeah you're patiently waiting so please
what's your answer to this question and
then also Tyler nikolaj and Sorenson I
know that you're waiting so patiently in
the waiting room I'm Gonna Let You in
I'll be quick then
speaking as the non-scientist here
um I don't really have a qualified
scientific well your husband of this but
I have more knowledge than all of us put
together on this topic
uh what I what I would say is what we
need is is reliable data capture so uh
the idea that I was expressing earlier
by I wish I could recall this particular
German scientist name but there's just a
number of these types of ideas of of
capturing data and then studying it um
now yeah I remember speaking with
Christopher Mellon about this who wrote
a very good piece about uh less than a
year ago calling out the United States
Air Force for its
absolute uh opaqueness regarding
the data that he he said he knows that
it has relating to this subject and was
referencing a large number of U.S
satellite systems that he said these are
perfectly designed for capturing
anomalous data and he says and I'm
absolutely certain they've done that but
we don't have access to that information
so I think you know it's it's not
repeatable as a phenomenon we've known
this for a long time I mean the problem
with science
correct me guys if I'm wrong here but
you know when you're doing science you
you the scientists are assuming that
you're in charge of the experiment uh
but if there's an intelligence that's
beyond your own uh it might be very
difficult to do that you might be
dealing with intelligence that doesn't
want to play the same game that you want
to play and might make it difficult if
that is the case if we're not at the top
of the the intellectual food chain here
in our analysis of something what is the
likelihood that a scientist is going to
be able to get you know it's one thing
if you're studying a virus in a and a
microscope that that'll behave more or
less the way you expect it to but I
don't know if highly intelligent
presumably extremely Advanced aliens are
going to play by our rules so I don't
know if that causes a problem in terms
of scientific analysis but I do think
data capture and historical analysis are
always going to be important my field is
my study is out of History I know that
very well and and the only thing that I
can say
pretty confidently is that the major
governments and National Security
establishments around this world have
engaged with this phenomenon and have
been utterly befuddled by it or Worse
really concerned and um yeah I mean I
have to kind of agree with
I figured Matt though in some level you
know three years ago exactly I was at a
Shabbat some friends
um one of my uh seat mates was saying ah
you know what do you have looking
forward to in 2020 I said I was invited
to visit the Tibet Ali CMB observatory
in Tibet never been to China I'm looking
forward to it he said ah you might want
to think twice about that I heard about
this virus maybe I was born in a couple
of months when are you thinking of going
I said April
I maybe wait until June and here we are
three years later I'm into that
um Kurt I need to sign off I want to
wish you a happy New Year I want to wish
uh my friend Matt and thank you Richard
it's a pleasure talking to you hopefully
let's interact uh some more maybe on my
Channel or your channel and um for those
of you interested in obtaining some of
your own extraterrestrial materials I do
on my mailing list Brian keating.com
List have a giveaway for the next
hundred people that sign up for my
mailing list I'll send you if you're in
the US if you're not I'll send you a
link to my uh first ever audiobook by
Galileo Galilei but brianking.com list
and I'll send you a chunk
Interstellar space Schmutz perhaps with
some alien RNA on it I don't know it
depends on what my kid had for lunch
that day when he Stuffs the envelope bye
Kurt by Matt bye Richard great seeing
you hi Tyler take care brother Happy New
Year I'm going to bail as well it's been
a pleasure Kurt loves it and uh if
anyone wants to check out what I do I've
got a YouTube channel Richard Dolan
intelligent disclosure I've got a
website Richard olmembers.com go see
what I'm up to I'm busy there every day
okay hold on hold on Richard if you
don't mind I want to plug exactly it
okay so goodbye Brian so Richard Dolan
intelligent disclosure this is correct
it's on the screen right now uh yeah
that's my YouTube channel and so just
let me let me be clear there's so many
people in this audience that are just in
love with physics and also that are
fascinated by the UFO topic
if you're in the UFO topic then Richard
Dolan's name is not as well it's
extremely familiar to you if you're not
in the UFO topic and you want an
introduction well Richard Dolan is a
great way to get such an introduction
and speaking of introductions I'm going
to introduce Tyler
and the rest of you all Sorensen and
nikolaj sorry shortly but again speaking
of introductions Matt Matt is the place
at least that I go for
on almost any physics topic just watch
Matt's video and then you get an
overview then if you want to delve
deeper you can go to books or articles
or even Wikipedia But mats is just a
great introduction so I want to plug
what Matt is working on even if you're
staying at it which is inventing reality
so just a moment here you go and Richard
Dolan what else do you got going on
while I plug this while I'm trying to
get this loaded up here what else do you
got going on for 2023 before I'm working
on book projects
um working uh still in the background of
my third volume of UFOs in the National
Security State I'll get that done one
day I'm working on a book actually on
Usos under unidentified submersible
objects and I'm doing kind of a history
of those I hope to have that out in the
spring
you're missing Ross
g'day how are you good good Ross so I
haven't yet so firstly goodbye Richard
Dolan thank you it was a pleasure thank
you everyone
I would like Ross please let me let me
introduce Tyler and Sorensen and nikolaj
first if you don't mind Ross I know that
you're you only have a couple minutes
but Tyler Sorensen and nikolaj you all
have entered into the theories of
everything physics and Consciousness
explication content contest and you made
fantastic
the pieces of art but but
well it's more than art it's informative
as well so like geez thank you all and
the links to it will be on screen and at
least it will be in the description once
this finally goes live so thank you all
for coming Tyler sorry I said and
Nikolai
yeah thank you thank you
Ross coldheart is an investigative
journalist I think these these words are
tattooed on my brain Ross because I've
seen that intro so many times I've
edited it it's our most it's one of our
most if not our most popular videos
thank you for that it's been a year
since I've spoken to you last
you're an investigative journalist who
has who well you're going to talk about
what you're working on shortly but
anyway just wanted to introduce you all
and we'll
we'll kick it off with
with
hearing what Ross is up to and then I
want to hear from you all about the
contest and telling everyone about your
videos please
what am I up to
um I'm rewriting the back end of my book
in plain sight because there's a new
edition coming out in 2023
and so much has happened in the past um
what 18 to 21 months since I published
the book
that I uh I think it needs an update uh
in fact I was I was actually I was
getting quite pessimistic towards the
end of 2022 because I was thinking that
yes we're all going to get snowed
there's really no desire at all for any
kind of truthful disclosure about what
it is whatever it is that the US
government knows if anything about the
phenomenon
and then as I was going through just
starting to think about all the things
that have happened since kind of um
you know the 2020 period it's quite
amazing really I mean there's been a
huge number of developments that give me
cause for optimism and and also I mean
I'm so privileged I've I I I know Matt
so worker because I've actually started
trying to understand physics by
following following some of Matt's work
frankly and as a as a journalist who's
somewhat deficient in understanding
physics and Mathematics I uh I I take my
head off to you good sir because you've
been able to popularize the subject
matter that I keenly think I need to
understand and uh I'm kind of a fanboy
of yours so it's a real privilege to
meet you that's that's really wonderful
to hear um it's always nice to know that
we're not wasting our time
yeah because you never know you know we
film in a a room staring at a camera
um there's no direct contact with anyone
that we're that I'm speaking to and so
hearing this sort of thing is
it's uplifting but even if not
do you still feel like you're having a
tremendous amount of fun
so for me at least like I'm having fun
right now I'm having fun whenever I
speak to guests like Ross solo Matt solo
even if it wasn't seen by many people I
wouldn't put it out and it's a
ridiculous frequently but thing to do is
a job and I'm grateful to be able to
very much just to follow curiosity
professionally
Ross you also have a podcast
can you state the name I do yes myself
and Bryce zabel my colleague in crime
Bryce is based in Los Angeles and he's a
a very well respected Hollywood uh
producer and screenwriter he's also
responsible for the Dark Skies series
and um uh he and I do a podcast called
need to know which is I guess an attempt
at a journalistic analysis uh news
program that looks at the phenomenon in
his
journalistically uh open eyed open
open-minded way as possible
um and uh it's uh I'm happy to say it's
thriving uh the the level of public
interest at the moment in the in the
phenomenon of uaps if there is such a
term this um is absolutely amazing I I
have to admit to Kurt I I um I almost
missed your invitation to this event
because I have had so many emails and
messages from people from all over the
world who who seem to think that this
journalist in Australia has incredible
resources to be able to investigate
stuff and people are sending the
original documents and witness accounts
and statements and uh it's it's all a
bit overwhelming but also it's it's it's
flattering because what it recognizes is
something that I think is really
deficient at the moment which is that
there is a a real shortage of objective
analytical news media engaging with what
I think is the biggest story of the
moment I mean I I'm I'm excited by
what's going on in modern science right
now I I love I'm just such a fan of the
stuff coming out of the James Webb
Telescope and um it's it's so exciting
to see this Cutting Edge technology
revealing stuff about the universe that
we don't know and how could people not
be engaged in a similar in a similar way
with what's being
somewhat begrudgingly admitted by the
United States government and to elicit
agree by other governments that there is
a phenomenon a mystery art there that
they don't understand
and none of us are saying it's little
green aliens despite what Mr Jenkins of
the Wall Street Journal or Mr Barnes of
the New York Times say frankly we just
don't know that there's a there's a
phenomenon which is a genuine mystery
that is confounding the best brains in
the in the Pentagon and the intelligence
community and I can tell you it's also
befuddling people in our um intelligence
services and defense community in
Australia even though they don't want to
talk about it and um it's it's
fascinating because
there is something out there that is
worthy of investigation and ultimately
at the heart of it good science as we
all know is about being willing to
engage with
the unknown and try and understand it
and uh I I think 2023 promises to be
quite an exciting year
speaking of the unknown these the
following threes are Taylor and Sorensen
and nikolaj they may be unknown to the
majority of the people here and they
shouldn't be so please I'm going to get
you all to introduce yourselves and give
a bit a brief overview as to what your
submission to the contest was and then
if you have any questions for Matt or
Ross please please ask so Tyler starting
with you then Sorensen then nikolaj and
thank you all
uh yeah thank you for having me on here
today uh my submission was about
what uh a Theory of Everything Is
essentially and what the process is like
of
Pro developing one and proposing one and
it's quite a unique uh experience and it
leads to a lot of lessons that I don't
think can really be uh
learned outside of that process so that
was what my uh my entry primarily
focused on
it was called theories of everything a
how-to guide
okay so I'll place that again in the
description I'll try and pin it well
right now in Sorensen
hello can you hear me yes okay and my
submission is called time independent
solution to a electron orientation
and it starts I started by
surviving some a little round
questions
and and seeing that instead of using a
gate condition you can define a electric
time component
and then uh yeah and then this when you
use this time command you get some
Quantum like effects
in electrical management and then I
could be aware ladder and
find some time independent solutions for
for this
equations
thank you
thank you and nikolaj and correct me if
I'm mispronouncing your name and if I
don't think I've met any of you Tyler
we've spoken but I haven't met you so
this is a pleasure so firstly so
great great Nikolai
yeah well I'm from Denmark so it's
pronounced Naval life but it's it's not
sorry sorry Nikolai oh my gosh
and well thank you for always it's an
excellent idea to this could thank you a
lot well I'm I'm
uh I've done something with different uh
I've tried to sketch a model for
fundamental nature reality but it's uh
well it's an it's a physical idealistic
model it's
it has some similarities with another
Castro's use I think and it's based on a
paper that was published last year and
and I have uh I've taken some elements
from a dentist Mystic called Martino's
he has a presented a comprehensive
metaphysical system and I take some core
aspects of his system and
uh well translated them into
academic philosophical language one
might say in order to
uh to sketch this
um
this uh model for the fundamental nature
of reality it's a it's a triadic model
so it's
the basic concept is that nature is
um
it's a triadic structure that kind of
generates Consciousness and experience
so
yeah well Matt has to get going and Matt
like it's I thank you for coming on at
spending again like your precious time
your holiday time thank you for coming
on twice on toll inventing reality is an
Indiegogo which is just read the
description of it I'm going to briefly
read it what is reality reality has
proved strange beyond our intuitions and
exciting
New Vision is emerging is reductionism
dead
can physics ever hope to find ground
truth the toe themes if you're
interested in that then go to
go to this the link hold on just this
link right here which will be in the
description and check out Matt's
Indiegogo as well as PBS space time and
Matt do you have any parting words and
if anyone has a quick question for Matt
that he can answer in 30 seconds then
please ask it now
else Matt just say goodbye
um no parting words except thank you
Kurt it's really good to be here again
uh I I hope we can make it make it
regular
um
and maybe find a way to get you on space
so I don't know we don't do that sort of
thing but maybe we should maybe we
should mix it up
um yeah you're gonna hold you to that we
have we we have the same goal
um so I appreciate the chance to join
the conversation the the incredible
conversation that you have curated among
all these uh all these great minds
um
yeah thank you Matt
okay take care man yeah man all right
appreciate it
Okay Ross
Ross it's so good to see you it's it's
like honestly thank you again thank you
too for for spending such time with me I
know that you said this is
precious family time and I imagine I I
can imagine just how much
stressed you're under and how many
projects you're juggling with atop
family commitments were you able to get
any breathing room so far over the
course of the past 10 days it's been a
beautiful Break
um it's funny actually because one of
the things that
um I don't know about you guys you are
the people that when I'm in done time
especially when I'm doing things like um
I I live on a little farm and I
constantly have to mow it because all
it's doing at the moment here in
Australia is raining and lots of
sunshine and so we have days of rain and
days of sunshine and my grass is just
growing constantly so for me it's a
constant battle against Grass and um I'm
um I I think somebody could do a
scientific courtesy and develop grass
that grows to a certain length and stops
growing then the rest of us don't have
to mow it anymore but when I'm doing my
mowing I find I do some of my best
thinking and it's that it's that idea
that by doing a task that has become so
autonomic so so you know something that
you don't even think about when you're
doing it you start thinking about big
things and um I love this time of year
because it's a genuinely creative time
of the year the rest of the year you're
so busy that you don't really get time
to stop and think and be creative and
I'm intrigued it's one of the things
I've actually been thinking of writing a
book about this is the number of
people that I've been talking to in the
the mystery behind the phenomenon
the UAP phenomenon the sort of the weird
paranormal world of people saying that
they've had these extraordinary
experiences the number of times people
say to me they've had downloads
where they literally all of a sudden
wake up and um and they've got these
incredible ideas in their head and then
I started researching it recently and I
was fascinated to read that um James
Crick the the the the person who
conceived the shape of the DNA helix
um he said that the whole idea of the
shape of DNA came to him in a dream
and then I started Googling and and
pulling out books off my shelf and it
really is it's fascinating how many
scientists
describe that the moment of great
inspiration that they had where they
they suddenly realized an idea or or
they suddenly be able to crystallize a
concept in their brain and they describe
being in a dream state or um not really
focusing in the intense way that we do
focus when we focus on things to try and
study and I just wonder sometimes
whether there's some aspect of the brain
that
allows us to work on things in the
background that we haven't yet described
because that's my chart of the year I I
love this time of the year because it's
a creative time of the year ideas start
bobbing into my head about what my next
book might be or because I'm a an
investigative journalist for a TV show
here in Australia I I also think about
what what the next story should be
and uh there's a nervous but um
interested part of me that's really
interested in the um the cultural Wars
right now I'm I'm fascinated by the war
on woke uh the fact that um it's
becoming a heresy now to
um to uh to to use certain language you
know you the the slightly Marxist
culture wars that dictate what language
we will use to describe gender and uh
whilst I'm absolutely fulsome advocate
of friends of mine who've decided to
transition I don't like the way language
is being appropriated and uh uh I think
they must write a book at it booking it
somewhere is there something different
about that is there something there that
strikes you as
um I I think um and again I'm actually
nervous even discussing this really
because I haven't done my homework
yeah but uh no and I I think that
universally around the world what we're
seeing is an attempt by
a
particular type of thinking to capture
ideas by
making certain ideas a transgression
from culturally accepted imperatives and
um it's it's the fact that there does
need I think there needs to be an open
and public discussion about
um what constitutes gender
uh I did a story once about uh a
beautiful woman who I accept as a woman
called Kim Petra and uh she um was a
born biologically a boy in Germany
Austria
and we um I went across from Australia
thinking this is all a load of nonsense
you know there's no such thing as
transgenders and stuff like that and um
uh she was the most beautiful young
woman and in return for shooting her
first music video we got the opportunity
to um to interview her about her
transition and and why she um she
decided that she was a woman and the uh
the German Austrian authorities allowed
us to interview her psychiatrists and
the the people who'd made the um uh the
decision that she should be the youngest
person ever to be allowed to undergo the
hormone therapy and then eventually the
surgery and
um I love the fact that she's now I
think performing in Los Angeles and
doing a very successful career as a
beautiful young woman so I guess I'm
probably more open-minded than a lot of
people about gender but at the same time
I don't like the way that
the cultural Wars have appropriated
things and you're not allowed to raise
things I don't like the way JK Rowling
was treated for saying what she said and
she wrote a beautiful 3000 word essay
and got vilified for um uh essentially
standing up for
people who who challenged cultural
imperatives about what constitutes
gender and I think there's a discussion
there that needs to be had maybe I'm
just Reckless maybe I maybe I just
didn't get attracted to contrarian areas
that such as uaps that people shouldn't
go near you know us media should do as
we're told and not go into these areas
of dangerous journalism where you get
into areas that are sensitive and taboo
well you're in an already dangerous at
least sensitive at least marketable area
which is UFOs
and it shouldn't be but
one of the things I've noticed this year
by the way that one of the things I've
noticed this year that has really scared
me a little is the
the nastiness that is starting to
develop on social media uh
around anybody that you know I've taken
quite a public position in saying as I
constantly do that the phenomenon is
real that whatever it is it's a genuine
mystery acknowledged us so you feel like
it's gotten nastier I feel like it's
gotten more welcoming and more
acceptable
I
suspect targeted troll campaigns you
know um uh there's a
um somebody out there doesn't like
people
like me rocking the boat and asking
questions about the phenomenon and um
there are a number of uh people who
basically made up their work to try and
pull down people who Express a view
that's opposite to the um
to the uh the accepted reality and uh I
I you know the bottom line is um I I
think we should ground our
investigations in solid science
um but then
just hold on to that thought Ross sorry
because I I rudely am having Tyler and
Nikolai and Nikolai sorry and and nud if
I'm even pronouncing that correctly
sorry Sauron sin I'll at least say it
which I can moderately or at least
passively pronounce
I'm I'm having you all here and and
you're probably wondering like well can
I come in do I have a question can I say
something so just so you know there's
only about two minutes left for for you
all before I have to let in other people
and actually I have to go on a walking
break because my legs are just so stiff
my neck as well
but if you all have any questions for
Ross then please like please do ask
okay I have a question
have you seen that a few weeks ago there
was a easy girl who make a YouTube
channel
can you repeat that once once more yes
uh I ask you if you have seen that two
weeks ago there was a
girl who made a
Channel
an E.T girl what she was claiming to be
alien was she yes
I mean had we proved that I mean this is
the I care out I'll tell you how my
brain works not when I get a message
like that I've had people contact me who
claim to be alien and I'm quite ruthless
with them you know I I I'm not taking
the piss with them but at the same time
I I expect people to be able to provide
evidence before I even engage
and um uh for example uh there's a um
while I went I won't cite this because
it's probably a bit dangerous but no I
mean I've I've been approached on
multiple occasions by people who purport
to be speaking on behalf of non-human
intelligence and I say great fantastic
um provide me with some evidence of that
you know I'm not willing to engage
because until I I know that you are who
you say you are and in the same way that
scientists verify academic credentials
before they make a an assessment about
the validity of Assessments that people
make journalists have to look into the
provenance of
um
claims made by somebody and I mean I'm
fascinated for example
um there's a chap called Santos who's a
politician in the United States who's in
terrible trouble at the moment because
he's been fibbing about his um his
background and he's lied egregiously
about his academic qualifications his
work experience and even whether his
poor mother died of cancer and the
incredible thing is is that this is a
person who's made it into the Congress
no less and in all the verification
procedures that go on in the world you
would think that before somebody is
allowed to become a member of the
Congress of the United States you
actually verify their background and
make sure that they are who they say
they are and um in the same way I think
one of the things that I recognize as a
problem in the study of the phenomenon
of uaps UFOs is there are
so many people who are so credulous
um about certain things for example I
um I'll give you one example notice the
uh the Space Program uh people people
say there is a secret space program and
there are people like Corey good and
others who go around giving conferences
earning tens of thousands of dollars
claiming that they are people who've
fought for some kind of Intergalactic
um uh Army against other aliens and it's
all Preposterous in my view and I I've
basically said to people who've told me
about this and they say oh you know why
don't you why don't you engage with this
why don't you take it seriously and I
say well give me a good reason to do so
and and the bottom line is science
empirical science where you use data is
a really good starting point to make a
judgment as to whether or not something
should be engaged with so if somebody
contacts me as they have done saying
that they're alien I mean the Anjali
case there's a classic
um this is a woman who claimed to have
had an extraordinary experience where
she went into a hill knit aliens and um
and she claimed that there would be an
opportunity for the media and selected
Representatives I was on the list at one
stage to actually go and meet these
aliens and I was terribly excited but
very very very skeptical and not to
anyone's surprise at all
system went away and
no I didn't know about the uh the fact
that there's a woman who's purporting to
be an alien but it doesn't surprise me I
mean there are there are a lot of
um
there are a lot of odd
planes that are made but frankly I don't
think we even need to look at odd claims
we just need to accept the fact that the
prevailing acknowledged officially
acknowledged mystery is enough for all
of us we now are in a new paradigm we're
in a new paradigm where basically the
government of the United States and to a
lesser degree other governments like the
British government and I think the
French government's being pretty good
too and the Russians they're all
acknowledging in varying degrees in a
public way that there is a genuine
mystery involving a phenomenon that
manifests itself in the sky that is
apparently detectable on radar that does
weird things that are Beyond known human
science that appears to manifest itself
as as craft as technological objects and
I find that fascinating and I think it
should be investigated and for me that's
enough of a mystery I don't think we
need to
um
get too involved with people who make
claims that they can't substantiate
Ross
I have to go for five minutes at least
just a stretch and Tyler and Nikolai
like I I apologize that that you're all
just just sitting here and I I would
love to talk with you further on the toe
podcast at some point once I have a
chance to go into your theories no
promises please it may even take years
but for sure we'll talk
off air and and Tyler it's like a
pleasure to meet you man I I want
everyone to search Tyler
Goldstein and I'll leave the link in the
description Nikolai and Sorenson so if
you have any so please just parting
words Tyler Nikolai Sorensen before we
go on a mini break
impressive that you can manage this
because there's so many people lots of
stuff happening at the chat or you see
that but thank you yeah
you have no idea man so yeah Tyler
yeah this is quite an operation so I'm
definitely impressed as well but I'm
just grateful to be here and uh and it's
it's been a greater
experience watching this Channel and and
seeing it help develop this discussion
around theories of everything and and
the fundamental nature of reality so
yeah
yeah I'd say that it'll be I've been
very grateful for
that you made this competition and I
have
been watching somebody out all our
videos and downloaders and books they
recommended and
interesting
thank you okay goodbye to Tyler Nikolai
and Sorensen now Ross I know that you
have special you probably have got to
get going if you feel like staying on
then then we would I would love to
welcome you on because the next guests
after this five minute break alien girl
Richie gaffon Garrett Vandenberg Chris
Leto and the Daniel from active
inference that's after five minute break
so if you feel like coming on with them
then you're more than welcome to stay if
you have to go I understand Ross
I can stick around for about five or ten
so uh that's fine okay well we're going
to take a five minute break anyway so
why don't you go get a cup of tea or
whatever you have to do and we're gonna
stretch my legs
there are a thousand people here and I'm
about to let in alien girl Amy
hey what's up girl how's it going good
great great it's good to finally meet
you Richie goffon good to meet you as
well thank you patience I appreciate
that man
Garrett Vandenberg hey how's it going
well we met good to see you again yeah
Chris Leno and Dan hey guys from active
inference
like these are all podcasts we're all
podcasters every single person here's a
podcaster even you Ross
even you
well thank you welcome welcome to this
celebration and all of the links to
every one of you will be on the screen
shortly but I'm gonna go through one by
one Ross I want to promote your podcast
need to know as well as the book in
plain sight
in plain sight I'm hepatitudinous Amy
alien girl11 the username says it all
you can search for that and that I
believe is also your Twitter and your
YouTube
that is correct that's where you can
find me on everything just Google it and
everything pops up and thank you so much
for having me on this is amazing yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's well thank you for
being so patient it's like just waiting
in the airport lounge I'm sure you're
just like okay come on the flight said
it was supposed to come on an hour ago
it's delayed and I have this and I'm so
thank you all I know
Chris Leto I believe doesn't need much
of an introduction but I'll attempt to
give one anyways it's a former pilot
correct
yes yep for former Air Force pilot who
has a great channel that analyzes uaps
and also you have your own toe which
we'll talk about everybody
about 10 of them so Garrett says Garrett
sorry it doesn't say it's from this
could be interesting
the podcast
that's right right and you also have
your own music channel which again I'll
link all of these
Richie Rich hey gafon
g-u-f-o-n so like UFO with G and N
placed at the borders sure
yeah greatest UFO Network
all right right actually it's my last
name Giordano's UFO Network yeah well it
serves multiple purposes of Daniel it
does inference
it's a it's a pleasure to meet you I
don't think we met man we have not no we
just uh emailed back and forth yeah nice
to meet you officially yeah nice to meet
you nice everybody here too yeah
and Ross I don't know if you're familiar
so who who here are you familiar with
Ross
I know uh I know Chris very well uh in
fact I just saw some beautiful pictures
of Chris's family just the other day he
posted a beautiful Christmas picture and
I congratulated him on his beautiful
kids and family and uh I've uh Richie
I've I've I sort of know although I do
like your shirt sir it's it's fantastic
I wish I had one of those uh and alien
girl and Garrett and Daniel I'm going to
have to inform myself but uh lovely to
meet all of you great to meet you Ross
likewise
yeah how's Australia are you back there
uh yeah yeah it's beautiful in fact it's
we've we've had the wettest Christmas
period of as far as I can remember and
um we had uh a bit over an inch and a
half of rain yesterday and um it's now
come out in beautiful blue sky weather
and uh and I'm really looking forward to
getting out amongst it after we have
this chat it's um it's been so rare
we've we had the pandemic then we had
floods and fires with we literally had
the Apocalypse in Australia because I
mean you might all remember we had
bushfires a few years ago we've had
fires floods pandemic I'm waiting for
Locust plagues and then a farmer friend
of mine pointed out that he's had Locus
plagues and we also had Mass plagues
earlier in the year as well so you know
frankly I think we've done the
apocalypse here already
don't you guys get dust storms out there
uh not where I live although
periodically you will you'll get a big
dump of red Outback dirt on everything
in your garden and uh periodically you
just get these weird dumps of of Red
Dirt but uh the Outback from where I am
is probably about four hours West but
periodically yes every now and then
you'll get a big lump of dust that
basically comes from nowhere but the big
truth the great mythology about
Australia is that we all walk around
with hats on our head with corks around
them and we live by billabongs and um
you know have kangaroos in our backyard
although I do have kangaroos in my
backyard
um the uh the reality is that most
Australians live on the coast and um
we're actually a coastal uh country and
vast amounts of the interior of
Australia are basically empty empty and
dry and Dusty and all all in all pretty
and hospitable
did you figure out which deity was was
sending the plagues to you or how did
that happen
I'm sorry what was that sorry I was just
joking I said did you figure out which
deity was was plaguing you with rats and
locusts and all of this oh no no no no
no it's um we we have felt well I must
confess I I really felt further up your
way Kurt because you've had some
shocking weather I've had friends who've
been in houses with minus 15 C which is
which that's about minus 25c
um uh I can't believe how cold it's got
up your way and um yeah uh around yeah
I'm so bloody hot here it was ridiculous
it was 31 centigrade
yeah it there's been storms here in case
people are wondering what is being
referenced them from Toronto and
recently there's been a slew of not just
extreme cold like minus 27 Celsius yeah
but and the wind chill is just crazy too
did you have your power go out at all
Kurt frozen rain no luckily and Daniel I
didn't give you a proper introduction
Daniel So Daniel please come in and
introduce yourself as as you have an it
well please introduce yourself Daniel's
from the active inference Institute
thank you Kurt greetings all
personally I'm a researcher in
California
I'm here as a uh Emissary of the active
inference Institute we're an open
Science Institute and we're learning and
applying active inference
so you may or may not have heard of it
but it's all there in the name it's
about action and inference Kurt has
featured some incredible and really
powerful discussions with several of the
leading researchers Carl friston Mike
Levin Chris Fields it's been some
incredible discussions and we come from
many different perspectives a lot of
different languages people with a lot of
mathematical backgrounds people who are
just becoming familiar with the
mathematics and we strive to make active
inference accessible and rigorous and
applicable and we have a great time
entertaining and dancing with theories
of things which is something which I'm
sure we can go into
okay now
okay just a moment
yep my headphone was telling me battery
is low
okay so Robert you're in the waiting
room and Lou please wait
thank you I hope that you can hear me
please give a thumbs up if you can hear
me
all right thank you for your patience I
appreciate it so just let's go over what
we
what are we looking forward to most in
2023
UFO report
I'm going to change my headphones so
continue please
I'm very excited about the NDA
I think it's super super powerful at
least I mean what do you think Ross I
think it's going to be a game changer
um I I look I I think the ndia what
we're talking about here is the National
Defense authorization act which has got
a whole lot of Provisions that make it
possible for people to blow the whistle
on if they exist secret programs that
are disguising
perhaps position of UFO UAP related
technology inside the US government and
they may in fact shed light on whether
or not the United States government
incredibly as incredible as it may seem
has ever been involved in retrieving
non-human technology or engaging with a
non-human intelligence and so it may be
that the Congress gets the answers on
this this year because of legislation
but Chris My worry is that um there have
already been hearings and I'm told and
some of this is starting to dribble out
I'm told that there have already been
witnesses that have given quite a lot of
detail in camera to the Senate
intelligence committee and the armed
services committee but um the big
question in my mind is whether the
Public's going to get told anything
about what these committees have heard
and it's interesting because really the
decision on what is released in any
unclassified report is really up to the
committee cheers and um uh my worry at
the moment frankly is that because
there's a delayed report to the Congress
that was due on the 31st of October
which was meant to be the first annual
report of what essentially is a UAP task
force inside the Pentagon because that's
delay not one politician has spoken out
to say how outrageous this is that it's
essentially flouting and ignoring the
statutory requirements of Congress so
I'm a little bit worried that what that
Flags is
um kind of like a a an attitude by the
Pentagon and the intelligence community
that really it's not going to take these
kind of requirements very seriously so I
just hope that the politicians muscle up
because the big question is going to be
yes Congress is getting told this stuff
but is the public going to be allowed to
know because we do we need to know
Tim burchett came out and said it's the
government is corrupt he actually used
the words corrupt they're not going to
do anything with this stuff he's afraid
we're never going to see anything the
light of day like what you're talking
about I believe that tonight
yeah Richie and the interesting thing
about Tim is that I know Tim has sat in
on one of these hearings at least where
Witnesses were deposed and were giving
quite dramatic evidence to the Congress
and uh because he sat in on that hearing
he's not allowed to talk about it and
it's not him who's told me about the
fact that he was in that hearing I'm I'm
aware of this from other sources but the
uh the interesting thing is is that it's
a bit like once you become part of the
secret world you have to sign your ndas
and you have to make your secrecy oath
the the big problem for politicians is
what on Earth are they being told behind
closed doors which is so secret that the
rest of the world isn't allowed to know
about it and Richie that's my Worry My
worry is that yes Congress may get told
something but the rest of us are going
to have a paper bag put over our head
and we're going to be kept in the dark
and fit on BS
once they start that process of opening
up Pandora's Box you can't close it
that's why this stuff has to be
scrutinized down to every single detail
what can be told what can't be they've
got a big big job ahead of them by not
accidentally saying something or showing
us something they shouldn't
you know we saw what happened the first
congressional hearing on UFOs it really
was not impressive at all so if that's
things to come you know and it's going
to be the same well yeah right
I'm worried we're all going to get
snowed basically and it's happened
before it happened what do you mean can
you repeat that because I don't
understand that this must be an
Australian oh uh it's basically I'm
worried that I'm worried that what's
going on at the moment is that there is
an attempt to pull the wool over our
eyes there's been an attempt to
constrain the whole Narrative of what
we're investigating by starting at 2004.
um Chris would know that you know
obviously a lot of the focus on the USS
Nimitz incident from 2004 and the
incidents involving the U.S Navy from
2014 2015 and since it's very important
that those are investigated but I I
suspect that there's a deliberate
attempt by people in the Pentagon and
the intelligence Community to avoid
accountability and public scrutiny over
what they've known in the decades prior
did they lie about Roswell did they lie
about other recoveries that allegedly
took place in the 1950s and the 1940s I
know it sounds crazy but imminent
respectable people are now asserting
that there is some truth possibly to the
idea that the United States government
is in possession of non-human technology
which is a Preposterous claim it's an
amazing allegation and I don't know why
it's not on the front pages of every
major newspaper I mean when you look at
the caliber of the people that have come
forward and said that they think that
this has credibility and that it should
be investigated and where are the Wall
Street Journal in the New York Times not
only are they asleep at the wheel
they're running polemics from lick
spittle journalists who are basically
running a party line given to them
probably over a glass of Shandy in a
golf club near the CIA somewhere frankly
it's outrageous journalists are there to
cause Mischief they're caused there to
Rattle the boat
Ross I gotta invite in our next guest
Bob lesno Lou Angelus
and Robert Lawrence [ __ ]
thank you all this is like so there's a
comments above that says this show is
running this tone Anza is running the
gamut from smaller podcasters all the
way up to PBS space time which is 2.77
million and Robert [ __ ] like Robert
Coons Channel closer to truth that's
like a
that's like a dream job you have Robert
and Luke Angeles people visit Lou
reviews I will leave the link in the
description but anyway welcome Robert
and Lou
good to see you Kirk congratulations on
a great year uh toe has really uh
developed over the year and we're all
applauding it
well thank you Lou
it's good to see you oh yeah absolutely
thank you for the invite uh pleasure to
be here
so Robert closer to truth what's is that
like okay forget about closer to truth
what else are you looking forward to in
the upcoming year well maybe don't
forget about closer to truth but yeah
well I have uh two sides of my brain I
don't know which is which uh but um you
know in terms of in terms of the world
uh we hope to have a better year
um I I follow
International affairs with uh quite
quite rigorously in my other in my
non-in closer to truth life uh I'm very
much involved with China so I I look at
the world from both a China perspective
and a U.S perspective and uh
with Ukraine and Russia it's a terrible
situation which affects all of us so we
hope they hope there'll be some uh some
significant transformation on that that
that's the hope but the likelihood it
doesn't look that way
so that's on the one hand close to the
truth I can be much more optimistic
about we we just launched the new
website after about a year in
development a few weeks ago and we're
excited about that
um and we're developing new new areas of
content we have focused in the past on
Cosmos physics
mathematics a third and a third on brain
mind Consciousness Free Will personal
identity diverse intelligences ESP
um
ESB it's not a lot of major thing of
what we do but it's definitely
definitely part of our explorations of
Consciousness from a particular point of
view and the third category is uh is
meaning which is basically philosophy of
religion the inter it's a relationship
between philosophy of religion and the
Sciences
as well as kind of Hardcore philosophy
those have been the three areas but
we're expanding it now
category which will include life which
will be life and and the primary aspect
is philosophy of biology so it'll
probably take we've just done our first
filming it'll take
it'll take well into the Year by the end
of the year before we start posting a
lot of a lot of material but it's it's a
new area for us and we think it's very
probative of the nature of reality to
really discuss the the nature of life
from all different points of view
particularly from a philosophical point
of view evolution is a a core area to
really understand how that works and
there's a lot of controversy in it but
it goes broader than that so that's what
we're looking at we're also developing
uh in the past our meaning section uh
has been largely uh
Western philosophy of religion and in
particular a Christian philosophy of
religion and there are two reasons for
it one is that
we're in the west and we film in the U.S
and UK so it's it's more convenient but
that's really the secondary reason the
main reason is that some of the most
sophisticated philosophy since the
Middle Ages has been in Christian
philosophy uh so that's why we we do
that my mother who died a few years ago
at 102 used to watch closer to truth
she'd understand anything she just was
happy to see me if I was happy and upset
if I if I look sad but she always asks
me she always asked me why don't you
have I see a lot of Christian
philosophers why don't you have any
Jewish philosophers
and so I said Mom I said we have a lot
of Jews they're all the atheist
physicists interesting
Okay so
so Rob I'm gonna what we're doing this
year to finish it off is that we've
developed a new area of global
philosophy of religion in which we're
focusing on uh non-judeo-christian
religions Islam is very close of course
in the abrahamic Traditions but also
Hindu Buddhist philosophy uh and some of
the more obscure areas Baha'i faith
zoroastrinism
um uh Sufism uh seek is um Shinto is um
so we're trying to get some of the same
basic questions which are non-sectarian
but it drives through different
perspectives
so I know there are nine people here I
didn't even know that this stream yard
allows this many people there's a 10th
person the jockey right here
so glad this isn't crashing or just
giving me some error and everyone was
allowed to be in you can do 10. yeah
there is ten there's one extra person
like I mentioned the jockey the jockey
hey Kurt um Kurt I've got to take off in
in a minute yeah but um I want to thank
you for having me on here briefly and
talking to everybody here and it was
good yeah yeah I I appreciate you coming
on it's it was it's lovely to have you
thank you for spending some of your
December 30th with me like you all like
Lou Robert Daniel
Chris Ross Ross is just chilling with me
in that chair
and Amy I haven't heard you speak up
much so I'm gonna Force some speech out
of you yes no please yes um I'm just
really excited to be here Pirates have a
good one yeah and before Amy I know I
just told you to speak up but I do need
to give an introduction to himself so
Lou please for the audience who may not
be aware of you give a an introduction
to yourself and then also to Lou reviews
please
uh yeah hi uh my name is Louise Jimenez
uh I um
yeah organized a um Grassroots efforts
for a national call in the Congress for
more clarity on the UAP topic
um and recently I've also added um
movies video games food reviews to my
channel so we'll be doing a lot of that
stuff too
and so yeah they're coming on are you
okay in a nutshell yeah
I'm doing great yeah okay
so
okay Amy sorry you were championing
yes I just want to say this is such a
great you've done so amazing I've been
listening to it all day long you've had
such amazing guests I'm Blown Away by
all the people I'm around I really you
know great podcasters great people
um yeah I guess they just thank you so
much for having me here and just like to
piggyback kind of on what Ross was
saying about the information never
making it to the public right and that's
really the biggest concern of all and we
always talk about well you know
nothing's really happening and it's fun
because Lou Jimenez is here big phone
home guy right but there are politicians
like Tim birchett you know there's Marco
Rubio we all know and so I'm just really
excited that we're all just here talking
about it sometimes I think half of it is
just it's just talking about it it's
such a complex topic and when you can
finally link up with people who are
really trying to get to it so thank you
so much for putting this together thanks
for inviting me this is just I'm having
a lot of fun
so
Robert about UFOs
have you been asked about that on your
show and are you interested in exploring
it yeah that's a great question I think
that there are three areas that many
viewers ask about uh increasingly
especially as we've gone more Global it
used to be 100 in the U.S now we're
about 55 outside the US uh three the
three topics are uh ndes near death
experiences reincarnation and UFOs uh
uaps
um and
my primary response to to all of that is
that none of those subjects
are directly
aligned with the uh the very narrow
approach the closer the truth has which
is to use both the scientific and a
philosophical approach to it we don't
report the latest news in physics that's
not what we do we look for the
implications of it so the example I use
of when people ask us to do more of that
and I've taken that seriously in terms
of planning to do more about it because
I've resisted it in the past and the
example I've used is what we've done
with ESP and parapsychology because that
we have addressed in multiple uh shows
and videos many dozens of videos with
some of the leaders the things in the
field and what we don't do is try to be
the adjudicator of right acts of the
matter
because you know I'm not confident to do
that I think I'm pretty competent in a
lot of ways but I'm not competent to to
uh to do the statistical analysis I just
know that a lot of smart people on both
sides have very strong positions
with ESP and parapsychology
they do the existence of God to kind of
broaden it out
um and so it's about a connection
between the para parapsychology and UFOs
or the topic of UFOs almost never comes
up yeah so far the UFOs has not come up
but parapsychology and ESP is and the
way we approach it is assume it to be
true and I always make the caveat that I
don't assume it to be true but if it is
what what would it mean and how would it
work and what are some of the mechanisms
involved how could it work
um and explore from that kind of
perspective and I think we've had a
diverse number of ways of thinking about
uh ESP from just fewer pure kinds of uh
quasi physical uh manifestations of
brain waves and some hyper and Hyper
aware sense in a physical sense to very
extreme sense of multi-dimensional
approaches to mentality and and some
would would relate it to UFOs so the
only time we've dealt with UFO is just
been in in some
not the majority but a number of
explanations for extra sensory
perception kinds of things
and so
um you know that that is the way we
would have if we would approach and I
think we need to do more we will do more
on reincarnation because that affects
Global philosophy or religion how
different uh groups uh think about these
questions
um and you know open to the Future on on
thinking through some of some of the
issues uh you know I'm pretty much uh a
skeptic on everything I mean that's my
mental set on on all sides of the issue
um sometimes I don't even know where I
what I believe myself but every view I
have I want a subject to kind of
critical thinking
um so you know I I I I like to say that
um I keep an open mind but one eye is
always at least one eye is always
hypocritical
Rob Ross has to get going so I just want
to promote need to know as well as the
the book in plain sight
so
Ross please
good to talk to all of you and uh my
essentially New Year's Eve here today in
Australia and I hope all of us have a a
happy and uh let's say more peaceful
2023 and may it be an Illuminating one
on the UAP mystery best wishes to all of
you and um imminent happy New Year best
wishes amen thank you Ross for spending
some time with you especially for so
long man thank you no worries bye-bye
cheers
ah
all right it's just us now Rob do you
consider yourself a podcaster or you
consider what is it that you
that's akin to podcasting it's
interviews it's like legit interviews
but
I'm curious what you classify yourself
as
um I I I I you know I I don't classify
myself other people can do it I just
have fun yeah
three or four different forms that we've
used originally it was very high
production value interviews
um and conversations that we would do in
a very short segments of uh seven to
twelve minute segments when we do live
interviews on location I mean in person
location uh interviews and then those
would be uh used on our website and and
YouTube as whole uh little chunks and
then we take excerpts of that of each of
the segments two and a half or three and
a half minutes and weave them together
into half hour television shows so we've
now done over 300 television shows over
20 years
and most of them will have four to six
contributors in each one in which we've
honed down those particular interviews
and and create sort of a a narrative Arc
uh about a topic that is in general a
sophisticated topic like The Observer
and quantum mechanics or uh the
different mechanisms how the brain could
create mind or
the nature of of a deity if if it said
that God knows everything what does that
mean does that mean God knows the future
is there free will with that those kinds
of sophisticated kinds of questions that
we weave a narrative on and then of
course since the pandemic we've started
online
um interviews as as we're doing now
um and and that that has its own
different Cadence to it that uh is is
great we can reach more people that way
that we wouldn't ordinarily do because
in the past when you're on location uh
you really confined to the people that
you can bring to that vocation or
generally it's at a conference
um and that sometimes leads to a
homogeneous genetic that's not
appropriate which we we really need more
diversity in every every sense of the
word diversity
um starting with diversity of ideas
Amy please I want to hear from you
and Daniel
yeah so
um yeah I mean I agree with him about
the diversity of ideas and in fact it's
something that I think makes this whole
network of people incredibly interesting
is everybody bounces ideas off of each
other and sometimes we don't always
agree but you know
I I just I get so connected with people
in this community and I have so much fun
with people in this community and I just
you know I'm just really happy that we
all can connect on this like awesome day
with theories of everything with Kurt
and I just hope that people take in a
lot of the fun that can go with ufology
because I know we can get into these
these these ideas right which is like
their frauds they're not frauds blah
blah blah but like I think if we just
kind of realize that ufology is about
looking for the real UFO
right we're looking for the real UFO and
I think when people focus on that a
little bit better it can really open up
a conversation to the possibilities that
we haven't even studied yet
Daniel I want to hear from you
the thought that comes to mind is
whether different intelligences would
come to similar formings in specific or
in general of theories of everything
would information Theory be something
with different kinds of pattern
recognition intelligences be shared or
communicable would they come to some of
the conclusions about Markov blankets
and how Markov blankets are related to
action and perception that we've come to
in active inference and communicating
across that blanket is as a non-ufo
researcher how I sometimes hear those
discussions what electromagnetic Spectra
and what kinds of semantics will be
conveyable and how can we have a
dialogue
synchronously or through time when there
might be entities that exist at
different spatial or temporal scales
Lou I want to hear from you
if you don't Wow first thing I thought
of was an ansible
to communicate across great distances I
don't know if that would work in
um
I guess from uh yeah that's exactly
where it's from it's from Morrison Scott
card zenders game it's basically a
device that allows you to communicate
with people that are light years away
um in a quicker more efficient way
because you send an email to somebody
who's a thousand light years away and it
takes them a year to get it you know
um through with this ansible so it's
like every time you check in with
somebody it's it's like basically a year
after they sent it so so much has
happened already between the time you
opened that message and the time it was
sent so
that's what makes that's the first thing
I thought of uh well we're thinking of
like sort of the open-mindedness of it
um you know I've sort of
really cheap dental 180 on My Views when
it comes to the UFO topic
um you know I got really close to the
top
and uh and saw that I mean at least to
me this is just a really sophisticated
way to hide extraordinary top secret
Tech and holes in our national security
system that are really embarrassing
um
either way this story is still really
fun and interesting
um whatever the reality is of it uh but
yeah
um okay so yeah 2023 well I was gonna
say 2023 I just hope for more clarity
on it from all so do you think
is it okay so do you think that China
also has access to Tech like this and if
so I'm curious Robert what you would
think because he's you're an expert on
China at least you're the most
knowledgeable about it here
salute what would that like do you think
so do you think it's just the government
that has access to this technology you
think maybe China as well
no I don't think the China has access to
this kind of Technology
okay so Robert if you don't mind
I don't know if it's a foolish question
or not but is it possible that China has
Tech like that that we see in UFOs like
Tic Tacs and extraordinarily fast
craft
no no question is absurd I I like sure
great
yeah
the more the question is not whether
it's absurd whether it's absurd enough
uh that's a good way to kind of keep
keep our mind sharp
um you know I I'm not a believer in
a lot of conspiracy theories
um and so I do not believe that either
any government is providing super secret
information that that almost defies the
laws of physics uh that that's not
something that I would subscribe to
for any any country under any condition
there's no conspiracy in the media to
keep things quiet
um so I'm a hyper skeptic about all that
Kristen Garrett I'm not saying that
there aren't some some uh circumstances
some events that may not be explainable
but there
if that's the case the answer in my
opinion will certainly not be secret
government agencies in any country
developing these Technologies I think
that's impossible
well if you look at the recent Twitter
files I mean
it looks like conspiracy is kind of the
actual Norm you know all of those all of
the Twitter files conspiracy theories
basically maybe but proven true so I I
don't know and you look at when you know
Ross was talking about the snow job
I think if you look the the report was
supposed to release October 31st
and the weekend prior you basically had
Matt you know mainstream articles and
all the major papers right New York Post
Washington Times And basically
saying that there's nothing to see here
right before the report had even been
released
you basically have these you know kind
of lower journalist hacks I think Ross
called them but he didn't use a pleasant
term but basically they're releasing
these articles saying that there's
nothing to see in the report before the
report even comes out
and then woe and behold they get kind of
negative reaction from these articles
and then the report is still not out you
know it's still delayed so
I don't know and then you look there's
still no mainstream coverage at all of
the NBA 2023 I mean there's just nothing
it seems just it's markedly missing
and you look at the FBI collusion and
the Twitter files to control the the
actual media I mean it I don't know it
just seems like
I think what we're doing here is really
the way the step forward that that
Kurt's doing and just as we're linking
up these you know more connections you
know I know four more people now today
you know than I did before before this
podcast and now we're just linking up
and now information travels faster and
it doesn't matter what they what some
secret office sends to The Washington
Post because we're all just talking to
each other
and your expeditions
and then I want to hear from Garrett
I'm sorry
can you talk about the work that you've
done this year with wave collapse
um so I was just thinking about that um
I had an interview with Dean radden he
works he's a scientist doctor at The
Institute of noetic Sciences and he's
proven now 14 out of 30 experiments have
proven that you can mentally think about
or observe the double set experiment at
distance and you can affect it so you
can collapse the wave function
uh and he proved that that was uh
distance independent
and so what that would mean is you could
put a Ouija board this is my idea or I
don't know my idea but anyway you could
put like a Ouija board or a keyboard
right on Mars and then you could sit
here on Earth and now you could just
think about
a the letter A you know
and that would if you had a sensitive
enough instrument now according to these
tests these experiments that Dean radden
did is you could detect that someone's
thinking about that letter A it
collapsed the wave function I think you
know from anywhere in the universe it'd
be non-local so in this case you could
just like think of a Ouija board and
transfer information anywhere in the
universe I don't know it seems like uh
it's very uh exciting so that's
collapsing the wave function with with
your brain I guess
Garrett what's on your mind
yeah well first of all thanks again for
having me and let me join in for this
conversation I it seems like there's
just about everybody who's in the room
right now is a podcaster or at least is
is making some kind of a kind of a
project that has to do with having
conversations right
I I kind of had a question sort of
directed at Robert and sort of at you
Kurt even
um about conversation because I've
noticed like obviously for I mean you
know anyways Kurt that I was doing you
know a project focused on conversation
for basically all of 2021
and I ended up kind of taking a lot of a
break this this past year because at a
certain point especially like if you if
you get honest and very
um
you actually ask the questions that
matter to you to a lot of different
people and really listen to their
answers it can be really emotionally
jarring it can be kind of overwhelming
in terms of taking in ideas and I wonder
like especially Robert you having spent
you said like 20 years talking to people
about very very deep topics
how do you like how do you keep an open
minded like you said and have kind of
one that's still looking critically
without kind of over correcting and
becoming too critical and while still
yeah it's still being open
I think over correcting is a very uh a
very good point to highlight because
there's always a danger in that in uh in
virtually everything that one does in
controversial areas
um that you you want to you want to
create the right of what you think is
the right impression and so you take the
opposite side to something that you
don't agree with and I think that's a
danger so I I'm I'm aware of that
um I I I I I I can't tell you that I've
gotten either uh bored or overwhelmed
after doing
um
know thousands of of uh of interview
questions with many hundreds maybe 500
people over these years in in
substantial depth
um I I can't tell you why I am any
closer to any real answers but I can
tell you is that the question you get
the most are you closer right right is
it we're usually you people
um always put a definitive article in
there and say are you closer to the
truth or I like watching closer to the
truth and I always correct them and say
it's not the truth it's closer to Truth
uh when it first started the manager of
the small PBS station that we started on
said when we talked about the title
closer to the truth and I said that's
not what this is going to be about it
can't be the truth it has to be closer
to true the present progressive kind of
understanding and when people have asked
me
how close I've become after all these
years I say I I appreciate
questions more I deeply understand the
questions in all of these categories
much more than I ever did and in fact I
love the questions and I luxuriate in
the questions themselves in their
specificity in how they articulate
together and that gives me a kind of
satisfaction
do I have a chance on answers I may but
I don't if I would I wouldn't take my
own opinions to Syria but I mean you're
asking high-stakes questions how do you
how do you engage with those like that
deeply unless I mean you must have some
sort of something grounding you that's
keeping you from feeling the anxiety of
like of the answers you know
yeah I I think you know I have a normal
life I have a family life and I deal
with other things in the world that's
very grounding
Carl Jung said that as well he said
that's what separates him from Nietzsche
is that Nietzsche could just go along
with his ideas and he didn't have a wife
he didn't have commitments to other
people and I just even just reading that
alone has helped me psychologically
tremendously to know that there is such
a thing as being too much in your head
and floating above and getting carried
away by the wind
sorry I interrupted your answer Robert
and then I want to hear Daniel I want to
hear what your answer is to the same
question that Garrett posed
sorry Robert I interrupted you no it's
it that's perfectly fine uh I think the
grounding is is good I have you know two
kinds of grounding one is the uh his
family and responsibilities uh for
family and children and grandchildren
and all the things that flow from that
um and then the other part of my life is
primary related
most people who know me either know me
for close to the truth or know me from
China very few associate the two and if
people ask me I'm very surprised when
I'm in my China mode that I do closer to
truth which seems radically different
which is uh I always say well that's my
evil twin brother I don't really talk
that very much which one's the evil one
the China One well whoever's asking me
the other one
is the evil
because of the truth the China guy is
the evil even the evil twin
um and so you know but that generally
gets me off the hook
yeah
yeah Daniel I want to hear your answer
please
I would second all of these embodied
groundings and to provide a more
conceptual answer it made me think of
the quotation by Lev fagotsky which is
through others we become ourselves and
so in dialogue it isn't necessarily just
getting whiplashed around and taking on
the other person's position in our heart
but it is about entertaining what is
said and about listening attentively and
probing actively and after a
conversation a research or a personal
conversation
I find that it's possible to feel more
of who I am more distinctive in that
sense and also more aligned with a
broader individual and Collective
purpose so seeing conversations not
merely for the information overload and
cognitive distances that they can induce
but also as these incremental stages of
differentiation by which we become who
we truly are and carry out the work that
we're here to do
hmm
and on the other hand it's important to
recognize the opposite problem which is
that after dealing with the kinds of
ultimate questions that some of us go
with Kirk you do and assume some of the
others uh that you can become employed
to it you can habituate and they they
can lose their power and it dulls your
senses and so I'm aware of that
possibility that that's not you know
I've not had that problem the question
yeah yeah I'm not at this they have too
much power these questions right now I
look forward to that
so Amy and Lou as an ending question and
I gotta kick you all out as much as I
want you here my
my room here
I'm I want to know what are you most
grateful for this year
yeah do you want to go first Lou
oh I know please leave me after you no
thank you
um my family honestly
um my daughter and my husband I love
them more than anything just the health
and
just having good health and being
blessed with you know a bunch of people
in my life who I love and I can connect
with
um and just you know all the things that
we do with people
wow just working with some of the people
in my life like in my in my regular day
like my whole days very much centered
around emphasizing much bigger issues
that are going on with with UFOs and
with aliens and you know so I'm I guess
I guess you could say yeah that's what
I'd say with that I'm very grateful and
being here thank you so much and it's
been a great 2022 I think we've got a
lot to look forward to in 2023
I'm grateful to have you all here like
yeah again thank you
that yeah I don't wanna that sounds like
an ending piece so Lou you please go uh
yeah I mean I'll double down on that you
know um family and friends outside of
the internet you know like tangible
human connections and people that
actually care about you
um those are those are the the
connections that I am most thankful for
in 2022 and I hope to make those
obviously stronger and hope all of yours
are stronger in the in the new year
you know what if you can circulate just
uh who I see names but I'm not sure who
was who is watching circulate who the
names are and what their websites are
yeah yeah it's a great great so Amy it's
from Alien girl11 which is your YouTube
channel as well as your Twitter handle
okay great this is correct
Garrett Vandenberg I'm not quite sure
what you're promoting right now why are
you here why am I here well yeah I I
have still my podcast which is
technically not not totally inactive I
still post clips and stuff occasionally
and I've been on some other people's
podcasts but the project I'm more
focused on this year is a musical one
I'm uh writing and releasing a
meditational uh album basically for to
help calm your nerves when thinking
through deep questions whether about
UFOs or about deep metaphysical things
but yeah it's it's sort of
what's it called yoga it's called
unknown and you can you can already
listen to some of the songs if you look
up my name on Spotify
okay and Lou and also who is in the
waiting room I see you your name starts
with a C I don't want to spoil it but I
see you just a moment
yeah um my blue reviews uh just YouTube
that and you'll find it and at Lou
ageless on Twitter
Lewis spelled Lu yes
Daniel Daniel active inference Institute
if you've watched some of the Carl
friston Behemoth podcasts
you will enjoy
Daniel's podcast or Daniel's channel
it's more than just a podcast
it's an open Science Institute everybody
is welcome to learn and apply all
languages and math backgrounds everybody
can act in first serve
Chris
uh yes Chris Ledo's name my Channel or
later files on YouTube and I just
released actually tonight and everybody
was here so there wasn't many people at
the premiere actually but released a
mini series episode one sorry about that
now we're a thousand people watching I
wanted to change it but I normally
release on Fridays you know but no great
show here everybody's been here so check
out the mini series after episode one on
Mount Wilson Ranch Journey to the cave
so interesting stuff there with Carl
Crusher
yeah it just
thanks and Robert Kuhn closer to truth
that like I don't it doesn't need an
introduction or an outro technically but
Robert please talk about it some more
and it's it's simple for anyone to
search it it's closer to truth you just
search that on Google or on YouTube and
you'll find the essentially High super
high quality versions of every single
intellectual you'd want a question posed
to who's currently living or well yes
who's currently living and and the
questions that you would like post to
them that are philosophical are
generally posed by Robert we still have
a lot a lot more to go I'm I'm the more
interviews we do the longer my list gets
uh so yeah we'll have to go into the
23rd Millennium before we can get there
everyone I find that to be the case as
well Rob Robert sorry because I get in I
get emailed on a daily basis people's
toes and I still encourage that
because I I tag them and eventually I
would like to go through them
but it's a growing list and so someone
that I said two years ago yeah I'll get
to you in three months now that's that's
I can't even see that that's that's
years in the future and I would love to
speak with you Robert just on what your
insights have been and how you navigate
questioning the questions of these
these
this is such yeah I I would extremely
tumultuous topics yeah I would I would
uh conclude with one thought which has
developed uh really over the last couple
of years not not before and that is the
universal uh ubiquity and uh interest in
the kinds of subjects that we we talk
about which gives me uh great
encouragement for humankind because a
lot of the other data that we have goes
in the other direction
uh but we get and I'm sure you do two
curtain up others uh literally from 190
countries
um and from every ethnicity race
religion uh and the characteristics are
are so similar
and that to me is is uh is a very good
sign so kinds of things we deal with
have no sectarian nature about them
and and are a wonderful antidote I
believe to the poison of sectarianism
and tribalism and nationalism when taken
to an extreme as we see in many places
uh in the world so although that's not
that has never been my primary
motivation or even my motivation at all
it was the questions themselves I've
come to see that these questions do have
a salutatory effect in bringing people
together that I could never have
imagined I mean there are many people
who have my Same upbringings by saying
scientific training
the same
ethnicity
and who with whom I I have you know just
casual relationships on the other hand
there are people in the world of
completely different religious ethnicity
points of view who who I am unified with
in communication about these types of
subjects and I feel closer to them
because of the unification that we feel
in these kinds of topics so
um you know I've just I've just had that
since in the last couple of years maybe
since the pandemic actually which has
been a catalyst for that but to me it's
a sign it's a it's a a good sign of Hope
Which flies against a lot of the other
things we say
so
okay well thank you all for coming
speaking of bringing such a right tag
set of individuals who welcome thank you
all thank you all for coming I gotta let
you all go because I have to bring in
the next guest
and Chris I know that you have a toe
yourself and I would like to hear more
about your toe so if you could stay on
for another 15 minutes at some point if
you can
yeah all right thank you
good to see you congratulations
yeah thanks again spending your December
30th like some of your precious time I I
appreciate that thank you for waiting
like thank you thank you yeah happy
being here everybody happy new toe happy
new toe to all yeah
all right good night all right man
the next guest is home Kelleher thank
you home for waiting for so long look at
you
like a boss there well I'm actually uh
still at my day job which is
um in the background they're a big low
Institute for God there's just no
studies but
um yeah I asked for a projection behind
you in 20 minutes or so but uh I just
wanted to come on to
congratulate you for so many different
really good shows during the year
um it's it's been a really
um I think good year
and uh May 2023 be even better
thank you thank you so just so you know
Sam here who's the jockey more than just
that but today serving is the is the
is the mediator of all of this his
favorite episode on toe from 2022 was
yours
yours
oh that's down that's all right thank
you
so very gratifying thank you for coming
out Chris do you have any questions for
Coleman have you met each other
we almost did coma I just actually
tonight released a episode one if it was
a few weeks back uh in November uh Carl
Crusher
and Chris Bartel we came to your office
but we didn't want to come in with too
many people you know so I I waited
outside actually but uh they came in
just asked yeah to ask about Mount
Wilson Ranch we are on our way up to up
to Mount Wilson Ranch
uh basically because Bigelow owned it as
well and had Jack valet in Ingo Swann
and all the guys up there
um so basically looking at it Mount
Wilson Ranch uh for those of you who
don't know
um is
um up in uh near Pioche in Nevada about
a hundred and something miles north of
Las Vegas but uh part of our research
during the niz operation at the very
beginning of the news Operation was uh
to kind of split our time between
Skinwalker Ranch and also the Mount
Wilson Ranch and I can tell you that we
did not see a lot of uh unusual activity
up there but they were the best
absolutely best uh views of the Milky
Way galaxy I have ever seen in my life I
mean it's 8 000 feet up there and
there's really not a lot of ambient
light in the in the the near environment
and it was spectacular so we spent many
many cold nights out there especially
especially during the winter on Mount
Wilson Ranch and
um you know we had night vision
equipment which made stargazing even
more spectacular
um so it was it was a very enjoyable
time I'm
um obviously Chris Bartel and uh and his
uh his research friend but we're in my
office in my building there a few weeks
ago so I'm sorry I didn't meet you
yeah it would have been next that's
great to hear actually well well
obviously we're looking for Paranormal
Activity there as well but we're also
setting up uh camera systems
yeah hundreds of acres and so we can set
up you know kind of a at least three the
plan is at least three camera systems
you know so we can triangulate so
separated by some distance so hopefully
we'll at least we'll have eyes upward I
I don't know at this stage what the
living space is
um on the on the uh Mount Wilson range
but when I when we were up there when
niz was up there we had a
um a series of sort of small
um small cottage like buildings one of
which was reputedly haunted by this uh
Native American person
um
yeah several of us slept in that
particular room but none of us saw
anything
um it was
um
but
I I have fond memories of Mount Wilson
okay yeah excellent
interesting yeah it's a six Show episode
or miniseries so I'll be releasing it
out and then in the spring we plan to go
back and put up uh extra cameras so it'd
be nice yeah maybe I can interview you
if I'm coming through and I'll put it in
a plug yeah yeah absolutely I I uh I
really enjoy that
um I'd also uh like to get maybe at the
end of this
um a link to your to your uh release
yeah so it's Chris Leto or the Leto
files and I'll send that to you
personally comb so don't worry you don't
need to write it down okay great and
also I will put it on screen for people
who are interested and comb what what is
it that you're working on in 2022 that
we can promote right now so that I can
put a link on the screen for people who
are interested in following
well the
um
as you as you know from the last
interview we did with myself and George
with you uh we released a book just uh
about just about a year ago now just
slightly over a year ago called Skin
markers at the Pentagon that really was
um we thought it was the sort of
um correcting the record in quote
unquote on the uh the program with the
defense intelligence agency which was a
boots on the ground UFO investigative
program
um there is an audio version of that
book coming out in January
um which we're pretty happy with but
um we think that the the overall program
was the sort of the Genesis of a lot of
the activity that is uh that is ongoing
now because there's a direct linear
relationship between the OSAP program
and then the much smaller atip program
but even then leading into the the um
the UAP task force the the there was a
couple of generations of the UAP task
force that uh that were very much tied
in terms of lineage to the Osa program
the
um Advanced Aerospace Weapons Systems
application program which
um we ran from Las Vegas I was the
project manager in Las Vegas and then a
a ballistic missile physicist called
James T lakovski was the program manager
in in Washington so jointly we ran that
program
um over about a 27 month period and
during that time
it was mostly a boots on the ground
field investigative effort
um so we ended up hiring about 50
different people in a very short period
of time which you know has its pluses
and minuses
um and we
um we we did have investigators
um around the United States and also we
deployed investigators to Brazil at one
stage in order to
um really sort of come to grips with the
the UFO phenomenon we were mostly
interested in
um both sensor sensor driven data as
well as effects on people uh so we we
kind of ran two parallel programs one
was trying to capture uh sensor data and
the other was trying to capture
um effects on people and we had two MD
phds on staff that did a lot of that
um
medical injury investigation so
it was very much a sort of a Hands-On
boots on the ground effort and all of
the writing in terms of reports and all
of that had to be done after all of the
research was conducted so
um it was a lot of fun
um
but you know hopefully in 2023 there
will be some kind of light at the end of
the tunnel regarding
um
you know right regarding a new program
uh although you know as time goes on
um
I I must say I'm not as optimistic as I
was you know because I'm frequently
disappointed
every time I think the two 800 pound
gorillas in the room are the
ousdi and S I mean back back in the in
the day when we were investigating UFOs
uh with the defense intelligence agency
um that that particular organization the
Pentagon was plain old usdi under
secretary of defense for intelligence
but now it's the office of under
secretary for defense intelligence and
security
um we found that particular organization
less than
um Cooperative in sort of helping out on
the on the
um you know on the the bureaucratic red
tape uh front the second 800 pound
gorilla in the room is the United States
Air Force which has been notably
reticent in terms of of bringing forth
um additional data although you know
I've heard that there are there are you
know there's a better level of
cooperation than there was sort of a
year ago uh but you know for example
Frank Kendall the the secretary of the
Air Force recently came out with uh sort
of a series of statements that was not
exactly positive
um they're basically saying that that
they the USAF did not see any they're
there so therefore they're going to wait
for any evidence before putting any
muscle behind that and I I think there
are the two main organizations that have
uh their stakeholders in this whole
process in ushering this new office
um into some kind of productivity
so I'm I guess I'm I'm less
um less optimistic than I was nine
months ago because I think Congress can
do a lot and you know the recent passage
of the National Defense authorization
act
um which still needs uh authorization
bills to to pass uh but the recent
passage of the ndaa I think with the
with the appropriate language for
whistleblowers to come forth and all of
that I think that's a wait and see
because realistically a lot of the
intelligence agencies the defense
intelligence agency the Central
Intelligence Agency have their own ways
of doing this and whether or not they're
actually going to cooperate and sort of
lie down for a series of sort of
amnesties
um is is an open question I personally
think it's going to be a very slow
process
so John Ramirez on Martin Willis's
podcast which by the way as a plug
Martin Willis has a podcast called UFO
or sorry called The Martin Willis live
show maybe the live UFO show I'm I'm
sure I'm uncertain about the specific
name regardless there was a prediction
made
fairly adamantly by John Ramirez about
2027 being a day or sorry being a year
that's important for the UFO phenomenon
in particular that UFOs May land or
touchdown then so calm have you heard
anything of about this what do you make
of it
I've seen that scuttlebutt but I I have
not seen anything to substantiate it I
haven't seen anybody who I would sort of
um
class as a as an Insider's quote-unquote
uh come out with that I I've seen the
scuttlebutt but I honestly don't know
so what are you most grateful for man
from all this year all of this year 2022
well I I think actually 2022 was uh was
a banner year for sort of the unfolding
of uh of this program and uh not only
the the program but the level of
interest in the public
so
um and also i i s the reason I'm very
optimistic uh from what has happened in
2022 is that I think that there's more
and more uh people in the the so-called
Consciousness field
um that are beginning to take an
interest in the
um in the UFO field and the and this and
this idea that there's cross correlation
between the UFO field and uh paranormal
activity for example and Consciousness
um with people like Jeffrey [ __ ] uh
don Donald Hoffman Edward Kelly and
um you know there's a husband who
commented on UFOs as far as you know
um I'm Jeffrey kreifel certainly has
um Ed Kelly no but but
um I think Donald Huffman has been asked
uh that question numerous earlier he was
on
I'll ask him next time yeah yeah I mean
it would be really interesting because I
mean he's pushing the boundaries a lot
in terms of this whole
um this new paradigm in Consciousness
that is you know the Consciousness is
not necessarily the result of
biochemical trafficking in the in the
brain and that you know there's a lot
more to the story than than that and um
I see that as
um and people like Jeffrey [ __ ] from
Rice University who is kind of really
getting into a much higher profile with
uh linking in Consciousness and UFOs I
see that as very positive because
ultimately you know
um you can deploy sensors in the field
and we have a project has to land in
Norway is a very good example of that of
having
um having
sensors for 40 years but you know the
effects of UFOs on people the effects of
UFOs on people's perception and even on
their world view
um is something that really should be uh
run in parallel to the actual Gathering
of the physics and the engineering data
I I think there's room for both in this
whole field and I I would say there's
room for optimism certainly on on from
my perspective there's room for optimism
well calm I know that you got to get
going so do you have any
if you have a last question Chris to
post a comb then please do so if not
then Como will give you an outro uh do
you have any insights calm into who
could possibly be called if there are
public hearings or who I guess who would
you be most most excited to see
you know call to a public hearing
um that's a that's a pretty good
question
um
I I can tell you that a lot of the
people that were involved in the ASAP
program
um were very are where and are very much
um interested in this whole uh Arena
people like Hal putoff and Eric Davis
who were intimately involved in the ASAP
program
um I would not be in the least surprised
to see people like that
um
being asked to testify plus there's a
lot of different my information at least
is that there's a lot of people who are
willing to come forward uh whatever
um what effect that has I I really I
really don't know I I think the office
of the under secretary Professor
intelligence
um it's kind of like a wait and see
um situation
um but you know I I think
um
you know I think time will tell 2023
will will be an interesting year
comb thank you so much the book is
called Skin Walkers at the Pentagon and
the link will be in the description
thank you thank you for for spending the
end of the the end of your year with me
well I I really appreciate what you're
doing Kurt and uh I wish uh both of you
actually a and whoever's listening
um a great New Year hopefully
um the odd bottle of Guinness will be
cracked and you know so
this I'm from Trinidad ah nice this is
from this is apparently inFAMOUS or
famous among trinidadians this paradrex
I don't drink it well I know I do drink
it on the holidays but I'm well I'm
saying so holiday now Kurt yeah yeah
yeah
I I have this I'm not allowed
I have this this strange
it's like right well whatever I'm not
allowed to eat until after I I do the
majority of my work so we'll see we'll
see my wife is coming to pick me up
shortly so comb it's good to see you and
yeah
during the year uh yes yeah we'll talk
next year so I haven't asked anyone this
but
Have you listened to the theories of
everything podcast comb
like I know we've been on yeah Have you
listened to any of the podcasts I know
we've been on you've been on the podcast
but have you yes I I I've listened to a
couple of Donald Hoffman's
um uh podcasts and you know
um as usual they're sort of way I mean
they're they're exceptional really
exceptional I think you know both of you
interact really well thank you thank you
I was going to ask which one was which
one was your favorite that's yeah
I've gone back though I don't know if
you remember the uh particular podcast
he did at the very start at covid with
you
um it was it was
writing I guess our April 2020. I found
that exceptional too thank you
well me and you we're gonna create
an exceptional podcast together one that
exceeds the March 2020. one with Hoffman
so I look forward to that in 2023
and I look forward to what you produce
and also let your boss know let Bigelow
know that I would love to speak with him
on the podcast
yeah well you know in the background you
can see Bigelow Institute for
Consciousness studies right now we have
we have launched a grants program
um a funding program which is very rare
in this field of certain what's what's
called Survival Of Consciousness after
death and so we have launched a program
that's worth up to a million dollars
um it's going to be broken into multiple
different grants of a hundred thousand
dollars and fifty thousand dollars but
in terms of the the field it's an
injection of money into this field which
is badly needed uh for research so right
now what that's what I'm doing is is
managing that programming and getting
the launch
um going for that program so I see that
as as something that could have value in
2023
okay great
goodbye and thanks for coming on
nice talking to you and uh yeah I I'm
looking forward to uh to uh sing what
the uh the story is on Mount Wilson
Ranch the latest story
excellent all right thank you Chrome
nice to meet you
nice to meet you too
so Chris can you check your WhatsApp
yeah let me check
number two and just for everyone in the
chat eight hours it's now past eight
hours
I will be leaving in about 11 minutes
however I want trailer gold team and
Chris Leto I want us all to just hang
out
so welcome back Tyler Goldstein good to
be back so I can't believe this is eight
hours
yeah geez so who's been here for eight
hours in the chat please let us know who
are the Troopers
thank you Sam Sam's one of them Sam's
one of them
and anyway so just as an introduction I
don't think you all have met this is
Tyler Goldstein of the theory of
everyone which is a toe it's on toe and
Chris little you have your own tone
Chris little well I you have your own
YouTube channel as well so just
Chris meet Tyler Tyler meet Chris
nice to meet you nice to meet you
all right I just wanted to I just want
to hang out with you all that's all
right
what's your longest show up to now Kurt
I think it was seven and a half or eight
hours
so this is an interview yeah
that that went on for maybe eight and a
half and it was cut down to eight hours
or we had talked before we pressed
record or talked after we pressed record
but anyway that was like eight and a
half so this is
similar if not exceeding
who's that filmed in one stream or was
that too interesting yeah no that was
filmed at once and we could have kept
going except I had to meet my brother
there's some like their Emergency Family
emergencies I had to go downtown
immediately and I'm just looking at the
time and I'm like okay Leah like time is
money this is just one question it's
been like two hours can you but anyway I
love Leo and
and that was a that was an interesting
podcast
yeah so it definitely was
so Chris and Tyler do you mind
as difficult as I know this is extremely
difficult but can you condense your toes
into about two minutes and just say them
to one another I want to hear what your
perspectives are on on each other's
theories of everything
yeah forgive me I'm gonna be listening
but I just need to stretch and I'm going
to stretch here
cool okay I'll go I guess first Tyler if
you don't mind
yeah basically um it's an uh
observational Theory so basically the
theory is that we can see the dimensions
and it's all based on size
so if you go back if you think um it
could all be vibrations frequencies so
if we just look at size
and we look down into our our own
Dimensions you know as you go smaller
and smaller at every level we see life
essentially so replicating molecules
uh that basically emerge at each level
you know higher higher size level to us
right and I think that can be kind of
obvious if you use a microscope you know
back in in the 1700s and we found
microscopic life we were really
surprised that it was ordered you know
we would assume based on if this is the
the only Dimension essentially that
there shouldn't be order down low at
smaller Dimensions
um so I basically if you just build up
and don't stop at our Dimension you
continue looking up
then I would argue the argument is is
that just like the cells make up us they
live in our body and die in our body we
make up a cell in a larger organism
which I would call the Nations
essentially but you know there's many
different levels little tribes so
organizational Theory I guess going up
to the nation and then but basically why
stop there
uh So based off just the EMF diagram I
used an EMF diagram you know of how big
things are and if you notice if you look
on Google you cannot find any images
that go past the building size you know
basically 10 uh 10 to the third
size right so I just made it I continued
the chart
to go out all the way to the galactic
levels
you know when you have humans at 10 to
the 10 to the zero so we're at one meter
and then you go down and so I just laid
out all those scales and then I found
repeating patterns basically like
octaves along those scales so that's
that's basically the theory and I found
you had actually repeating patterns
based off of
um
uh the rule so rule of sevens
essentially so there was a number it
repeats very large 10 to the 21 zeros is
when the system actually repeats so that
that's basically summarization of the of
the theory
very interesting there's a lot of
similarities with my work as well
um I my work is uh I call it sentient
Singularity Theory and it's basically
that the totality of existence is like a
singularity of sentience that is
creating additional singularities within
itself or sentient beings and um but we
it also in some of my models I even have
Nation as a level above
uh humans as well that we are cells in
essentially a nation and uh it's it's
not as big as much based on size it's
more my work I tried to follow a lineage
um perspective I guess which parts go on
to make up larger part I guess larger
Parts but I try to avoid size actually
uh but it's it sounds very similar
so Glenn Glenn just commented and I just
want to say Glenn young that I emailed
you so please check your email and T car
I have I received what you said so thank
you so much that's just confirmation
sorry to interject and there's so like
man thank you it's not the end sounds
like the end but I just want to
interject just to thank you all again
for coming out
eight hours ten minutes eight hours 12
minutes and there are there have been so
here's the lineup so far for today
Ian mcgilchrist Michael Levin Don
Hoffman like that alone
that's enough then
Gary Nolan comes on then Andy from that
UFO podcast Dan from that UFO podcast
John for veggie Carlos from the stmf
Christina Gomez was here I'll be lobe
Garrett Vandenberg Anthony mativier Greg
Henry X Jesse Mitchells Chris little
Tyler Goldstein Lillian dindo came on
that I love that part
Daniel smonberger was supposed to come
on SO Daniel sorry you're you're not a
good guy in my books you said you were
coming you know you're borrowed from tow
so Shanna Jones I'm just kidding Daniel
Shoshanna came on Ross coldheart came on
rich and Amy came on Robert Kuhn came on
Lou
Angelus came on Daniel from active
inference geez comb Kelleher
what the heck
we're all a part of that isn't that nuts
do you ever look at what you do Tyler
and like you see the impact and same
Chris and and you're just thinking this
is it's just not only fun but like we're
so lucky
yeah it's been an amazing last two to
three years of watching this
I guess
field bloom
and this topic really catch on and go a
new Direction then it has uh you know in
decades prior
I think it's very exciting
yeah what do you think it's cool to go
around your you know really seems like
your channel has been a key Pivot Point
you know I to be honest I haven't
watched it in just the last month but I
go through periods where I'll really
pick up you know
real topics and watch like three hours
of your crazy long
crazy long interviews you know it's cool
to see this these interactions happening
what is it this is like a medical
conversation what is it that you think
is
the reason for the
increase in interest in theories of
everything not just let's say the toe
Channel itself
but the actual physics and Consciousness
topic
is much much more popular now I was
mentioning before I talked to Dr Dean
radden you know he's been in the the the
pseudoscientific realm for decades of
Consciousness you know just kind of
grinding when no one really paid
attention and he said it used to be that
you would have maybe one Consciousness
conference a year
and now they're every month
yeah well I'm asking him not yeah I'm
asking
what's
responsible for that
what do you attribute that to
Tyler do you have any ideas like is
there some event that happened is this
just a fad
a few decades
I think that it's it it has a lot to do
with the internet and um the rise of
long-form
podcasting and and uh interviews of
these topics and I think also as that
has happened
it's really become Apparent at least
from my perspective that
Consciousness I mean I try not to use
that word so much I try to use sentience
more but just because it's a bit more
defined but
um I think so I mean it's just it the
focus on feeling uh is
is more specific than I think
Consciousness tends to have just so many
different meanings depending on who
you're talking to and even how you're
using it even in the same person uh you
could say I'm conscious of that but I'm
also conscious
it's like there's that's two different
um
so it gets it gets a little complicated
in using it in a specific manner but I
think that just because it is becoming
apparent that you can't separate that
under understanding what is you know
mind essentially from this you from any
kind of unification of fields uh because
we're the ones you know observing and
and maneuvering these fields
it's made it also a lot more
universally appealing to people because
we are it's all it's become much more
about understanding ourselves I think
and that has made it very popular
it just feels like there's been a mental
phase shift
and I think kovid kind of started it
kind of pushed people down the path and
essentially I think we're at least I my
audience is U.S Centric you know it's
half half from the U.S
and it just seems like there's kind of
been a mental Shake where
you know we don't know everything
whereas before I think you had a lot of
there's a lot of uh anomalies in all of
these fields you know you the quantum uh
the Double set experiment you know you
can mention any Consciousness
experiments there's kind of these
anomalies where I think they've just
mainstream science been kind of ignoring
them
but now that it's piecing together as
we've kind of reached a
you know the snowball's built up to be
large enough to now where people are
like maybe I should go check that out
you know maybe
maybe the some of these conspiracy
theories actually do hold water you know
like I said earlier they all there are
some valid conspiracy theories so I
don't know it seems like I think people
are just more open-minded
they're kind of curious what's what's
out there and what could be out there
it's exciting for me I find it very
exciting
yeah hey someone's come to say hi and
it's going to be the last one
Daniel did you hear me bar you from toe
and then you you're like okay let me
just get on right now this is I don't I
don't want to be in Kurt's bad side
Daniel you're muted
hello hello
no can't hear you
it's Bard no yeah yeah rejected and
kicking out nope sorry it's too late I'm
just kidding kidding around
so my wife will be here shortly so
here's the schedule while Daniel is
working out the Kinks Tyler and Chris I
just I'm gonna say bye to you but after
Daniel is here and then I'll speak to
the audience for a bit to you all I just
I don't even like calling it The
Audience or you all I feel like that's
so impersonal I just want to list you
each by name so the memes of Destruction
candidate candidate Joseph M T Carr
Jacob loyal Nancy pulley hi by me you
Ronald
digital content Richard Cliff Kurt
another Curt Barack so thank you all I I
want to know what is it well what are
you almost grateful for everyone who's
who's why don't you list what are you
grateful for from 2022 and okay Daniel
seems to be gone so so either way I want
to say like it's an honor it's a
pleasure to spend my last public minutes
with you all for the year
Tyler you put out so much content like a
meta commentary on toes and I appreciate
that and Chris you've done so much for
the UFO the UAP I was going to say
industry it's not industry field
industry well some people think it is
but I'm a big fan thank you thanks yeah
thank you all for for being here it
seems like Daniel's gone so
at least Daniel appeared so we can add
Daniel schmuttenberger to that geez you
didn't hear him but
okay all right
thank you Tyler thank you Chris
have a good night and please give and
just say goodbye to the audience as well
and then leave and I'll say goodbye to
the audience after
or I'll go yeah I'd like to say I am
grateful man this this past year kind of
a much more positive uh I have a much
more positive outlook on the life uh on
life in general you know and I think a
lot of that's just from I see the world
moving in in a better Direction you know
I think a lot of people are really
Doom and Gloom these days but I think uh
a lot of it starts inside internally and
I think mentally we're going the right
direction so I'm excited I'm really
excited for 2023 thanks for having me on
and happy New Year to everybody nice to
meet you Tyler thanks for coming on
Chris and Tyler Tyler Goldstein theory
of every one one spelled with a zero and
E and again I'll link this all in the
description
yeah I'm uh I'm just very grateful for
uh
just this I mean a lot of things this
year
um you know family this this
uh experience that and this uh
for your channel for just the changing
conversation that's been happening over
all of this and I also am very
optimistic um like Chris said it's there
seems to be a lot of Doom and Gloom but
at the same time there's it's there's a
lot of change happening and there's a
lot of opportunity and change so very
grateful and looking forward to 2023
Daniel it's good to meet you
I believe I can hear you now no still
can't hear you hold try again
okay that's okay
that's okay Daniel why don't you just
well I don't know what to do I don't
know sign language it was
gonna have to be the way it is yeah okay
it's gonna have to be like this so I'm
gonna just say Daniel it's a pleasure to
meet you even though we didn't get to
actually meet see if you can work out
your sound issues it'd be great if I
could we could just hear your voice
we'll spend another couple minutes
everyone here can we wait another couple
minutes
or do you want
no we'll wait
beautiful podcast thank you
thank you Joanna I'll just be thinking
in the chats
Thor I can read lips so you can at least
speak to Thor here
now I am become deaf
thank you thank you
David thank you
thank you thank you thank you all thank
you all
Daniel
no Tyler Tyler stay on until
I kick you out okay I think it's fine if
you don't mind no I don't mind that's
fine
just didn't want to intrude
I I'm about now I think it'd be nice for
us all to just there we go
there we go it comes with the like the
voice all right oh my goodness I'm so
sorry about that
that's all right it's good to meet you
yeah it's good to uh meet you live as
well
and uh Tyler good to meet you and I
don't I don't see everybody else here on
my screen
there is no one else there's 800 other
880 other people watching live right now
but essentially we're just saying good
night goodbye and I I would love to go
in deeper with you and talk about
well several subjects that we've talked
about over email
but for now why don't you just say what
you're most grateful for for 2022 and
what you're looking forward to in 2023
um
foreign
I'll say it in context to this situation
here
um
oftentimes I talk about some of the
risks that novel types of Technology
create but that doesn't mean that they
don't also create lots of awesome
capabilities and so
you using the ability to broadcast and
bring people together to advance
people's understanding of how we more
deeply understand the Universe I think
is a sign of something pretty awesome
that there are networks of affinity that
are coming together
to be able to have the deepest thinking
across disciplines oriented to the most
important topics and able to have
Community emerge globally around that I
think that's something pretty exciting
and um
I think I I appreciate seeing Theory of
Everything not be limited to
mathematical physics but uh you know
having people thinking about
phenomenology and semiotics and all
those things my work appreciates those
topics but doesn't do anything novel in
them
um
is novel
I said even taking what's disparate and
putting together in a putting together
firstly is novel obviously putting
together in a new ways novel but if you
take what's never been put together it's
automatically new
and I um
most of my focus for a while has been a
kind of Integrative Endeavor across the
various risks Humanity faces as a kind
of integrated set of design criteria for
how to do civilization design
and um I think
a number of the people who are in your
space have an interest that goes from
the purely theoretical how does the
universe work to is there applied side
on how we design a better human world uh
that's a topic that maybe we'll get to
discuss in 2023 yeah we will we will and
I'm looking forward to it
So Daniel yeah that's it Daniel thank
you for coming schmattenberger and Tyler
Goldstein thank you for being here thank
you for wrapping the year with me that's
like that's it's incredible thank you
yeah cool to touch base for a moment
yeah okay now before you go I was asking
I only asked this of calm but I'm
curious so if you've listened to the
toll podcast which one of the past year
is your is
one that you like the most
and same Tyler like which ones which one
stands out most to you for whatever
reason
I have not got to listen to enough of
them in full to speak to that I would
like to it's actually high on my list
um the fact that you
did um some kind of uh
formal logic idealism from information
Theory I thought was really cool
um because most of the people who argue
against physicalism usually have to do
it in a pretty informal way
um so Castro up and folks like that and
uh
and then the fact that you also got to
things that were more focused on the
integrative epistemology like the theory
of knowledge rather than just kind of
the ontology Theory of Everything
um so I I would say rather than which
one I like the most I liked uh the
breadth of the topics that you included
in that scope
thanks
I uh I really liked uh Carl friston's uh
podcast with you and um or stream with
you I thought it was it's one I watched
multiple times and it was just very
I probably both I know I've seen both I
think and it's they're kind of blur at
this point but
um but just his being introduced to his
work
um was was fascinating
well very important
I'm super grateful for you both when I
think about what am I most grateful for
for 2022 it's it's number one it's my
wife and number two even just the other
day I was standing here and I was
looking at
we have an editor and we have an
operations manager and I'm just thinking
like man oh man like it just hit me like
this is darn cool that I get to do this
holy moly okay I think if I was to truly
appreciate it it would just bring me to
tears and I wouldn't be able to to move
so I have to take into small dosage
but anyway thank you thank you thank you
Dad I would say you have about as cool a
job as exists and you made it so yeah I
think that's that's a good lesson for
everybody about possibility
yeah yeah it's it's super cool yeah
yeah well anyway we'll talk some more
Daniel and Tyler
have a good New Year likewise thank you
Happy New Year
okay let's see okay I just want to say
thank you to all of you who are watching
my wife is
out here somewhere she told she told me
she's waiting in the parking lot so
Glenn younger
I invited you on the stream just so you
know Glenn and it's okay next time next
time okay it's it's getting quite late
here there's this light here that's in
my face and it may affect my sleep but
will most likely will affect my sleep so
I better turn it off
in fact Sam can you can you turn it off
let's get some mood lighting in
wow
wow here we go go to bed yes well I'm
gonna eat I'm gonna eat oh my gosh
ravenously with my wife and just like a
glut and it's a pleasure and it's a
privilege thank you all thank you all
for coming out to this thank you Sam
everyone thanks Sam who's been behind
here the the jockey please I'm not
leaving until I see at least 10 thank
yous for Sam thanks Sammy thanks thanks
Sam thanks okay there's enough stamps
all right that's too much now I'm
getting jealous all right
thank you all thank you all for coming
out take care all right thank you thank
you so much for watching eight and a
half hours it was actually nine hours
because we came on a half hour early we
were just testing out behind the scenes
regardless essentially a nine hour long
live stream from start to finish you're
here thank you so much thank you for
watching for reading for listening for
commenting again if you'd like to see
more content like this then go to
patreon.com Kurt jymungal there's no
obligation all of Toad's content is free
if you'd like to contribute completely
voluntarily then visit that website
patreon.com Curt jymungal
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l and contribute
with whatever you can either way your
viewership your listenership your
commenting is more than thanks enough
the fact that you care the fact that
you're watching you're still watching
you're still listening I'm just gonna
sit here
you're still watching you're still
listening thank you thank you so much
enjoy the New Year welcome to the new
year thank you and take care
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]